LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT ON
PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT OUR
HEARINGS. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE WITNESSES ON THE BILLS FOR
THIS HEARING ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
LAST HEARING NEXT WEEK WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE LESS THAN
IDEAL FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY BUT
WE NEED THE NAMES AND WITNESSES
OF WITNESSES IN ADVANCE. FOR
NEXT WEEK'S HEARING WE NEED THE
NAMES OF FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION BY THURSDAY AT THE
END OF THE DAY. PLEASE CHECK
WITH OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS NO EXCEPTIONS WILL
BE MADE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION WE HOPE AUTHORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS ARE RESPECTFUL IN
THIS PROCESS. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING. DUE TO THE CONTINUED
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WORN IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM WHERE THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE WE DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE HAVE SO A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. TODAY IN THE
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WE CAN
ONLY A COMEDY TO MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF. AND
UNLIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING- ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
PRO. PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC
TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL
AND FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM.
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. WOULD ASK THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
FISCAL DISTANCING UPON LEAVING
THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE
TAKEN UP IN THE ORDER LISTED ON
THE AGE. GENDER AND THAT AND IN
THE DAILY FILE WITH MEMBERS WHO
ARE NOT ON THE COMMITTEE FIRST.
IN ALPHABETICAL ORDER. AND THEN
MEMBERS WHO ARE IN THE CAR ON
THE COMMITTEE AND- ALSO IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER WITH THE
CHAIR PRESENTING LAST. FOR WITH
FOR VIDEO WITNESSES IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN ASCERTAIN. THAT WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
THEM QUESTIONS. LOSS OF USE IN
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO.
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND IN THE DAILY FILE.
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN. PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
HIS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. AND ALSO
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE LIMITED ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
HE'S ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOU ARE
MAIN WITNESS. IF YOU WERE MY
MAIN WITNESS TO PROVIDING TEST
FOR IT TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL. YOU REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE IT WILL BE NEAT NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED UPON TO SPEAK. YOU'RE
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE SEVEN AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. I
ALSO WANT TO KNOW WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE LEAD POSITION LETTER PORTAL
WITH INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. YOU CAN
FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE
COMMITTEE THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS A AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE. TO
RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION PROVIDE A COMMENT
YOU'LL NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATE IT WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP. AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WHILE SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND CAN BE RECORDED. IN
FAIRNESS TO EVERYONE TODAY. WE
WILL BE ESPECIALLY STRICT ON
TIME LIMITS WE WILL HEAR FROM
UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE. AFTER
THE TWO MAIN WITNESSES FOR EACH
SIDE TESTIFIED. IF THERE ARE
ANY WE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
AND PROVIDE COMBINED ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. THESE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY
FOR TODAY'S HEARING AND A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
REMOVE THE BILL FROM CONSENT. I
REMEMBER FOR AB FIVE SIXTY
THREE BY MR BERMAN. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB TEN FORTY SIX BY
MISS BLANCA RUBIO. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY. AND AB
AND IT- NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHTY FIVE. FOR
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. THE WITH
THAT LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST BILL- SEE THE
AUTHOR IS HERE- MISTER K. HAND.
THAT WAS THE WRONG LIST SENATE
MY LAST. ALL RIGHT HANG ON
SECOND WITH A DIFFERENT LAST
YEAR. THAT WOULD BE THAT THAT'S
THE THAT THAT MAY BE THE ONLY
MISTAKE THAT HAPPENS OR A
ANYTHING TO HAPPEN TODAY SO
ANYWAY- THE REAL. TO THE IS-
ITEM NUMBER TWO. EIGHT NINE TEN
FIFTY MISTER BENNETT. HM I
NUMBER ELEVEN AB SEVEN NINE
MISTER. AN ITEM NUMBER. AB
THREE EIGHTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS SO WITH THAT. I
THINK WE CAN START THIS IS A
AHEAD MR K. YOU HAVE A NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBER I WANT TO START BY
THINK WE CAN MEET. AND STAFF
FOR PUTTING IN SO MUCH TIME IN
FIVE INTO ENSURING THIS
TRANSFER PIECE OF LEAD THAT SHE
ALL OF ITS INTENT GOALS WE LOOK
FOR CONTINUE. WORKING WITH THE
KERR. AND SO INCLUDING CAN'T
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AT
THIS BILL MAY FORWARD. LAST
YEAR UNION PASSED AND THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE HOTLINE DESIGNATION ACT
ESTABLISHING NINE EIGHT EIGHT
AS THE NEW THREE DIGIT
ALTERNATIVE TO NINE ONE ONE FOR
SUICIDE AND MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. STATES ARE NOW WORKING
TO IMPLEMENT THE NINETY DAY
SYSTEM BY JULY OF. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHEN I NEED IT GOES
LIVE. AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT ALSO
KNOWN AS THE MILES CALL
LIFELINE. IMPLEMENTS THE NEW
NINETY DAYS. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH AROUND THE
CLOCK MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
CARE. THE BILL RESTS ON THREE
CRITICAL PILLARS A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS RESPONSE. TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN ACCESS TO CRISIS
COUNSELING THROUGH CALL TEXT
AND CHAT. THE DEPLOYMENT OF
MOBILE CRISIS TEAMS STAFFED BY
TRAINED MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND PEERS. TO
RESPOND TO CRISIS INSTEAD OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND ACCESS TO
CRISIS RECEIVING AND
STABILIZATION SERVICES. SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS AND MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AREN'T LEFT TO LANGUISH
IN OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS OR JAIL.
WELL EACH COMPONENT OF THIS
CRISIS CONTINUE I'M IS EQUALLY
VALUABLE AND DESPERATELY NEEDED
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO IGNORE THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR MOBILE CRISIS
TEAMS. SENATE TESTIMONY IN
DEREK JARMAN'S TRIAL FOR THE
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD BEGAN ON
MARCH TWENTY NINTH MORE THAN
THREE PEOPLE A DAY HAVE DIED AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE NEW YORK TIMES HAS
IDENTIFIED SIXTY FOUR FATAL
ENCOUNTERS. MORE THAN A DOZEN
OF WHOM WERE MENTALLY ILL OR IN
THE THROES OF A MENTAL
BREAKDOWN. TRAGICALLY THIS IS
NOT AN ANOMALY. AS A DIRECT
pCONSEQUENCE OF OUR OVER
RELIANCE ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. APPROXIMATELY 25% OF
ALL INDIVIDUALS KILLED IN
POLICE INVOLVED SHOOTINGS IS
TWENTY FIVE. TWENTY FIFTEEN HOW
TO KNOWN MENTAL ILLNESS. WITH
BLACK MEN DYING
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IS NINE
EIGHT EIGHT TAKES A MONUMENTAL
STEP FORWARD IN ADDRESSING THE
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES IN OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM BY
DECRIMINALIZING OUR RESPONSE TO
MENTAL HEALTH. IN DISMANTLING A
MAJOR SOURCE OF SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICE. WITH ME TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
EIGHT IS THANH HALL. MOTHER OF
MILES HALL THE BILL'S NAMESAKE.
MILES WITH A WONDERFUL YOUNG
MAN WHO LIVED IN MY COMMUNITY
WHO DIED AT THE HANDS OF POLICE
WELL IN THE THROES OF MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. THIS BILL WILL
GO A LONG WAY IN ENSURING. THAT
MEN LIKE MILES HAVE A FUTURE.
AND ALSO WITH ME ARE TERRIBLE
EASTMAN FROM THE STEINBERG
INSTEAD. MISTER THANK YOU TO
OUR MODERATOR PLEASE- OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND WHEN
YOU WITH OTHER WITNESSES LINES
ARE. THESE GOOD. HUTCHER NUMBER
NEAR ME YES MA'AM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU HI
JEREMY MY NAME IS TOM I'M AND I
AM HERE BOTH OF THE FOUNDER OF
THE OFF. ECHO SPONSOR THE BILL
AND OF MY MOM BERMAN. THE MOUNT
PUBLIC LAND NAMES AND SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE GERMAN AMOUNT
OF SUPPORT THIS BILL AMONG THE
COMMITTEE AND FOR THE OFFICE TO
SHARE MY FAMILY WITH TODAY. ON
JUNE SECOND TWO NINE NINETY SON
WAS AND KILLED BY THE WATER
CREEK PLEASE DEPARTMENT NOW
LET'S GET THE JUST SORT I
EVERYTHING I COULD TO HELP. BUT
THE COMPLETE LACK OF A MENTAL
THANK YOU LET ME KNOW TO TURN
IN A CAR EXCEPT THE POLICE. FOR
YOUR THAT TO WORK WITH ONE OF
THE LEAST OF. TO SUPPORT MILES
THANK IN STATE BUT THEY MY
HEALTH CALL THE ALERT THEM THAT
HE WAS THE ONE AND THEY SHOULD
EXPECT. MEADOW GARDEN TOOLS THE
POLICE OFFICERS WHO RESPONDED
SHOUTED AT MILE THROUGH THE
WEAPON AND FIRE. THE LAST MILE
THE BEST BEEN OUR BIGGEST CAR.
BACK IN THE FOR OUR COUNT WITH
THE COUNTLESS FAMILY LIKE OURS.
FAMILY BUT IF THAT FOR THAT
COME FROM TO HELP LEVEL OF THE
A CRISIS AND REALIZING WE HAVE
WAY TO TURN. IT TIME FOR
GOVERNOR TO PART HI BUILDING A
MENTAL SYSTEM TRULY HELP YOU
LIKE MY- IT'S PAST THE MOUTH
HOW LIFE MIGHT NOT BE ALLOWED
CAL. LUCERNE IS VERY MENTAL
HEALTH DISTRESS OR WITNESSES
SOMEONE IN DISTRESS TO CALL ONE
EASY TO PHONE. NINE EIGHT EIGHT
AND GET THE HELP SEVEN NINE
EIGHT EIGHT HAD EXISTENCE THE
AWFUL DAY INTO NINE. THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSION ADDED FUNDED
SMILED AT THE POLICE TO GET
CHANCE YOU BE A LOT. IS MY
MISSION MAKES THAT NO OTHER
FAMILY HAS SEVEN FACT OF.
ACTUALLY REQUESTED A IN A VOTE.
AND WOULD. FOR THE MAHALAYA ACT.
PERFECT HARD GAMBLE EASTMAN
WITH THE STEINBERG AND CUTE.
WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT NON PROFIT
PUBLIC POLICY IF YOU. OKAY TO
ADVANCE SOUND PUBLIC POLICY AND
INSPIRE METER SHIP ON THE ISSUE
THE BRAIN HEALTH. AND WE ARE
VERY PROUD OF DR EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ECHO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE HAND AND SAY THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE. STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ENGAGEMENT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE DISCUSSION TO
ENSURE THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT THE
SIMPSONS THAT THEY SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE MENTAL. HEALTH
CRISIS- THE NATIONAL BY DOES
THE HOT OF THE DAY AFTER GIVEN.
AND ON ABOUT UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY. TO DO THAT A WE-
OF. AND COULD. MAN HEALTH
PRACTICES. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT WITH PARTNERS WITH THE
THREE FOR AND THREE FOR
ADMINISTERING THE NINE EIGHT
EIGHT THE BAN NATIONWIDE THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE I THINK IF YOU CAN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION THIS
ONGOING PARTNERSHIP HAVE
ENSURED THAT THE LANGUAGE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY EIGHT EIGHT.
NOT ONLY REFLECT THE FEDERAL
MANDATE BUT ALSO THE INTENDED
VISION FOR THE NATIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM. BY CLICKING ME.
ENCUMBERED CAN DIGIT HE WAS AND
HEALTH PROBLEMS I CAUGHT
WEARING. ET NUMBER THREE DIGIT
NUMBER CALIFORNIANS MAY CRISIS
WILL KNOW HOPE IS ONLY ONE CALL
AWAY. BY LEAKING CALLERS WITH
APPROPRIATE LOCAL RESOURCES
WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
IN CRISIS ON THEIR LONG TERM.
RECOVERY AND WELLNESS JOURNEY.
WE THE PUBLIC IN A HAS THIS
MANDATED. DATE OF JULY TWENTY
TWENTY Q. WHILE CREATING THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THIS LEVEL OF THE
FORM OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN
MONTHS IS INFECTIOUS. IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY- DUE TO
EXTRAORDINARY FEDERAL
INVESTMENT. AMERICAN RAP THE
PLAN INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL FUNDING TO DEVELOP THAT
WITH THEM IT INCLUDED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS TO
START BUILDING A PROGRAM AND
ENHANCED MEDICAID FUNDING THAT
WILL TAKE 85% OF THE COST TO
OPERATE MODEL RIGHT. AND THERE
IS TALK ABOUT MORE FUNDING IS
ON THE WAY. FAILURE TO PASS
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT NOW
COULD LOCK CALIFORNIA OUT OF
ACCESSING THESE RESOURCES INTO
NOT BEING A MEDICAID EXPANSION
STATE UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT. BUT THE PRICE OF AN ACTION
IS MORE THAN LOS DOLLARS WE
WILL BE FAILING CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHO HAVE NOWHERE%
ELSE TO TURN. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE FOR THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. FIGURING OUT ALL OF
THAT. SO MIST- MR MODERATOR
PLEASE WE'RE GOING TO NOW GO
TO- THERE'S IN SUPPORT AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY REGISTERED
AS A WITNESS FOR UP FOR
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THOSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND WILL JUST BE
ASKING FOR THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER ROBERT REITER.
RESTAURANT PRAYER CAN YOU HEAR
US. ALL THE THAT WAS ON MUTE
OUR FIRST LINE IS LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD NINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. OUR NEXT LINE COMES
FROM THE LINE ONE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
G. AND YOU CALLING FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU- NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT CALLER IS
LINE TO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
THANKS REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE PASSCODE BUNKERS AT EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT CALLER'S LINE. TO
SIXTY ONE. IT SEEMS LIKE THEY
DROPPED OUR NEXT CALLER THIS
FROM LINE TO SIXTY FIVE. GOOD MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS THERMIC EIGHTEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE ARE
A STRONG SUPPORTER BUT THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED WE WANT TO
THANK THE FABRIC OF THE PEOPLE
WERE- WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BE ABLE HELP
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION TO MAKE
THE BILL. IMPLEMENTABLE BY-
JANUARY- TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
JUST STRONG SUPPORT TO CONTACT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE CARE
MEMBERS TERAFLOPS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA. HEALTH NETWORK
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I NEXT TO
THEM THE NUMBER ONE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RHONDA WALKER AND I WORK FOR
AN ORGANIZATION THE AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER FORTY
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION A
PSYCHIATRIST IN CALIFORNIA
HAVING A CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY I SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MORE TALK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LOCKSMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY NUMBER ASSOCIATION IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME FOR JUST
FIFTEEN SECONDS WE DO SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL I WE'VE
APPRECIATED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OFFICE STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS. IF YOU BELIEVE THE
BILL WOULD BE STRENGTHENED BY
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE THAT WOULD
WORK WITH THE CALORIE **** IN
THE EXISTING NINE ONE ONE
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST SET UP THE
NINETY EIGHT SYSTEM- THIS IS
GOING TO BE AT A TECHNICALLY
CHALLENGING INTEGRATION AS
CALLS WILL COME INTO ONE PLACE
AND THE OTHER. NEED TO BE
ROUTED BACK AND FORTH SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW THE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER THERE BRIDGE
ON THE TOP OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
IT'S GOING PLEASE. WELL NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO BE NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT- YOU. MOVED TO NUMBER
ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I AM HEIDI STRUNK
REPRESENTING. I MEAN MENTAL
HEALTH AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING IN STRONG SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AN AMATEUR IS HERE
WHERE WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
THE QUEUE REMAINING OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU- NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE HE'S GOT
A- I. HAVE WILL COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK
ACTIVE SPONSORS AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE SUPPORTED
RENDON THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE WHITE
HIM ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AN EXCELLENT OF THE
NUMBER TEN THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS TIBETAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THE COR COMMUNITY BUNDY
HAPPENS EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU I'LL TALK FOR
NUDITY CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION FOR IN A SUPPORT
IT'S AMENDED POSITION LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON CERTAIN
POINT BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER
TWO FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER CALLING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHEN I GO
TO NUMBER TWO TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN ABA LOS AND I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER TWO
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO. THE
MEASURE NUMBERS CHANGE MONSTER
HERE ON BEHALF OF STOCKTON
HOUSE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS SHELBY YOU'RE
VERY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION
ANYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
NUMBER TWO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
HELP. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
WOULDN'T ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS DEANNA CALLING TWENTY I
AM ABSOLUTELY DOES. AND I WOULD
JUST AS FRIENDS WORKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
EIGHT CRISIS RESPONSE TEAMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER TWO
SIXTEEN WE'VE GOT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS BEN
AB ON BEHALF OF WELL SPACE HELP
SUICIDE PREVENTION CRISIS
CENTER AND INSTRUCTOR DR LEE
AND WECHT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETY DAY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THERE MY NAME IS SAM
BRINTON I USE THE PRONOUNS THEY
AND THEM AND I THIRD FOR THE
TREVOR PROJECT WE ARE IN FRONT
OF THE PORT OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AND THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS BARBERSHOP FROM THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION SAN DIEGO CHAPTER
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT EIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY THIRTY
FOUR LINE IS OPEN. I APOLOGIZE
THIS IS AND GPS ON BEHALF OF
ESTATE CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE A
LATE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR I LOVE
THE SPONSORS ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JOHN
CARPENTER AND WITH THE GROUP
TRUTH LOVE JUSTICE IS MY
THIRTIETH YEAR THE TRIAL ARE
REPRESENTING PEOPLE INCLUDING
PEOPLE OF LOST LOVED ONES WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES YOU DO NOT
AMONG CALLS GONE WRONG. GEN
WHILE I SUCCESS THIS IS RON
WHAT IS YOUR NAME AND POSITION
PLEASE. JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
TO NINETY TWO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A TWO NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALLOCATIVE DROPPED
FROM THE QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU.
IN LATE JONAS ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINE EIGHTY EIGHT THIS PRESS
ONE ZERO. HOW WE CAN GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY THREE- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THAT SO I
MEAN AS ON BEHALF OF THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES OF DUBLIN
LIVERMORE PLEASANTON SAN RAMON
AND THE TOWN OF DANVILLE AS
WELL AS THE CITY OF SAN PABLO
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THE NEXT WILL BE
GOING ONLINE TO SEVENTY SIX-
LINE TO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE OR THINK IT BECAME
A FORM A CO SPONSORED AB NIGHT
EXPRESSING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALEX
BIRD AND I'M FROM THE B.
GREATER SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
AMERICAN FOUNDATION GIVES BIRTH
TO THE CONVENTION AND I AM AND
AS STRONG SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ACTUALLY GOING
TO LINE TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
WOULD ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME
IS ROBERT COLLINS- I'M WORKING
FOR JUSTICE FRENCH LOOKING
FOLKS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MILE CALLED MY FRIEND ACT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE TO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES KIM
GROSS ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
CONTRA COSTA WHICH IS A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE TO
SEVENTY EIGHT WE'VE GOT A- HI
ERIN DALTON CASE MANAGER WITH
REDWOOD COMMUNITY SERVICES IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND I AM
VOICING STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS WAQAR FIREFOX ALLEN I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
MANZANITA SERVICES THING YOU
KAYAK CALIFORNIA WE'RE A FULL
SERVICE MEDAL HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WEARING SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO THE LINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS CHALLENGING CAN AND
I AM A SURVIVOR AND A VOLUNTEER
WITH EVERYTOWN SURVIVOR NETWORK
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IN LINE TO EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DR CREEK CAMPBELL CHAIN AND I'M
A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE EIGHT EIGHT THE MILE CALL
LIFELINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN
LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNA
CONNOR AND I'M A STUDENT
VOLUNTEER WITH MANTA ACTION
CALLING CARD OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. YOUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. HI NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN JONES I'M A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE LINE TO A ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
CAROL ROGERS AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH EVERYTOWN
SURVIVOR NETWORK CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS DOMINIC
THEY WORK THERE YEAH OKAY- VERY
ORGANIZATIONS. END OF THE ON
THE COURT. EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BORDERLINE TO SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO HI MORGAN
CALLING CALLING WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY AND INLAND EMPIRE DESERT
THE CHAPTERS OF THE AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE EIGHT
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE LINED
TO NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOULD AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TERESA FERNANDEZ I'M WITH
JUSTICE AND LOOKING TO GO IN
AND SHOW SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
NINETY EIGHT CRISIS RESPONSE
TEAMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
QUESTION NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT IN LINE TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH HI MY
NAME IS ADAM EXCITING ABOUT THE
WE CAN PLUG JUSTICE SHE GOT CUT
OFF THE CALL EARLIER COMMON GUT
FEELING THIS ONE TO SAY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU- WE HAVE SOMEONE IN
THE- GALLERY WISHING TO. YES
THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN WOULD HAVE
MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AS
RECOGNIZED IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO I'M GONNA ASK-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HERE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW. BONTA. NO
WE JUST ARE YOU OPPOSED TO
BEING HERE JUST OPPOSED. THANK.
I THINK HE'S HERE HELLO IS HERE
BONTA. BURKE. WE DON'T KNOW
WHO'S HERE AND WHO'S WHATEVER
OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD CARILLO.
LARA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON. YEAH I HAVE A
FARM WHERE WE HAVE A WELL OILED
QUORUM HERE SO. TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
MISTER VICE CHAIR. HEY I KNOW
THAT- WE DIDN'T HEAR FOM- THE
TABLE GOOD COMMUNICATIONS OF
FOLKS- THEY DO HAVE AT PROVIDE
US A LETTER- IN OPPOSITION
WITH. A NINE OR TEN DIFFERENT-
REASONS WHY THEY WANTED TO
OPPOSE- AND I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF WHAT AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
THEY MIGHT BE INTERESTED. IN I
DID NOTICE THAT THIS NINE EIGHT
WAS ACTUALLY STATUS THAT SIGNED
INTO LAW BY- BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT- AND- AND I GUESS
THIS IS JUST A STATE BY STATE
OF US IN ACTING IT BUBBLE WHY.
A WHITE WHY OPPOSE THIS IF IT
WOULD BE OKAY TO BE ABLE TO
ASK- MISTER ROSCOE. THANK YOU
JUST A MOMENT MAYES. THE CABLE
INDUSTRY WE'RE VERY SUPPORT OF
THE PROGRAM THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING ITS FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OUR ONLY CONCERN IS DEALING
WITH THE- COLLECTION OF THE
SURCHARGE- THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. IT DOES NOT
PARALLEL WHAT WAS SUGGESTED BY
THE FCC. AT THE COMPARISON HAS
BEEN MADE THAT THIS IS SIMILAR
TO NINE ONE ONE. IN THE NINE
ONE ONE COLLECTION OF THE
SURCHARGE WE DON'T PAY FOR THE
POLICE AND FIRE AND AMBULANCE
THAT RESPOND. TO EMERGENCIES
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
WOULD REQUIRE THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE INVOICED
CUSTOMERS PAY AN ADDITIONAL
SURCHARGE TO NOT ONLY CONNECT
THE CALL WHICH IS WHAT NINE ONE
ONE DOES. BUT IT IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDE THE ACTUAL SERVICES. SO
THE AS WRITTEN IT'S- VERY VERY
BROAD. AND WOULD INCREASE AT A
SIGNIFICANT SURCHARGE TO ALL
VOIGTS CUSTOMERS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND FOR THAT WE WOULD.
HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE OUT
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS AND REQUEST
THAT YOU LIMIT. AS A NINE ONE
ONE SURCHARGE IS LIMITED. THANK
YOU AND IF I CAN MISTER CHAIR I
REALIZE THIS IS THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE THIS IS NOT- THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAS.
JURISDICTION OVER A TELECOM
BUT- MISS ROSS ACTUALLY TO MAKE
THE ACT OUT IT'S ANOTHER
QUESTION IF I IF I CAN'T IF WE
SIT DOWN- AND THE QUESTION THAT
I ACTUALLY HAVE BECAUSE I
RECENTLY SET. A SET UP. A NEW
TELEPHONE AND INTERNET. SERVICE
THROUGH A- A TELECOM COMPANY.
AND THE BILL CAME AND THEY TOLD
ME OVER THE PHONE AFTER BEING
ON THE PHONE WITH THEM FOR
ABOUT FROM ABOUT FORTY MINUTES.
AND THE THEY SAID I WAS GOING
TO BE A HUNDRED AND. FIFTY
DOLLARS A MONTH SO GREAT. THAT
GREAT. AND THEN I GET FIRST
BILL AND IT'S A HUNDRED FOUR TO
A MONTH. A AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
OVER THIRTY PER. OF WHAT I WAS
TOLD THE COSTS WERE IT WAS ALL
FEDERAL AND STATE. ERIS ARE
TAXES THAT WERE THERE AND I
THINK OFTENTIMES WE JUST FORGET
THAT THAT THAT THAT EXIST THOSE
ARE REAL REAL REAL DOLLARS.
WHAT'S THE AMOUNT AGAIN I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE HEALTH-
COMMITTEE BUT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER THIS IS A PROPER
PROGRAM WHAT THE FEW MIGHT BE
IN- AND WHY IS IT A DEEP AND IT
DOES. TO THE TELECOM COMPANIES
HAVE ANY. INPUT INTO IT AT ALL
OR IS IT JUST DONE BY UP OF
FEDERAL FEDERAL STATE.
LEGISLATURES AND OR OR
REGULATORY BODIES AND JUST
ADDED ON. YEAH YOU CAN AND THE
ANSWER THAT. SO THAT PIECE OF
THE LEGISLATION IS NOT CLEAR
ABOUT THE COLLECTION OF THE
SURCHARGE- RIGHT NOW WE CLICK
TO SURCHARGE FOR A NUMBER OF
OTHER PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM TO
HEARING IMPAIRED CALIFORNIA
BANNED SERVICES FUND- THE HIGH
COST ONE EIGHTEEN P. THERE'S A
STRICT FORMULA FOR HOW THAT'S
CALCULATED THE NINE ONE ONE
SURCHARGE WAS CALCULATED ON-
YES COMES. BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE FOR AN APPROVED
BUDGET AFTER YOU APPROVE THAT
BUDGET THEN THEY DETERMINE HOW
MANY ACCESS LINES ARE OUT THERE
IN THE PUBLIC AND THEY DO SOME
SIMPLE MATH AND COME UP WITH A
RATE TO NINE ONE ONE SURCHARGE
CAN ONLY BE BETWEEN THIRTY NO
MORE THAN EIGHTY CENTS PER
ACCESS LINE PER MONTH. THIS
BILL IS SILENT ON THE ON THE
AMOUNT HAS TO BE COLLECTED WHAT
THIS BILL SAYS IS. IN WHATEVER.
COSTS ARE OUT THERE. THE PHONE
CUSTOMER WILL BE THE BACKSTOPS
TO MAKE UP FOR ANY SHORT
SHORTFALLS. SO RATHER THAN JUST
LIMIT THE SURCHARGE TO PAY FOR
THE INTER OPERABILITY OF
CONNECTING A CALL. IT IS ALSO
IT IS VAGUE AS TO. WHAT OTHER
SERVICES CAN BE CHARGED TO THE
PHONE CUSTOMERS SO. THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE IN THIS
BILL I HAVE NO CLUE BECAUSE
IT'S THE SKY'S THE LIMIT
THERE'S NO CAP THERE'S NO LIMIT
THERE'S NO DESCRIPTION OF HOW
FAR IT WOULD GO OTHER THAN TO
SAY. THE PHONE CUSTOMER WOULD
BE THE BACKSTOP FOR WHATEVER
COSTS WERE NOT COVERED. OKAY
THANK AND THEN ONE FINAL
QUESTION DONE AND MAYBE THE
AUTHOR I CAN GET ANSWER THIS-
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TWO ONE ONE.
WE'VE GOT A BUNCH OF OTHER
PROGRAMS AS WELL. IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY JUST GET USED TO IT
NINE ONE ONE OF THIRTY TO GET
SOMEBODY IT'S NINE ONE ONE- AND
SORT OF MAGIC THAT THERE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO BE SOME SORT
OF EDUCATION OR SOME SORT OF-
ADDS SPEND. A DOES THE ARE THE
FEES THAT ARE COLLECTED GOING
TO GO OUT TO BE ABLE TO EDUCATE
BECAUSE I MEAN I WOULD IMAGINE
THERE HAVE TO BE. A VERY LARGE-
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN.
AWARE TO THOSE DOLLARS COME
FROM TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. IS
NOT BUILT INTO THIS LEGISLATION
AS WELL THANK YOU MISTER IS IF
YOU DON'T MIND IF I CALL
SERVICE ADDRESS GEORGE YOU KNOW
HOW TO. HELP YOU GET YOUR- SO
ONE THING I DO WANT TO SAY IS
WE- WE WILL BE PUTTING A CAP ON
THE- THE AMOUNT THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO. WORKING WITH THAT WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT. AND WHAT
THE ACTUAL COST OF SETTING UP
THIS PHONE SYSTEM IS- AS MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS BODY NOW I THINK
ALL OF US WERE HERE WHEN WE
APPROVED AN ADDITIONAL NINE ONE
OR IF YOU ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
CAPABILITY WE WANT TO ENSURE WE
HAVE THE SAME CAPABILITY WITH
NINE EIGHT EIGHT- BUT THERE
WILL BE A CAP SO IT ISN'T JUST
GOING TO BE UNLIMITED SPENDING
I WANT THAT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
AND WE ALSO AS REFLECTED IN
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- AT. FEDERAL
LEGISLATION ALLOWS US TO- COVER
OBVIOUSLY ANY TELEPHONE FIA'S
COMES THROUGH FEDERAL. ENABLING
LEGISLATION AS THIS GUY'S. AND
THE FEDERAL. AS YOU KNOW.
SIGNED BY. PRESIDENT OF. THE
OTHER PARTY BUT I'M- SO I. LED
IT IT ACTUALLY DOES ALLOW US TO
BOTH PAY FOR THE PHONE SYSTEM
ITSELF. AND ALSO FOR THE
SUPPORT TO RESPOND TO THOSE
CALLS WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS NETWORK.
AND WE THINK THAT'S AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE CONVERSATION. AND
THEN YOU ASKED ABOUT. AND
IMPLEMENTATION EDUCATION I WANT
TO BUY ONE THING WHICH IS. IF
YOU WERE TO ONCE THIS PHONE
NUMBER IS IN PLACE IF YOU CALL
NINE ONE ONE WITH A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS YOU WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TONIGHT EIGHT ONCE
THIS IS IN. PLACE SO IF PEOPLE.
CONTINUE TO CALL NINE ONE ONE
BUT THE MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE
THEY WILL BE SENT TO THESE. AND
CALL CENTERS WHERE WE CAN
HANDLE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SO
IN THE BEGINNING. PEOPLE MAY
CALL THE WRONG NUMBER AND THEY
WILL STILL GET THE SERVICES AND
I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS WILL BE
ENSURING THAT NO MATTER WHO YOU
CALL YOU GET THE PROGRAM.
RESPONSE AND SERVICES- BUT I
WILL ALLOW TERROR TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT EDUCATION AND
HOW THAT HAS GONE INTO OTHER
STATES ARE A LITTLE BIT AHEAD
OF US SO SHE MAY HAVE MORE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THAT.
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE IN VERY CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH THE NATIONAL
BY PREVENTION- DANCE AND THAT
EACH AND THERE IS A BAD
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
EDUCATION LOOKS LIKE AND THERE
WILL BE FEDERAL FUNDING AND
SUPPORT NATION UP COMING DOWN
TO SUPPORT THAT AND WE OUTLINED
IN THE BILL THAT THE STATE
ENTITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
RUNNING NINE EIGHT EIGHT UP
ELABORATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO ENSURE THAT THE
UNIFIED WHICH- THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRING IN
THE FOURTH YOU KNOW WE'VE
INSTEAD OF FACING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. FOR AS LONG AS I CAN
REMEMBER. AND HAVING A
DEDICATED EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM CAN HELP PREVENT THE
TRAGEDIES THAT OCCUR FAR TOO
OFTEN MENTAL HEALTH CALLS ARE
HANDLED IN THE SAME PROCESS
CALLS ARE ABOUT CRIMES IN
PROGRESS. WE HAVE TO TRANSFORM
A MENTAL HEALTH EMERGENCY
RESPONSE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CAN DELIVER MORE APPROPRIATE
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE TO CARE.
I HOPE ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
WILL JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING YOUR
EFFORTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MR RODRIGUEZ THIS QUICK
COMMENTS WERE ALSO ON A STRONG.
TALKING STRONG SUPPORT AS A CO
AUTHOR OF A- THIS BILL IS A
VERY IMPORTANT WE HAVE- MORE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDER
FOR FOLKS QUESTION THE MERIT.
MERCY SETTING SO LOOK FOR
SUPPORT IN A AND R. THANK YOU
FOR A COMPANY TO BE A
COOPERATIVE FOR SPRINT ABOUT
THINKING. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
A COUPLE AYE SOME COMMENTS IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME HERE SO VERY
VERY COMPLEX BILL I THINK WE'LL
ALL AGREE THAT- AND EVEN IF THE
ISSUE IS EVEN MORE COMPLEX SO
IT PERHAPS SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
TO YOUR BILL- BUT FAILURE TO
PASS A BILL THIS YEAR- THAT
DOES NOT MEAN CALIFORNIA GETS A
PASS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION-
DATE OF JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AND WHAT FAILURE TO PASS A BILL
WOULD MEAN IS CALIFORNIA WILL
BE FORCED TO RESPOND WITHOUT
ANY FUNDING OR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE. PUTTING TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS PRESSURE ON AN
ALREADY BURDENED CRISIS
RESPONSE SYSTEM. MOST MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHILE FAILURE TO
MEET THE DEADLINES IMPOSED BY
FEDERAL LAW. WILL NOT RESULT IN
ANY PENALTIES. PEOPLE WILL BE
PUT IN JEOPARDY. THE
CONSEQUENCES OF INACTION WOULD
MEAN CALLS GO UNANSWERED PEOPLE
MAY NOT RECEIVE NEEDED CARE AND
OUTCOMES FOR CALLERS COULD BE
WORSE THAN THEY ARE NOW. I
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR AT THAT
THE AUTHOR NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO ADDRESS THE MANY
AREAS OF CONCERN I BELIEVE
GREAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
EVEN JUST THIS MORNING TOWARDS
REACHING A CONSENSUS. AND THAT
IS VERY ENCOURAGING SO IN AS
MUCH AS THIS BILL IS DOUBLE
REFER TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE- AND THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT CRISIS CARE SYSTEM
AND THE CORRESPONDING FUNDING
MECHANISM OR CRITICAL THIS
YEAR. FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
HAS RECOMMENDED THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS
WE HOPE WILL ULTIMATELY BE
REFLECTED IN IN THE FINAL BILL
SORRY EXPECTATION THAT ALL
PARTIES WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER. AND THEN WE SEE THIS
BILL BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY WILL
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OUTLINED-
AND WILL REPRESENT A SOLID
PARTNERSHIP. THAT BUILDS OUT
THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT CRISIS
CALL CENTERS SO- WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME BUILDING ON THE IN
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RECIPIENT ENHANCING RESPONSE
DISPATCH AND DELIVERY OF CRISIS
CARE SERVICES. AFTER HAVING
SAID ALL THAT I'D LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER MAYBE IN A COAL. YOUR
BILL- WITH THE- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HONORED TO HAVE YOU AS
A COP AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
MY CO AUTHORS ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND ACROSS THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS EFFORT IN WASHINGTON WAS A
BI PARTISAN EFFORT IT IS HERE
AS WELL BECAUSE- THEY NEED TO
SUPPORT OUR COMPARTMENT EASING
CRISIS RIGHT NOW IS EVIDENT. TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THIS IS A
HUGE STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ONE THIRD OF ON HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS OR
THE FAMILIES LIKE YOU HEARD
TODAY. HELLO PAID THE ULTIMATE
PRICE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET.
AN APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS RESPONSE WE HEARD FROM
TOWN HALL WE ALSO HEARD FROM A
FEW OF ANGELO CANTOS FAMILY
MEMBERS ANOTHER. INDIVIDUAL
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WHO DIED AT
THE HANDS OF POLICE WHILE IN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. AND IT'S
TIME WE MAKE THIS NECESSARY
CHANGE AND AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED WERE ALSO FORCED TO
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
IT'S WE NEED TO DO IT WE NEED
TO DO IT RIGHT AND THIS IS
COMPLEX LEGISLATION. BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH OVER SEVENTY FIVE
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE WE
GET IT RIGHT. AND THEN WE GET
IT RIGHT FOR CALIFORNIA WE GET
IT RIGHT FOR THOSE THAT ARE
SUFFERING AND ARE IN CRISIS. SO
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
A SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HI WHEN I MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO. BONTA BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORAL.
FLORIDA VOTING MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON. HAS SIX NEEDS
TO MORE SIXTY ONE K. WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN OR LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL EXCUSE ME AND- PICK IT
UP LATER. BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT BILL I'D LIKE TO HAVE
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR INCLUDES AB TEN FIFTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW. ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS
AMENDMENTS THEIR MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MR
BIGELOW. MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I WHAT I
MAYES. MAYES I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW I. BONTA BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO AYE MAIENSCHEIN
OUR FLOOR LARA. FOUR I
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RIVAS- I'M SORRY NAZARIAN I
REQUEST RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
IT'S TEN ZERO TWO ZERO THAT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT WE MOVE
ON TO- MR FONG PRESENTING AB
FOUR NINE FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE AND FEEDBACK ON THIS
BILL I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB
ONE FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR WALAU
REGISTERED NURSE WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF A BLOOD COLLECTION AT
A MOBILE BLOOD BANK. TO BE
AVAILABLE BY VIDEO
TELECONFERENCE. BLOOD DONATIONS
SAVE COUNTLESS LIVES ACROSS THE
STATE AND NATION WE KNOW THAT
AND ACCORDING TO THE BLOOD
CENTERS OF CALIFORNIA SOMEONE
NEEDS A BLOOD TRANSFUSION.
EVERY THREE SECONDS. DONATED
BLOOD PRODUCTS ARE USED TO
TREAT INJURIES AND DISEASES.
AND EVEN CANCER HEART DISEASE
ORGAN TRANSPLANTS. AND AS WELL
AS SEVERE TRAUMATIC INJURIES.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT WE
RELY ON THE KINDNESS AND
GENEROSITY OF BLOOD DONORS TO
HELP SAVE SICK AND VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
MADE BLOOD COLLECTIONS SCARCER.
BUT CURRENT REGULATIONS ALLOW
FOR DEVIATIONS FROM STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY. LAST APRIL
GOVERNOR'S THEM EVEN ISSUED AN
ORDER AND ENCOURAGING HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. TO MAXIMIZE
THE USE OF TELEHEALTH SERVICES
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
CONTINUE TO ADJUST TO THE-
ADJUSTER PRACTICES. THAT WE
FOUND TO BE SUCCESSFUL DURING
THE PANDEMIC. BUDGET NATIONS
HAVE BECOME EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
LATELY AS INDIVIDUALS WHO
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVERAGE.
NINETEEN CAN DONATE BLOOD WITH
THEIR ANTIBODIES TO HELP PEOPLE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SICK AND
EVEN HELP TO CONTINUE TO STUDY
THE VIRUS. KERN FLEXIBILITY
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
TO ENSURE BLOOD AND BLOOD
PRODUCTS. THAT ARE STILL
COLLECTED SAFELY RESPONSIBLY
EITHER WITH A NURSE ON SITE OR
AVAILABLE VIDEO
TELECONFERENCING. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. I AM JOINED
TODAY BY SOME A GALLEY THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF HOUSING
COMMITTEE BLOOD BANK WHICH HAS
HAD SUCCESS OR ORCHESTRATING
BLOOD DONATIONS THIS PAST YEAR.
ALSO WITH ME TODAY IS LAURIE
CAMERA AT ADVOCATE FOR HATCHING
COMMITTEE BUT BANK AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THEPHONE LINES FOR THE PRIMARY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THEIR LINES ARE OPEN UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANK
YOU PEOPLE- CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
SIR. OKAY MY NAME IS SEAN NOW I
AM THE PRESIDENT DOES DO ACTION
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANK IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. AND I
AM TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. BUT THANKS A BIRD
COLLECTION PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
SAVING LIVES PARTICULARLY IN
THIS CURRENT ENVIRONMENT WITH
THE CODE NINETEEN THAT THE
PANDEMIC IMPACTS AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL WILDFIRE WILL FIRE
HER MERGING THESE. HOSPITALS
AND CARE GIVERS NEED TO HAVE
THE NECESSARY BLOOD SUPPLY
WHICH COINCIDENTALLY. IT'S AN
ALL TIME LOW. OUR POLICIES MAY
NEED NURSES ON SITE AT ALL
TIMES THAT ARE PERMANENT
LOCATIONS BUT DOING SO AND OR
MOBILE SITES CUT SIGNIFICANTLY
INTO OUR ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
BLOOD COLLECTION. AND THAT'S
JUST THE FACT OF THE MATTER. IF
WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
CONDUCTOR MOBILE SITE
COLLECTIONS WITH NURSES WHO ARE
NOT PRESENT AT THE MOBILE SITE
BUT ALWAYS IN CONSTANT
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATION. WE'RE
ABLE TO MAXIMIZE OUR BOOK
COLLECTION AND WE CAN DO THIS
FOR PROVIDING FULLY FOR THE
SAFETY OF THOSE WHO DONATE
BLOOD AT THOSE SITES. SHE
MAINTAIN CPR. TRAINED AND
CERTIFIED STAFF. TO ADMINISTER
RESEARCH. ANOTHER FOR STATUS
ALL OUR LOCATIONS. THE NATION'S
AFTER NOT MEDICAL OFFICES WITH
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT OTHER THAN
WHAT IS USED TO COLLECT BLOOD.
AND THE FACT IS THAT IT'S THE
P. R. IN GENERAL FOR AID
CONSTITUTE THE FULL EXTENT OF
MEDICAL INTERVENTION POSSIBLE.
WHAT WOULD YOUR RESPONSE TO A
NINE ONE ONE CALL IN THE EVENT
OF BLOOD DONOR APPEARS. HAVE A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY. BUT IT'S
GIVING TO THE OF WORK ARE. RARE
DONATION SITES IN FACT I WOULD
WAGER THAT IT IS MORE DANGEROUS
YOUR MORE RISK OF AN ACCIDENT-
DRIVING TO AND FROM THE BLOOD
DONATION SITE- THEN- ACTUALLY
DONATING BLOOD. JUST THE
GOVERNOR. EXECUTIVE RDER
ALLOWING BLOOD DONATION WITHOUT
THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF A
NURSE. THERE HAVE BEEN NO
SERIOUS INCIDENTS THE PROCESSES
WORKED WELL. I IN FACT AT
HOUCHENS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
INCREASE BLOOD SUPPLY DURING
THIS PERIOD WHICH IS KIND OF
INCREDIBLE- THAT IT SPEAKS TO
THE FACT OF- THE- DID NOT A
FLEXIBILITY AND EFFICIENCY THAT
ALLOWS US. ALL WE ARE ASKING IS
TO KEEP DOING WHAT IS THAT THE
REALLY SUCCESSFUL PRACTICE. AND
FINALLY I WOULD ASK YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONTO OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YES THANK
YOU YOUR WORD AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS LAURIE KAMMERER
I AM THE- ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANK- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR- HOUSING IS A CO SPONSOR
ON THE BILL- PENSION. IS AS AS
STRONG BUT NELLIE HAD
MENTIONED- BASED SERVER MANY OF
THE WORLD COMMUNITIES. IN OUR
STATE- YEAH THERE YOU CAN TO
SEARCH THE ROLE CAN YOU. AND
THAT WE FOR YOUR I. BOATS TODAY
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- JUST GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THE LINE FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND ONE
OF THE WITNESSES IS NOT
AVAILABLE BUT THERE IS ONE
WITNESS TO TESTIFY. STE. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR WOULD AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
O'MALLEY I AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ACT CAN'T FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR WHICH
WE BELIEVE WOULD READ THE
HEALTH OF BLOOD BANK OWNERS.
THIS BILL WOULD END OF. THAT
BLOOD BANKS HAVE A REGISTERED
NURSE PHYSICALLY PRESENT DURING
BLOOD DRAWS AND INSTEAD ALLOW
OUR AND TO MONITOR THE PROFITS
VIA TELECONFERENCE. WELL WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND THE PROPONENTS WILLINGNESS
TO AMEND THE BILL SUCH THAT OUR
ROOMS AVAILABLE BY
TELECONFERENCE MUST BE
REGISTERED IN CALIFORNIA. WE
REMAIN CONCERNED THAT PATIENTS
HELP COULD BE READ BY THIS
CHANGE. ONE SUCH CONCERN
INCLUDES RED THAT COULD BE
EXACERBATED AND RURAL AREAS
WITH LESS RELIABLE INTERNET.
SERVICE THIS LIKELY LONGER
TRAVEL TIMES REPEAT CARE IN
CASE OF AN EMERGENCY. WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE BLOWS UP LIKE
THE INTERNET AND DROPPED CALLS
DURING TELECONFERENCING EVEN IN
URBAN AREAS. NEVER MIND THE
LACK OF ACCESS AND RURAL AREAS.
AND IN THIS SITUATION IT COULD.
PROVE TO BE EXTREMELY HARMFUL.
BLACKLY THERE WAS NEVER AN
ARCTIC OR TEN NEED ARMORED THAT
WOULD SUPPORT AN OFFICIAL
CHANGES. IN FACT IN SUNDAY NEW
YORK TIMES BIG STATES THE
AVENUE FOR COUPLE PLUS HAS NOT
MATERIALIZED. AND WHILE THE
REST OF DRAWING BLOOD ARE NOT
AS SEVERE AND OTHER FORMS THAT
HAVE HERE THEY ARE VERY REAL.
AND THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF A
NURSE WHO CAN MONITOR BLOOD
DONORS BUT THEY'RE TRAINED
ABILITY TO JACKSON YOU FOR
EMERGENCY CARE IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO MISTER ROBERT WERE GO TO
OTHER OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WITH DISASTER THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE SO. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE LINES. THEN LATER
GERMAN FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THE.
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR. ENSURE
THE TIME LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT TWO IN THE QUEUE PERFECT
THANKS PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN
THEY'RE READY. WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE REMEMBER SAILORS
ACTIVITY CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WERE OFTEN
OPPOSITION LEGISLATION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER THREE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HAPPENING WITH THE SHARE
ONLY A GRIPPING WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
OFTEN OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. AND AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME AND SEE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE CONTINUE MR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. MISS
CARILLO. THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORD I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TO
ENSURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK OUT SOME OF
THE DETAILS SPECIALLY WITH SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION ESPECIALLY
THE NURSES SWITCH DO THIS VITAL
WORK MY CONCERN IS ALWAYS ABOUT
EQUITY I WANT TO AND YOU COULD
REPRESENT A RURAL COMMUNITY AND
I REPRESENT A COMMUNITY THAT IS
20% BELOW THE NATIONAL POVERTY
LINE AND ALREADY ACCESSING
DOCTORS AND NURSES. IS A STRAIN
WHETHER YOU'RE IN A RURAL
COMMUNITY OR AN URBAN COMMUNITY
THAT'S RIDDLED WITH WITH
POVERTY AND LACK OF RESOURCES
AND MY CONCERN HAS BEEN IN
TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S
TELEHEALTH IT'S ALWAYS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEBODY TO
ACTUALLY SEE A DOCTOR IN PERSON
OR TALK TO A NURSE IN PERSON
AND I THINK GIVEN CALL OF IT
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GIVEN US THIS
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
REIMAGINE AND RETHINK WHAT
HEALTH CARE LOOKS LIKE. BUT
ALWAYS COMING BACK TO THE
CONDITION OF EQUITY CAN WE
ENSURE THAT WHETHER IT'S RURAL
OR URBAN AND LOW INCOME AREAS
AT THE END OF THE DAY HAVE
ACCESS TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
TALK TO A DOCTOR AND TALK TO A
NURSE SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TO INSURE THAT YOU
CAN CONTINUE. TO MOVE IT
FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY YOU COME
TO A RESOLUTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. RICHARD
QUESTION. OF WE'LL BRING CARDS
OKAY NO I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY- BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR WE DID THAT
ALREADY EXCUSE ME BRING IT BACK
TO THE AUTHOR- THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
JUST WANNA SAY AND JUST A
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE THAT-
THIS THIS BILL IS TO- INCREASE
ACCESS THE BLOOD BANK SERVICES-
CERTAINLY WHETHER IT'S AN URBAN
AREA RURAL AREA- WE DO NEED TO-
PROVIDE ACCESS ESPECIALLY AS WE
BEGIN TO REOPEN THEY'LL BE
OTHER DEMANDS FOR BLOOD
SERVICES BLOOD PRODUCTS AS
WELL- WHETHER IT'S A CAR
ACCIDENT OR OTHER. OTHER
AILMENTS OR OTHER- AMONG OTHER
DISEASES AS OF LATE EDITION
ECHO ECHO THERE WILL STILL BE
HERE AND WE NEED THAT THOSE
ACTS AS WELL SO BLOOD DONATIONS
CAN BE SAFELY DONE EVEN AS A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND I APPLAUD
THE WORK OF OUR BLOOD BANKS
ACROSS THE STATE AS THEY
CONTINUE TO ADJUST AND AS I
SAID EARLIER THIS BILL IS TO
PROMOTE INCREASED ACCESS TO
BLOOD BANK SERVICES STATEWIDE
AND IN RURAL AREAS IN
PARTICULAR. WHAT WE DRAW CLOSER
TO RECOVERING FROM THIS
PANDEMIC- WE NEED TO BE AGILE
I'M PREPARED TO HAVE BLOOD
PRODUCTS READY TO RESPOND TO
ANY EMERGENCY POSSIBLE AND THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE DATA- OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS IN THE
MIDDLE DEPEND PANDEMIC ABOUT OF
HOW MANY AMOUNTS OF DONATIONS
AND PINTS OF BLOOD THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO COLLECT- WITH THIS
FLEXIBILITY SO WITH THAT I
RESPECT THE ASPEN ITEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A MOST
ON THE BILL. LOS BY MISTER
FLOOR- SECOND BY MISTER MASON
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO-
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT HI WHEN I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. BAKER CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW II BONTA.
BONTA NOT VOTING. BURKE BURKE
HI CARILLO. HI FLORA FLORA HI
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I
REQUEST RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
ELEVEN ZERO BECAUSE ELEVEN
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF A
BROTHER SAT ON THANK YOU MR
FONG I THINK IT WAS CHAIR. WE
WANT TO- AB FIFTY TEN TWENTY BY
MISS FRIEDMAN PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO OUR
PREDECESSORS IN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED TWO KEY PIECES OF
REFORMS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE SEEKING MEDICAL HELP
BOTH THE HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING
ACT AND THE FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT. WERE
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE BASIC
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR-
RESIDENCE- WHO WERE FACING
MEDICAL BILLS AS WELL AS
AWARENESS- OF FOR THEM TO KNOW
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE TO THEM SO
IMAGINE FACING WHAT COULD BE
THE WORST DAY OF YOUR LIFE.
BEING IN THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE
OF A MEDICAL EMERGENCY AND
BEING UNDER INSURED OR
UNINSURED AND THEN IMAGINE
LATER WHEN THE BILLS START TO
ARRIVE AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO BECAUSE YOU CAN'T PAY
WILL COULD BE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS IN MEDICAL BILLS.
AND THEN IMAGINE DEBT COLLECTOR
STARTING TO CALL YOU AT ALL
HOURS AND IMAGINE YOU'RE NOT BE
ABLE TO GET A LONER SEND YOUR
CHILD TO COLLEGE BECAUSE OF
THESE BILLS. AND THEN. WHAT IF
YOU FOUND OUT LATER THAT YOU
ACTUALLY WERE ENTITLED THE
CHERRY CARE ARE ALL ALONG AND
THAT CHARITY CARE WAS NEVER
OFFERED TO YOU. WHILE YOU WERE
IN THE HOSPITAL. MAYBE AT ALL
OR IN A WAY THAT YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND OR TO LIVE WITH YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY HAPPENS TO FAR
TOO MANY OF OUR EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE PATIENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. KAISER HEALTH NEWS
REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS IN CALIFORNIA COULD
HAVE. BUT DID NOT PROVIDE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN CHARITY CARE TO
PATIENTS. PATIENTS REPORT BEING
DISCHARGED AND RECEIVING
MEDICAL BILLS WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAL BUT THAT
THEY COULD APPLY FOR CHARITY
CARE. WORST HOSPITALS OFTEN
SELL PATIENT ACCOUNTS TO
COLLECTIONS AGENCIES. WITH
WHICH FURTHER NEGLECT TO INFORM
PATIENTS THAT THEY COULD APPLY
FOR CHARITY CARE.
CONSEQUENTIALLY PATIENTS A
PHASE NEGATIVE CREDIT REPORTING
AND FINALLY COLLECTIONS
LAWSUITS. TO ADDRESS THE GAPS
IN EXISTING LAW AND STRENGTHEN
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS AB
TEN TWENTY DOES THE FOLLOWING.
IT'S STRENGTHENS STATE
ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT OF THE
HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING ACT. BY
PENALIZING HOSPITALS THAT DO
NOT COMPLY. PROVIDES PATIENTS
WITH MORE DETAILED INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR BILLS AND HOW TO
APPLY FOR PUBLIC PROGRAMS LIKE
MEDICAID. AS WELL AS CHARITY
CARE AT THE TIME OF DISCHARGE.
AND WHEN THE BILL WAS SENT TO
COLLECTIONS. IT PROHIBITS
HOSPITAL FROM SELLING PATIENT
AT. IT EXTENDS ADVERSE CREDIT
REPORTING AND COMMENCEMENT OF
CIVIL ACTION FROM A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS AFTER INITIAL BILLING. IT
REQUIRES DEBT COLLECTORS TO
CERTIFY THAT THE PATIENT HAS
BEEN SCREENED FOR PUBLIC
PROGRAMS AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BEFORE THEY FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THAT PATIENT.
IT RAISES THE INCOME LEVEL FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FROM
310050% OF THE POVERTY LEVEL
24100% MEMBERS OF THE PAST FEW
WEEKS WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAD. AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WE REACH
AN AGREEMENT ON THE LANGUAGE
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
THEIR AMENDMENTS IN
APPROPRIATIONS. I APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL. AND FOR
THE SAKE OF OUR PATIENTS WHO
ARE. NOT ONLY FACING MEDICAL
CATASTROPHE BUT OFTEN FINANCIAL
CATASTROPHE I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YES I TODAY I'M GOING
TO HAVE WITH US TRACY DOUGLAS
WITH THAT SUBJECT LEGAL
SERVICES AND MONIQUE MONIQUE
DAVIS WHO WAS A PATIENT TO
SHARE THEIR- PERSONAL STORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL HAVE
THE OPERATOR OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND WHENEVER
THEY'RE READY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU HONOURABLE MEMBERS
THAT SAID IT IS A NONPROFIT
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION AND WE
ARE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY
TEN TWENTY. I WORK IN A MEDICAL
LEGAL PARTNERSHIP AND HELP
PATIENTS WITH THE LEGAL
PROBLEMS THAT EXACERBATE THEIR
HEALTH PROBLEMS. WHAT IS
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
IN MY WORK I HAVE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BUT MISS DAVIS WILL
DESCRIBE SO POWERFULLY. MEDICAL
DEBT HAVE DEVASTATING IMPACTS
YOU CAN SEND PEOPLE INTO
POVERTY THEY CAN LIVE THEIR
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND FOR
CLOSURE. DISTRESSED DEBT PILING
UP IN COLLECTION CALLED WORSE
WITH THEIR HEALTH. AND IT WEARS
NAY MAY BE FORCED TO FILE FOR
BANKRUPTCY MEDICAL DEBT IS THE
LEADING. CAUSE OF CONSUMER
BANKRUPTCY. AND QUICKLY.
CALIFORNIA HOPPED AND PROVIDE
SHARED CARE WHEN THEY COULD AND
ALSO NOT TELLING. ABOUT ITS
AVAILABILITY. MY CLIENT FIFTY
HUGE BILLS- SENIORS WHO HAD MET
EMERGENCY CARE FOR NEEDED
SURGERY FOR A CONDITION. AT NO
TIME DID THE HOSPITAL EVER LET
THEM KNOW ABOUT CHARITY CARE.
THEY WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH. TO
BE REFERRED TO LEGAL AID FOR
HELP. ONE BLACK SHE NOT BE. IN
ACCESSING JERRY THAT. ARE TO
OFFER THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
PROCESS SHOULD NOT BE OPAQUE
AND HARD TO GET. IT SHOULD BE
READILY AVAILABLE. I THINK IT'S
NOT THE ONLY LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION NOTICING THE
PROBLEM MY COLLEAGUES FROM
OTHER LEGAL SERVICES REPORTS
JEAN KING ISSUES. OFFICIALS ARE
CONTINUING COLLECTION CALLS
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE CAN
EXPECT THAT MEDICAL DEBT WILL
INCREASE. THE TIME HAS COME TO
STRENGTH IN THE HOSPITAL FAIR
PRICING ACT SO THAT EVEN THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE A PROGRAM LIKE
NINE BENEFIT FROM IT AT THE END
IT. BUT THE THREE OF THEM WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
AGO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU MY NAME
IS MONIQUE DAVIS I LIVE IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY FIVE
AND SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY TWO.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH A RARE
BONE MARROW DISORDER. I HAD
NEVER BEEN SICK BEFORE AND I
WAS AT THE TIME OF MY LIFE AND
CAREER. I WAS TREATED OVER FIVE
SEPARATE HOSPITALS BEFORE
RECEIVED CHEMOTHERAPY
CHEMOTHERAPY AND A STEM CELL
TRANSPLANT REQUIRED. MULTIPLE
TIMES I WAS RUSHED TO THE
HOSPITAL IN AN EMERGENCY EACH
TIME I WAS ADMITTED AND STAY
FOR AT LEAST A WEEK OR MORE. I
WAS SEEN AT UC IRVINE. PARMA
INTER COMMUNITY MEMORIAL
CALIFORNIA COAST MEDICAL CENTER
ANAHEIM REGIONAL. WORK AND HOW
TO MEDICAL CENTER. I WOULD
DEFINITELY. FOR OVER A YEAR NOW.
IN A OUT OF HOSPITALS NOT. THE
CALL TREATMENT AND TIME THE
ANSWER HOME WITHOUT THE PROPER
DIAGNOSIS AND- ACCUMULATING
MORE AND MORE MEDICAL THAT. I
COULD NOT WORK MY HUSBAND HAD
TO TAKE TEMPORARY LEAVE FOR
NETWORKING FOR ME FALLOUT
MEMORIAL CARE THE TOLD MY
HUSBAND TO BORROW MONEY FROM MY
FAMILY MEMBERS FROM OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
BEFORE THEY WILL CONTINUE MY
TREATMENT. NONE OF THE
HOSPITALS INFORMED US OF THE
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL HELP. HE
STARTED TO RECEIVE MEMBERS HAVE
TO BE THE MAIL PHONE CALLS THEY
WILL CALL ME WHILE I WAS STILL
IN THE HOSPITAL. THEY WOULD
CALL MY HUSBAND AT WORK
DEMANDED PAMENTS. WERE SCARED
FELT ALONE AND TERRIFIED. I WAS
TOLD. AT TIMES I THOUGHT MAYBE.
IT WOULD BE BETTER IF I HAD
DIED THEN MY HUSBAND WOULD NOT
HAVE TO CLOSE THE ADDED STRESS
AND FINANCIAL BURDEN OF ME. THE
BILL KNOWN SAID EMMA COLVIN ANY
KIND OF OVER THE COLLECTION
AGENCIES AND WE POINTED
NEGATIVE CREDIT ACTIVITY. ONE
THIS IMPACT MY. HOUSING
OFFICIALS SERVICES EXECUTIVE
WHETHER MY FATHER BECAME ILL
HIS MONEY MORE IMPORTANT IN MY
LIFE. IT WAS NOT UNTIL I
CONTACTED THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER
THAT I FOUND OUT THAT I
SHOULD'VE GOTTEN HELP FROM THE
HOSPITALS REDUCE MY BILLS IN
OUR YOU PLAN- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
WHAT BILL EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE
ON TO WE DO HAVE A WITNESS
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION-
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THAT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS BARBARA
GLAZER WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DID
HAVE A POSITION OF OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED BUT WE HAD
TENTATIVELY REACHED AGREEMENT
ON AMENDMENT AT THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN STATED. AND WE WILL BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
TEN TWENTY I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR STAFF IN THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US TO
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS. WE THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY GOOD
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELL NOW MOVES TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR- CALLERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
BILL WOULD JUST ASK FOR YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL. PLEASE OPEN. THE
LINES WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTER ROBERT REITER. ANTLION
INSURANCE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION A. B. TEN
TWENTY. AT THIS TIME WE'VE GOT
SEVEN IN THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR
GREAT PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
WE WILL START WITH NUMBER THREE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON YES MEAN PALETTE
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN
THE B. NUMBER THREE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CLOSE BURKE IN BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOT
ALIGNED TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WOULD AND ATS ON BEHALF OF
ESCAPE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT TO BE LINED THREE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ACTUALLY THEY
REMOVE THEMSELVES THANK YOU
WILL MOVE TO LINE THREE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE OR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHO
MOVIELINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DAVID REID AND I'M
WITH THE RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE RESELL
PROHIBITION CONTAINED IN AB TEN
TWENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
CONSOLIDATION BEHALF OF ENCORE
CAPITAL GROUP SH AND WE'RE ONE
MINUTE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT LIZA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RONALD KOEMAN TO BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ACTUALLY MOVING TO LINE. THREE
OH FIVE. A LINE THREE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE OR
FIVE YOUR OPEN. CHEN MEMBER
CABINET GETS AT THE CORE OF AN
ENTIRE THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK
PLEASE. YEAH ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE MORE
IN THE QUEUE K. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER. TWO FORTY ONE TO FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE TO
FORTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. THAT
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER
TECHNICALLY FARRANT THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER ONE OF THE COOKS ON
THIRD AND AB TEN TWENTY AND WE
ARE IN COURT AT THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I THINK
YOU SAID THAT WAS IT THOUGH. AT
THE TIME THERE'S NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR. GREAT THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NOAM. THE
THERE WERE. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
BYE MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND
BY THIS CARILLO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS LIKE
CLOSE MYSTERY THIS IS A MOTHER
STUCK CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE AND I WOULD URGE YOUR
TITLE THANK YOU THANK YOU IN A
SHOULD THE BILL PASS ON TO ME
I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU CONSIDERED
ME AS A CO AUTHOR FOR YOUR
BILL. WE WOULD BE VERY HONORED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THAT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHAT I. WHAT I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE. CARILLO
RIO AYE LARA. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WALDRON HIGH.
NINE ZERO THANK YOU BELIEVE
THAT WOULD BE YOU HAVE NOT
NINETY NINE VOTES AND IT WILL
BE THE ROLE OF THE BROTHERS
ADAM THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MR
GABRIEL YOUR TURN AB. FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SIR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO PRESENT BABY FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO WHICH WOULD IMPROVE
PATIENT CARE AND SAFETY AND
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY BY STRENGTHENING
THE PROCESS AROUND PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUEST RELATED TO
NURSE TO PATIENT STAFFING
RATIOS. AS AN INITIAL MATTER
LIKE TO NOTE THAT STAFFING
RATIOS HAVE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN PROTECTING BOTH NURSES AND
PATIENTS. AS RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THEY CAN LITERALLY
SAVE PATIENTS LIVES WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING NURSES FROM INJURY
AND ILLNESS. I ALSO KNOW THIS
FIRST HAND FOR MY MOM AN
EXCEPTIONALLY DEVOTED AND
COMPASSIONATE REGISTERED NURSE
WHO SPENT EARS CARING FOR
EVERYONE FROM NEWBORN BABIES TO
ELDERLY CANCER PATIENTS. AS MY
MOM TELLS IT THERE WERE TIMES
WHERE HER HOSPITAL WAS SO LEAN
WE STAFF. BUT YOU WERE THAT
EVEN TAKING A QUICK BATHROOM
BOY WHAT PART HER PATIENTS
ARREST. UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
GROWING EVIDENCE THAT IN RECENT
YEARS SOME HOSPITALS HAVE
SOUGHT TO USE PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUEST TO
CIRCUMVENT STAFFING RATIOS.
THEREBY PLACING PATIENTS NURSES
AND THE COMMUNITY AT RISK. AB
FORTY TWENTY TWO SIX TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY MAKING A NUMBER
OF COMMONSENSE REFORMS TO
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY REQUEST.
MOST IMPORTANTLY GIVING OUR
FRONT LINE NURSES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT
I'M CHRIS CRITICAL. POSSIBLE
SAFETY DECISIONS. AB FOUR
TWENTY TWO ALSO INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PUBLIC OVERSIGHT AROUND THE
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY PROCESS.
CONSISTENT WITH THE BASIC
NOTION THAT DECISIONS WHICH
IMPACT PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY SHOULD NOT BE HIDDEN
FROM PATIENTS TO THE PUBLIC.
BUT ALSO LIKE TO KNOW THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS MET WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND WE APPRECIATE
THE CRITICAL ROLE OF CNA IN
ESTABLISHING AND DEFENDING
STAFFING RATIOS. THAT IS WHY
WE'VE ALREADY INCORPORATED SOME
OF THEIR HELPFUL FEEDBACK INTO
OUR FIRST ROUND OF AMENDMENTS.
AND WE REMAIN A 100% COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
WITH A CNA NCHA AN EFFORT TO
FIND A WAY FOR THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE. IT'S TIME HOWEVER TO
MOVE FORWARD AND STRENGTHEN THE
PROCESS AROUND PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY REQUEST. OUR
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE HEROES
HAVE GIVEN SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITIES OVER THE PAST YEAR.
AND A BARE MINIMUM WE OWE THEM
THE BASIC COURTESY OF AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VOICE IN
DECISIONS. WHICH CAN HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR HEALTH
THEIR SAFETY AND THEIR
LIVELIHOODS. IN ADDITION TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR
PATIENTS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF FIGHTING FOR WORKERS
AND SERVING OUR COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING SEIU CALIFORNIA YOU
NAP ASKED ME THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR MATT WAS
A FROM US TO YOU CALIFORNIA.
ATTORNEY SERRANO A REGISTERED
NURSE AND I FEEL YOU WANT TO
ONE ARE AND MEMBER. THANK YOU
IT WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GO AHEAD AND ASK THE
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR THE- OF. TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT SKEWS ME. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR CHAIR MEMBERS THAT WAS A
ON BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA
THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO- PERSON
JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON THIS BILL. NURSES ARE
ADVOCATES FOR THEIR PATIENTS
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAFELY VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS REGARDING
CHANGES TO PATIENT CARE GROUP
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY REQUESTED
CRITICAL TO MAINTAIN A HIGH
QUALITY. OF PATIENT CARE THAT
THE PUBLIC EXPECT. CALIFORNIA
WAS THE FIRST IN THE NATION TO
SET MINIMUM RATIOS FOR NURSE TO
PATIENT- BY UNITS- IN THROUGH
THESE RATIOS GO THESE RATIOS
ARE MANDATED BY LAW- HOSPITALS-
BROWN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN. SEVENTEEN
REPEATEDLY VIOLATED- SAFIR
PARLIAMENT'S DUTY TO LOCK UP
ENFORCEMENT. THERE WERE SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR OUT OF
RECIO DEFICIENCIES REPORTED TO
CDPH DURING THAT TIME- AND- SO.
WITH A BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN YES YEAH YOU SPONSORED
S. JUNE TWENTY SEVEN TO IMPOSE
FINES OF HOSPITALS BY FOUND
VIOLATING STAFF REQUIREMENTS
THAT REQUIREMENTS. THERE'S A
BIG ISSUE RATIOS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO IMPROVE NEWSMAX
WELFARE RESULTING IN BETTER
PATIENT CARE AND NEEDS
PROVISION PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK LAW
PUSHED BACK ON THE HOSPITAL'S
EFFORTS TO DATE. RATIO THROUGH
PROGRAMS LIKE TO BELIEVE
REQUIRES HOSPITALS ABLE TO MAKE
CHANGES THAT IMPACT NURSES
STAFFING WITHOUT THE INPUT OF
NURSES BEACH PROGRAM BUT
COMPLETE A REQUEST RANGE FROM
CHANGING THE DESIGNATION OF BAD
FROM HIGH TO YOU TO DELIVER TO
BAD OR CHANGING THE NUMBER OF
INTENSELY NURSES IN THE
NEONATAL INTENSIVE CARE UNIT
THESE CHANGES CANNOT
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
CRITICAL CARE THAT NURSES
PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE- SOMETHING.
AS SIMPLE AS CHANGING THE
DEFINITION OF A BAD- IN THE
END- IN I. C. U. R. NICK YOU-
FROM INTENSIVE CARE
INTERMEDIATE CARE WITHOUT THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT MEANS THAT
OUR MOST CRITICAL PATIENTS. ARE
PUT AT SIGNIFICANT RATES.
DESPITE WITH THE PROGRAM FOR
REQUEST EMPOWER NURSES DAILY BY
AND THE CARE THERE'S NO CURRENT.
FOR THE IMPACTED NURSES TO
VOICE CONCERNS HE BE FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO SIMPLY REQUIRES A
PERIOD OF PUBLIC COMMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE NURSES HAVE.
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE CONCERN
WITH THESE CHANGES. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ALSO
PROMOTES TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT
OF PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY- I
HAVING HE TEACH BOTH THESE
REQUEST ALONG WITH THE
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION ON
THEIR WEBSITE. NURSES ARE OUT
FOR THE AND NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS ARE CRITICAL TO PATIENT
CARE STATE. AT FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO IS NEEDED TO BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO THESE PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THAT NURSES CAN VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS FOR THE
PATIENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS TERRY THROW AND I'M A
NURSE IN A NEONATAL INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT OR NICU TWENTY YEARS
AGO PEOPLE WERE DESIGNATED AS
AN APPROVED NICK YOU BY
CALIFORNIA'S THE CHILDREN
SERVICES AND BACK WHEN WE
REALLY HAD AN IMPACT HE NEEDED
NEEDED TO BE ON THE VENTILATOR
MY HOSPITAL AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH OR
CDPH. THE PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY
WHICH ALLOWED MANAGEMENT TO Q.
R. AND ON THE FLOOR FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS. OVER
TWENTY YEARS WE NOW HAVE A
STATE OF YOUR NECK YOU FOR
EVERY SINGLE BABY ADMITTED TO
THE UNIT IS EXTREMELY HARPER
REQUIRING INTENSE LEVEL CARE
DURING THE OPENING TWENTY
YEARS. THE WHOLE ALSO
DRASTICALLY SLASHED WITH
SCHEDULED TO SUPPORT STAFF LIKE
NURSES DAYS MINOR TEXT AND YOUR
SECRETARY. YEAH HE PHD OVER
NEWS THAT PROGRAM THE YEAR
ALLOWING OUR HOSPITAL THE
UNDERSTAFFED. OR NICK YOU. THE
PROGRAM. ALLOWS HELP WITH THE
THREE OR FOUR. EACH IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE DAY FOR TRYING TO
PAY. THEY REQUIRE. CARE AND
MARK. AND IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
THEM WITH YOUR THEY- WELL HOW
WHO IN TURN UNDER. BUT. I
APPRECIATE ALL IN DEBATE ON.
THERE SOMETIMES AND THEY NEED
CONSTANT BECAUSE- THEY HAVE I.
V. THEY NEED. I'M GONNA RUN FOR
OUR COUNTRY EVERY TIME MINUTES.
YOU GIVE ME AN ADDITIONAL
THREE. AND FAMILY ALL MY COUNTY
PATIENTS AT RISK. ALSO BECAUSE
THE STONE. YOU CAN'T ALWAYS BE
A TO. OUR COLLEAGUES WITH THE
FIFTY THAT WERE TO OUR AN-
ELECTED I HAD. THE TIME HAD A
BABY THE HELP WHO WOULD BLUE
ISN'T CAUGHT SPELLED. I HAD TO
FREQUENTLY SUCH HIM BECAUSE HIS
AIRWAY. THE BABY WAS AND I PLAY.
WANT ANOTHER FOR. I WOULD BUY
MY- A NO MAKING RESOURCE ON
THAT FLOOR NO NURSING NUMBER.
THERAPIST AT ONE POINT WHEN I.
ON A- HE WAS HAVING A REALLY
BAD. FIT THE WAS THERE WITH ME
HE STARTED. I GOT TO BACK TO BE
AND HOW TO HAVE THE- MOM GO.
THERE FOR HELP. IF THAT BABY
COULD YOU TO CO I COULDN'T DO
IT ALONE THAT SEVEN COULD HAVE
DONE. RECENTLY WERE TWO OF US
GOING TO PLUS CHARGE NURSE. I
HAVE ONE VIDEO HEIGHT. GEN THE
OTHER NOTABLE CASE. BUCKLEY
BABY A MOM WALKED INTO
CREATURES TWENTY ONE OF THEM TO
OUR WOULD NOT LIKELY LIVE AFTER.
THE TURKEY NEVER NEEDED MY HELP
THE- TO LIVE. THERE ARE ALWAYS
ABILITY TO. THE DAY UNIT- ALL
TIME BUT WE HAVE TO LEAVE MY
COLLEAGUES. WITH ALL THREE THE
OTHER DAY. CHAU MY ONLY
PATIENT. EVERYTHING THAT THAT
BABY MY COLLEAGUES SAID MY
OTHER PATIENTS. THE BABY WHO
WAS ON THE HIGH FLOW OXYGEN
WHEN I WENT TO CHECK OUT OUR
PREVIOUS SO THEY COULD SHIP
PULLED OUT HER FEEDING TUBE AND
PROJECTILE VOMITED ALL OVER THE
CRIB. IF YOU COULD CHOKE WELL
WITH THE OTHER TWIN. UNABLE TO
LOOK INTO NOTE THAT THERE WAS
AN ISSUE. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
THINK WE CARE FOR ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS THIS WAY. LET ALONE
GET THE KIND OF INDIVIDUALIZED
CARE AND PATIENT EDUCATION. SO
WE WERE TRYING TO PROVIDE. THE
KIND OF HERE BELONG TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF CARE OF THE BABIES
AND NEW CHARACTERS- I. URGE YOU
TO HELP US PROVIDE THE CARE TO
SAVE LIVES AND HELP. OUR
LOCATION. KEEPSAKE PLEASE THE
COURT AB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO.
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE TO. HAVE RAY. WITNESSES AND-
ALTHOUGH I DO. SERVICE ON. SO
WE WILL GO BUT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR-
OPPOSITION IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL I WILL BE ASKING FOR THEIR
NAME. POSITION AND-
ORGANIZATION I WILL I KNOW
THAT- CNA HAS OPPOSITION I WILL
ALLOW THEM TO MINUTES DURING
THAT PERIOD- TO- TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE- LOOK AT MORE
COMMENT THAN EVERYONE ELSE BUT
EVERYONE ELSE IS JUST ASK TO
GIVE- THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON THE BILL. SO MR
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HENLEY'S GERMAN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
AT THIS TIME WITH ABOUT SIX IN
THE QUEUE MISTER CHAIR PLEASE
OKAY GREAT PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. WE WILL START WITH
NUMBER THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF PATRICK WHELAN HERE
ALSO WILL SNAP TO C. ON BEHALF
OF UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED THE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS THAT
YUNEEC YOU H. C. P. PROUD
MEMBER OF ABNEY PARK THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND MEMBERS ARE
PROUD TO BE CO SPONSORS OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO
ALIGN THREE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS AYE
CHAN AYE YOUNG AND I'M A NURSE
AT SAINT JOHN'S THE PLEASANT
VALLEY I'M ON A SUBACUTE UNIT
AND I DO SUPPORT THE SPELL OUT
TO MY CO WORKERS THANK YOU I'M
WITH S. C. I YEAR ONE TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SO THE LINE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR OF
SOVEREIGNTY CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE'RE CURRENTLY IN
THE POST MUST AMENDED POSITION
THAT SUPPORTIVE OF TRANSPARENCY
BUT CONCERNED ABOUT THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD INTERFERING WITH
REAL TIME WAKE BELIEVERS NEED
FOR PATIENT SAFETY CREATED
INITIAL DISCUSSION WITH THE
AUTHOR SPONSOR LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
CLICK ON THE LINE ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CATHERINE KENNEDY PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THREE ONE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAU DONAHUE
REGISTERED NURSE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE FOUR TWO
TWO. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE ALIGN THREE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHAPTER COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARIA THERE IS A BIGGER
WITH THE LOCAL THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE ENOUGH IS ENOUGH-
EIGHTY FOURTH INFANTRY. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WILL
NOW MOVE THE LINE TO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I ANY
CORTES ON THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED DAVID- BILL AND THIS IS
VERY DANGEROUS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL
NOW READ ONLINE ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS VIRGINIA LEASE AREA I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FOUR
TWO TWO PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SOME OF THE LINE
THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE LED
BY CHAIR MASON NUMBERS TO HELP
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VICKY
PREMIERED AND I AM AN RN
INSTINET ACTED ON THE NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS- WE JUST WANT TO
BRING OUT THE POINTS THAT THE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS AB
THREE NINETY FOUR- REACHED ANY
CHANGES AND THEM ARE RESTRICTED
TO RURAL HOSPITALS. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL
UNDERMINES THE NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS BY IMPLYING THAT THERE
IS AUTHORITY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NOT CURRENTLY. THREE AND NOW.
UP POINTS OUT THE GDP- HAS.
TWENTY PROGRAM NINE. LIKE BUT
WITH THEIR TALKING ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC FLEX WAIVERS WHICH
WILL EXPIRE ONCE THE
PENDENTIVES OVER- OUR CONCERN
IS ABOUT THIS BILL AND WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN AFTER. THE OPTION
DOWN NEXT- AND IF HE- OFFICES
CAN YOU RIGHT NOW IT'LL BE MORE
CONFUSING IF THIS LEGISLATION
PASSES WERE IN OPPOSITION. AND
THE ONLY UNITS THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE THE PROGRAMS I COULD
BE AND I FEW ICO AND- THE
OPERATING ROOM- THE PROBLEM'S
BEEN EXCUSE WE RECOGNIZE BUT
THAT REALLY IS A PROBLEM WITH
THE PATIENT CLASSIFICATION
SYSTEM AND YOUR PRO. STAFFING
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT WILL
COUNT AS THE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY SO EVERYBODY ELSE
FROM HERE ON OUT IS JUST NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. A TWO
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY MY NAME GUILTY
VERDICT CENTERS AT COMMON.
GETTING NORTHRIDGE HOSPITAL AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER
JOINING THE QUEUE TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. I WILL MOVE TO LINE
THREE FORTY TWO- LINE THREE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET
ME CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU HELLO. HI MY NAME IS
THAT MONIQUE MICHAEL HERNANDEZ
I'M A NURSE AT RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.%
AT THE TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MINISTER RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GAVE REFERRING
IN THE LEGISLATION FOR- AS WE
ALL KNOW NURSE TO PATIENT RATIO
RATIOS ARE VITAL BECAUSE THEY
ENSURE PATIENTS RECEIVE QUALITY
CARE. ADDED THIS CREASES THE
CHANCES OF NURSES MAKING
MISTAKES AS A RESULT OF BEING
PLACED IN POSITIONS WHERE THEY
CANNOT APPROPRIATELY CARE FOR
THE PATIENTS I UNDERSTAND WHY
ANY CHANGES TO IT OR NOT BEING
TAKEN LIGHTLY SO I HOPE THAT
YOU IN THE SPONSORS AND THE
OPPOSITION WILL WORK TOGETHER
MOVING FORWARD GIVEN THE BOTH
REPRESENT OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS AND HAVE THE SAME GOALS
WHICH IS PATIENT AND DINNER
SAFETY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR RODRIGUEZ. I ALSO
WANTED TO SPEAK TO OFFER.
REGARDING OF THE PATIENT
RACHEL'S I'M OVERSEE PATIENT
RATIOS ARE THERE TO PROTECT
OVERSEE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE PATIENTS BUT MOST PORTED
TO TAKE OVER OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS ARE NURSES IN THIS CASE
THAT ARE DAY IN DAY OUT
WORKING- THESE FACILITIES
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SPECIAL NOW
WITH THE PANDEMIC. I JUST WANT
TO. WHERE'S THAT THE AUTHOR CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND MAKE SURE THAT
THESE FLEXIBILITY REQUEST DO
NOT COMPROMISE PATIENT CARE
SAFETY. THAT WE MAKE SURE F.
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD. THAT
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE AWAY
WERE THERE ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE. AND AS I WAS READING-
SOME OF THE ROLE OF THE LETTER
FROM OPPOSITION REGARDING SOME
ISSUES I WISH THEY WOULD BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH THE
MORNING BECAUSE- TO THE COULD
BE MERIT ON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT THEY TALK ABOUT IN THE
LETTER I WAS READY. BUT THAT I
AM LOOKING FOR TO SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT I. AM ALSO TORN
ABOUT IT BUT- WITH THAT
HOPEFULLY AS THIS BILL MOVES
OUT. THERE WE CAN SPIN YOU
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE DIALOGUE.
WITH BOTH- ORGANIZATIONS
BECAUSE I WHICH IS VERY RARE
THAT WE HAVE. TO- ORGANIZATION
BY THE SAME SO TO JUST. WE'RE
ON DIFFERENT SIDES LIKE THEY
ARE TODAY- BUT HOPEFULLY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONTINUE WORK
WITH THEM AND BRING FOLKS
TOGETHER HOPE WE GET EVERYBODY
OUT A BETTER PLACE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROTECT THE PATIENT
RATIOS AND PROTECT OUR NURSES
ABOUT PATIENTS OUT THERE DAY IN
AND DAY OUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- NEXT. QUESTION IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I- I WAS
GONNA ASK A QUESTION FROM THE
AUTHOR ABOUT- THESE AMENDMENTS
I RECEIVED- TODAY FROM CNA BUT-
BUT AS I UNDERSTAND ALSO THIS
MAY HAVE ARRIVED. LATE ENOUGH
WHERE- THE AUTHOR MAY HAVE NOT
EVEN SEEN IT- ACTUALLY I WOULD
ADD THAT THE CHAIRS NOT SEEN
THESE AMENDMENTS EITHER. OKAY
SO- I'M HAPPY TO SHARE IT WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR. HAPPY TO
BELIEVE LAW CENTER TEN THEM
TODAY. NO NO THAT'S NOT THE
OBJECTIVE THE ONLY OBJECTIVE IS
TO SAY THAT WHEN I WAS
REVIEWING THESE- AMENDMENTS
THEY JUST SEEM TO BE- SPEAKING
TO THE SAME LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY THAT I BELIEVE
THE- I STRONGLY FEEL THE AUTHOR
WOULD BE IN AGREEMENT WITH SO I
WOULD. JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THE UP WITH CNA- AND TO
COME TO A RESOLUTION ON. ON
SOME OF THESE AMENDMENTS THAT.
AT FIRST GLANCE DIDN'T SEEM TO
BE- ANYTHING THAT WOULD FOR
YOUR EFFORTS. SO I WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND
CONTINUE ALSO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN JUST ONE
ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD TO SAY
THAT THIS IS THE- FIRST HOUSE.
IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE AND I
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE WEARING YOUR
APPROACH- MR GABRIEL TO WORK
WITH ALL PARTIES AND ANYONE WHO
WALKS THROUGH YOUR DOOR SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO CONTINUE TO
COLLABORATE WITH WORK WITH AND
LISTEN TO THE OPPOSITION TO
HELP GET THE PLACE TO HELP YOU
THEY CAN BECOME NEUTRAL. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE- JUST A COMMENT
AND THAT'S- I WANT TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL IT HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I THINK NURSES
SUPPORT NURSES IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AND THE PROGRAM FLEX
IDPH IS OUTDATED AND OPAQUE- I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP WORKING
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND DPH TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS SOMEWHAT
CONCERNED IT SIXTY DAYS MIGHT
ADD ADDITIONAL COMPLEXITY- TO
AN ALREADY COMPLICATED PROCESS
I DO AGREE THAT NURSES SHOULD
HAVE PRIOR TO PRIOR KNOWLEDGE
OF CHANGES- WHEN A HUSBAND
PROPOSES CHANGES TO THE RATIOS
BUT I I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THE
TIMING ON THAT SO. SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
MISTER GABRIEL YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
PREFIGURE COMMENTS WANT TO
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES- CERTAINLY
ARE A HUNDRED PERCENT-
INTENTION TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH BOTH TO SEE
ON A NCHA- AS I MENTIONED. THEY
HAVE RAISED ON BOTH SIDES AND
POINTS FOR US TO CONSIDER WE'VE
ALREADY TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY CNA I
GUESS I'LL JUST CLOSE BY I'M
SORT OF ECHOING SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FOR MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WHICH IS YOU
KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT IN THE
PAST YEAR ABOUT OUR FRONTLINE
HEALTH CARE HEROES AND ALL THE
SACRIFICES THAT THEY MADE FOR
ALL OF US TO PROTECT US GOING
INTO WORK DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
RISKING THEIR LIVES PUTTING
THEIR FAMILIES AT SAFETY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THIS BILL BASICALLY ASK THE
SIMPLE QUESTION WHICH IS DO
THEY DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON CHANGES THAT WILL
IMPACT THEIR SAFETY AND THE
SAFETY OF THE PATIENTS THAT
THEY SERVE AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT THAT
IS A RESOUNDING YES AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A. DAD WINNER
TINA MOTION- MOST BY- MYSTERY
BUSINESS. BY MID AND IS A- THE
IS PASS AS A MAN TO A PRO.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NARROW BONTA
BONTA HI BURKE. CARILLO
CARRILLO HI LAURA. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN HIGH RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. EIGHT TO ONE THE BILL
HAS EIGHT HAVE BEEN BILLS OUT
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS AND I THINK YOU MISTER
GABRIEL THANK YOU MOVING ON NOW
TO- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
TEN THIRTY MISTER GIBSON.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN THIRTY EIGHT. WHICH
SEEKS TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM FUND TO
REDUCE. THE ON JOBS- IMPACT ON
CORPORATE NINETEEN. NOW AND
INTO THE FUTURE THIS BILL WOULD
SUPPORT PARTNERSHIP AMONG
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
COMMUNITY CLINICS STRIVE
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. THAT SERVE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THESE
ENTITLES WILL CREATE STRATEGIES
TAILORED. TO LOCAL NEEDS AND
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE OF
INEQUITIES THAT EXIST BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. AND HAVE ONLY
WORSENED. THESE ISSUES INCLUDE
HOUSING AND FOOD INSECURITY
EMPLOYMENT INSTABILITIES UNDER
RESOURCE SCHOOL CARE UNDER
UNDERSTAND A RESOURCE SCHOOLS
AND CHILDCARE COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE AND HATE CRIMES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE. AS WE
KNOW RACISM IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IT IS THIS SYSTEM THAT
ASSIGNS VALUES DETERMINES
OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON THE WAY.
WE'LL LOOK AT COLOR AT THE SKIN
AT THE COLOR OF INDIVIDUAL
SKIN. THIS IMPACT OF RACISM
AFFECTS WHERE ONE LIVES LEARN
WORK AND WORSEN. THIS CREATES
INEQUITIES IN ACCESS TO SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS LIKE
HOUSING EDUCATION WELFARE AND
EMPLOYMENT THESE ARE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS THAT DRIVE HELLO
EQUITIES IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. IT PUTS THANK YOU IT PUT
HIGH RISKS OF POOR PEOPLE AND-
DIMINISHES THEIR HEALTH
OUTCOMES BIG A COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- IS ONLY
ANOTHER STARK EXAMPLE OF THESE
ONGOING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC DATA
SHOWS THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
EXPERIENCE HIGHER RATES OF
ILLNESS AND PERMADEATH ACROSS A
WIDE RANGE OF HEALTH CONDITIONS
WHEN COMPARED TO WHITE
COMMUNITIES THESE CONDITIONS
INCLUDES DIABETES HYPERTENSION-
OBESITY ASTHMA AND HEART
DISEASE. N. THE LIFE EXPECTANCY
OF A NON HISPANIC SLASH BLACK
AMERICANS IS FOUR YEARS LOWER
THAN A WHITE AMERICAN. THIS
IMPORTANT THIS INFORMATION
SHOWS US THAT THE IMPACT OF THE
STRUCTURAL RACISM IS PERVASIVE
AND DEEPLY ROOTED IN OUR
SOCIETY WE NEED TO BUILD A HELP
SOCIETY FOR EVERYONE AND I
REPEAT THAT EVERYONE AND TO DO
THIS WE MUST CONFRONT SYSTEMS
AND POLICIES THAT RESULTS IN A
GENERATIONAL INJUSTICE. THIS
ISN'T NEW INFORMATION BUT
SOLUTIONS HAVE BEEN SLOW WE
MUST STEP INTO THIS AB STEP
INTO AND STOP THE CYCLE NOW IS
THE TIME TO ACT. IMMEDIATELY IN
ADDITION TO ADDRESSING TODAY'S
MOST URGENT PROBLEM THIS BILL
WOULD HELP BUILD COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE TO WEATHER THE STORM
TO WEATHER THE STORMS FOR
FUTURE DISASTERS. THIS IS THE
ONLY THIS IS THE ONLY BEGINNING
ASSEMBLY BILL ON TEN THIRTY
EIGHT WILL CREATE A PARADIGM
SHIFT FOR HOW WE INVEST IN
COMMUNITIES BY SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS THAT KEEP PEOPLE FROM-
NEEDING HEALTHCARE AND IN THE
FOR IN THE FIRST PLACE. THIS
APPROACH PROMOTES JUSTICE SAVE
LIVES AND HELP- TO REDUCE THE
COST OF MEDICARE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES
IS A MEMBER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK. AND
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND AFTER ADDRESS
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TO
PROTOTYPE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR GIPSON- STROP WRITER YOU CAN
OPEN THE LINE FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
WHENEVER THEY'RE READY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTY MONEY FOR SO
LONG AND DO WE HAVE AN
INTERPRETER ON THE LINE PERFECT
THANK YOU YES. YES WE DO. OKAY
PERFECT NOT ENOUGH TO GET A
BETTER LOOK AT THE MONEY
ALREADY THANK YOUNG AT THE
BOARDING GATE. THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH WHEN THEY COME INSIDE HE
MET WHETHER THAT ENOUGH ABOUT
THE CATTLE PUBLIC BY AND- UNITS
BUT A BULLET ENTERED THE TOP.
ANOTHER APPLE. HE OKAY- ORDER
NUMBER IS NOT ENOUGH DATA IN
THE FIFTY MINUTE FIVE OUGHT TO
BE OUT OF IT DO YOU THINK THAT
YOU. MY NAME IS. LORRAINE HOW
HANNAH AND- MY TESTIMONY IS IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. AT.
EIGHTY TEN THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
YES HELLO FROM A FOUR MONTH OLD
OTHER SALUTE FOR MY FIFTIETH
ANNUAL BUT I MEAN OF THE LOCAL.
WHICH I LIVE IN LAS. AND I'VE
WORKED AS A PROBLEM WITH ASK
FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF THE
COMMUNITY. I THE MUNICIPAL. OF
IT THIS IS AN EMERGENCY BASED
KNOW THAT. ALSO SUFFERED FROM
DIABETES AND THYROID SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD. INDEPENDENCIA COMO
FORMAL DON'T UNDERSTAND ALL THE
COMMODITIES THAT PICKED UP FOR
THE SECOND BECAUSE YOUNG. YOUR
LOCAL MONOPOLY THAT LUCKY
ENOUGH TO PUT IT THE NEW JERSEY
IN MAKING OTHER OF PANICKED
ECONOMY CLASS. IN FACT ON THE
SALUTE INDEED ONE ECONOMY. BACK
IN MY- AS A PRO TORA AND AS
SOME WHO. HAS DIED BE. I'VE
SEEN. DILLON COMMUNITY THE- BY
THE INEQUITY OF SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES AND IMPACTED
THEIR HEALTH AND BEING
COMMUNITIES ENTIRE HEALTH. I'M
GONNA BE DOINGNUMBER TWO KNOW
MORE ABOUT THAT IS THE ONE THAT
YOU THE BCS. MOTOR THEN THE
WHOLE ROOM AT THE- COMMON IN
THE BUDGET. CANNOT BALANCE WITH
THE WHO THOUGHT HE DATA. FROM
THE PHASE BEATING ME THAT. EVEN
BEFORE THE COURT VIRUS WE WERE
FACING A LOT OF INEQUITY. I A
LOT OF A WHO ARE LOOKING WORK
IN JOB. THAT ARE LOW PAYING DAY
ARE WE ARE NOT OFFERED I JUST
BALLERINI AND RESPECTED. THIS
ECONOMIC AMEND STATE GOVERNMENT
STATES IN SOUTHERN. LOOK AT THE
ME ASK THE NAME OF OKAY UP OF
ENTERING. IN BUT I FEEL I'M
LOOKING ON WITHIN THEM OKAY AND
THE FUNDING. ONE FROM THE
MOMENT THE. THAT US. STRUGGLING
AT THE AND SO- AND IN AN
UNSTABLE THE- WE HAVE TO PAY
HIGH RENT COMPARED TO WHAT WE
EARN SUPPORTER FAN AND TO ON
THE. ECONOMY REMARKS AND OF
OCTOBER. THE MOM FROM THE EVEN
ALSO ON THE RUN HAVE. TO HANDLE
MUCH OF THE LAST AND IDEA. THE
HUNDRED FORTY MILES SOMEONE
USES TO THE ANSWER NOT BUT AND
THEN WE BEGAN INSULT THE ANIMAL
JUST THE UNITED. A LOT OF US
LIVE IN LOW. RESOURCE TO. WHERE
EITHER SERVICE ARE NOT AND THEY-
OR THERE MAY QUALITY- HELLO
FIRST AND DON'T LEARN. ONE OF
THE LOCAL NOT READING THE
COMMISSION IS ENOUGH FOR ME
THAT THE BILL RATTLE. BLACK
PAINTED LIBERALISM THE NAV OWN
MONITOR SO THEY CAN FIFTH AVE
PHONE. THAT HE'S BEEN THERE
FROM YOU NOT TOPIC THAT A LOT
DAYS. I WONDER BY STREP. HE
STILL HAD TO WORK IT ONE IN THE
FUTURE OF WHETHER THEY WERE
GOING TO WORK OR NOT. IT WAS
THAT THEY STILL HAD TO GO TO
WORK. YOU CONFIRM THE CHANCES
ARE GONNA CALL ME THAT OKAY LET
GET SOME OF THE MAMMOTH OF A
HOT. YOU'RE ONE OF THE FACTORS
INFLUENCING IDEAS THE IBM
INDIA. VICTOR. ALPHA MAYBE EVEN.
YEAH THE- WITH MIDDLE DATE UP
IN EITHER WITH. BECAUSE THE LOT
OF COMMUTE- THANKS TO COME.
PEOPLE GO TO WORK AND COME BACK
WONDERING IF SOMEBODY IN THE
HOUSEHOLD WHAT IMPACTED WITH
THE VIRUS BUT THEY WERE VERY
FEARFUL TO ASK FOR HELP. IBM
WATSON'S REMOTE IS THE KEY
ELEMENT FOR THE POOL SEVEN
UNLESS THERE'S SOME OF. THE
TIME B. M. ONE THIRTY EIGHT I
DON'T KNOW THE FULL NOT.
CHEROKEE A WOMAN BUT SOME OF
THE MOST THING IN THAT CASE. I
WAS US IN THIS BOOK IN THE
FINANCING. SOPHIA THERE WERE
ROOM ABOUT PEOPLE DIPPED. AND
ONE THE VACCINE DERIVED. WE
WERE HEARING RUMORS. OF PEOPLE
NOT BEING ACCESS. AT BEING ABLE
TO ACCESS THE VACCINE BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A CLOSE WITH
THE KERRY NUMBER. I'M GONNA FOR
SOME OF THE HELLO THIS IS
INSANITY. CAN ALISAL SYSTEM A
LOT FROM THEM YET ABOUT THE
LAST YOU. NOTICE THE MOST THAT
YOU LOVE BUT ALSO SENATE
UNDERSUPPLY MEDIA. AND ALTHOUGH
ARE IF WORKERS HELPED THE
ECONOMY DURING PANDA. WE
RECEIVED NO HELP TO HELP. TO
SUSTAIN OUR FAMILY. WHAT IS
YOUR MOBILE THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM MONTH GIVE
ONE OF THE FEW THAT ALSO
BENEFIT THOUGH THE THING NUMBER
WILL NOT BE THAT YOU'RE NOT
DONE WITH MONTHS. SPENT. THAT'S
WHY WE NEED TO SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR US SO THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT A MORE JOB. AN
EQUITABLE LIFE AND HELP. THANK
YOU WE LIKE YOU TO COME UP ON
THE THIRD. I THANK PEOPLE
TRANSIT BUT GAVE NO POINT
DEPARTMENT I'VE LEFT A LITTLE
BIT LESS DOESN'T HAVE A WHOLE
JUST FOR SOURCE. MY WORK AS A
PLUMBER DORA IN POOR BECAUSE WE
ARE A SOURCE. OF HELPING OTHERS
IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH. I'M A
PROMOTER IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
CENTRAL SIX ONE UNIPER EVEN
THEN WITH THE FEW ON THE LEFT
AT IT IN THE FILM. AND STUFF-
BESSEMER CANADA'S. IN THE CLASS
THIRTY MUSICAL- GET THE MY
BECAUSE MANY CHAU. HERE AT OUR
HOME OFF WOMAN FROM A DONOR YOU.
FOR THE THAT DIFFERENCE WITH US
BUT I MISSED. AS A PROBLEM I
CLASS. ONLINE EVERY FROM.
SEXUAL AND WE- HEALTH NEEDS.
MENTAL SUGAR IN DIETS. IF WHO
HAVE TAKEN MIKE AND OTHER
DAUGHTER STATED IDEA JOB. AND
THAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE
CHANGES TO A THEIR HOW. I'M IT
IS THE PROBLEM WHOLE THE- OF.
THE MIDDLE- YOUR POINT LEAVE A-
YOU WILL THE CALL. WHAT IT THE
SPEED UP OF ALL. WITH A LOT OF
A THOUGHT. ATTENDED FOR YA. IT
FORMED ALL BUT I DOZEN. I THE
WAY I DO AND I FEEL PROUD OF
ABLE TO. HELP FOSTER POSITIVE
CHANGE IN MY CAN. PLEASE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT MY WORK BY
APPROVING THAT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR LOW DOCUMENTS.
A PROGRAMMER TO PROMOTE BUT I
JUST REMEMBER THAT IS NOT
ACTIVE. THIS PROGRAM WOULD
OFFER MORE FUN TO. PROGRAMS
LIKE PROMOTE TODAS AND OTHER
RESOURCES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS AND WE'VE KIND OF
GONE WELL OVER OUR TESTIMONY
TIME SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE
KEEP IT TO THREE MINUTES AT
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS EUGENE CAMPING SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK WHICH IS
THE STATEWIDE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO IMPROVE
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING A
BLACK CALIFORNIA. SHOULD BE A
CHANGE ALONGSIDE THE OTHER
COSPONSORED STRONGLY SUPPORT
CAN BE BUILT IN THIRTY EIGHT TO
CREATE A HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM
I NEED THIS PROGRAM IS BECOMING
APPARENT ACROSS THE BAR AND
THEN THEY CAN EXACERBATE AND
AMPLIFY THE INEQUITIES AND
VULNERABILITIES THAT HAVE LONG
EXISTED IN OUR COMMUNITY. IF
YOU WANT TO TRULY ADDRESS THE
INEQUITYTHAT EXISTS WE MUST
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES YOU
MUST LOOK AT SCREEN AND BETTER
PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION. AND
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH- TEN THIRTY EIGHT ALLOW
CRITICAL AND- TO BE DIRECTED
TO. COMMUTER ORGANIZER. CLINICS
TRAVEL ORGANISER. AND LOCAL.
HELP JUNIOR YOU CAN
ORGANIZATIONS. THIS HAVE A
GREAT UNDERSTANDING OF THE
NEEDS AND BARRIERS THAT ARE
TAKING A COMMUNITY. LEGISLATION
WILL ENCOURAGE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN ENTITIES AND ALLOW FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS HOUSING SECURITY. FOOD
SECURITY ECONOMIC INSTABILITY
CHILD CARE AND THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. FOR EXAMPLE. IS
PROGRAMS SUPPORT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE WORKING
TO PROVIDE HOUSING SUPPORTS
THAT IS EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSE. ACCORDING
TO A REPORT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT. BLACK CALIFORNIANS
MAKE UP NEARLY 40% OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
OUR STATE. GET THAT. ACCOUNT
FOR JUST OVER 6% CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION. THIS CALL GRANT
WILL POINT INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES AND PARTNERSHIPS THE
HOUSE OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
ADDRESS THE INEQUITIES IN
HOMELESSNESS. THE PROGRAM WILL
ALSO WORK TO SUPPORT IMPORTANT
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS FOOD
SECURITY ACCOUNT OTHER DRESSING
NOT JUST THE QUANTITY OF FOOD
THAT IS AVAILABLE NOT
COMMITTEES BUT THE QUALITY OF
FOOD AVAILABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. INNOVATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN CLINICS
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
HAVE SHOWN TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HEALTHY FOOD TO
HELP PEOPLE DESCRIPTION
PROGRAMS AND PARTNERSHIPS
RETAILERS THIS PROGRAM WILL
SUPPORT. THOSE EFFORTS AND
OTHER INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES. IN
THE BUILDING ARE GETTING. THAT
TO HELP EQUITY CO TO DO IT NAME.
AS WE ALL KNOW IT QUICKLY AND
THAT THE- THAT CAN. THAT NEED
THIS. ACT TO THIS PRO. THANK
YOU DELIVER IT TO SUPPORTING
HARD BY THE CORONA VIRUS AND
GIMMICK A SEPARATE FROM CHRONIC
UNDERINVESTMENT AND GET THE
BEST. TYPICALLY INTERPOLATION
PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION AND
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. BILL WILL ESTABLISH AN
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAM OPERATION AND
EQUITABLE MANNER THAT THE
COMMUNITIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS. ARE
NOT LEFT BEHIND. AS I CLOSE I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE HELP
MEDIAN THE LEGISLATURE. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT IN FRONT OF US. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WRITE A
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
WRONG FOR FAR TOO LONG. BUT
THAT PROSPECT WHICH URGES
SUPPORT FOR THIS. BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL BRING BACK TO
THE CAN FOR. ARE MISS WELL.
DOES THIS WORK YES. THANK YOU
NO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT THAT- YOU KNOW COLD IT
DID UNCOVER A LOT OF- SYSTEMIC
FAILURES SURROUNDING OUR
EXISTING PARADIGMS FROM EVD
PROBLEMS DMV. TO THE RAMPANT
EXPOSURES IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
AND YOU KNOW AS THE AUTHOR HAS
M. EMPHASIZED THE DIRE AND HARD
BRAKING- AND EQUITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN WATCHED BY OVER NINETEEN.
IN A UNDERSERVED AND HIGH RISK
COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW IT
DOES NO GOOD TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
INEQUITIES WITH OUR DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT- SO THIS BILL
AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT WILL START
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT WHICH
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T LET WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED NO JUST. LIKE SO
MANY THINGS WE DO ANALYSIS AND
STUDIES AND THEN WE PUT IT ON
THE SHELF AND COLLECT DUST- YOU
KNOW GIVING THE FUNDING TO
NONPROFITS CLINICS TRIBES AND
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS- YOU
KNOW CAN THEN USE THE FUNDING
TO ENGAGE THE LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPLEMENT. NET
BASED INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS
THAT WILL RESULT IN DECREASED
RISK. WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT-
FOR PREVENTABLE ILLNESSES AND
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
SO YOU KNOW THOSE THINGS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT SOURCE FROM
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THIS CARILLO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD
LIKE TO AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL AND
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR IF YOU CONSIDER ME
ADDING AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT I THINK
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO
ONE- THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. MISTER THIS AREA AND
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO
WHICH LIKE CLOSE MISTER GIPSON
THANK YOU VERY MCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE WANT TO ALSO
THANK- THOSE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM CALIFORNIA- BLACK HEALTH
NETWORK AND ALSO TO HELP
PREVENT ORDER. A LORRAINE FOR
BEING WITH US AND TESTIFYING-
THAT THIS PANDEMIC HAVE SHOWN
US ALL WITH THERE'S A LOT OF
HOLES THAT NEED TO BE FIELD.
AND CERTAINLY THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I WANT TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL AND ASK COMMITTEE FOR-
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE SENATE
BILL TEN THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MY ERROR I
DIDN'T GO TO THE WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE- SO MY APOLOGIES SO-
NINE WITNESSES- TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL JUST YOUR- NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION. ON
THE BILL SO SORRY I GOT A- GOT
AHEAD OF MYSELF SO MR. OR WHEN
YOU'RE READY. UNLADEN GERMAN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THE P. TEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN IN
THE QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY.
WE'LL START WITH LINE TWO
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ERIC PAIN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN
INSTITUTE IN THE SPIRIT OF
GEORGE FLOYD WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY EIGHT
AS A DOWN PAYMENT FOR THE
SYSTEMIC CHANGE WE NEED TOWARD
HEALTH EQUITY THANK YOU M
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU AND
JUST TO NAME POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE NEXT TO
THE LINE THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RONALD COLEMAN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. WELL NOW MOVES THE LINE
THREE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JENNIFER LAWRENCE BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT WE APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT GETTING A LETTER IN.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT NEXT TO THE NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF CAN ROUND
ON BEHALF OF YOU TO CHANGE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M TRACY
RESTAURANTS REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. I'LL GO TO NUMBER THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON OFF TO SEND OF
ALL BEING YOUR GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER YOU'RE LOOKING
A QUOTE FOR ALL THE CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
AND THIRTY EIGHT THANK. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TEXAS
NUMBER THREE FORTY SIX THESE
GUYS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JAMIE MORGAN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PARTICIPATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER
THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JACQUELYN DO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATE IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA
NURTURE SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT IN LINE TO
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR
LENDS OVER FORMALLY SONOMA
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER AND
CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UCSF I AM
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THE
VARIETY THE RANGE OF NUMBERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO WE BRING IT BACK
WE HAVE- A MOTION BY MISSION IS
AREA SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
MOTION TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
OF BELIEVE YOU CLOSE BEFORE I.
THRIVING OFF WITH THEM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHEN I WHEN I MAYES THANK YOU.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO BONTA.
BURKE CAREER I CAN FLOOR.
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
CAN NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I REQUEST.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ FIVE THANK
YOU SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON
AYE THANK YOU. SIX SIX TWO ONE
SIX ONE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GIBSON. MOVING ON TO MISS- WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE US-
WE COULD START WITH EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY ONE PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB SEVEN FIVE
ONE WILL PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED
COUNTY RECORDER'S TO ACCEPT
ELECTRONIC REQUESTS TO ACCESS
CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS WHICH
ARE BIRTH MARRIAGE AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES. CURRENTLY TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES USE REMOTE-
IDENTITY PROOFING TO PROCESS
THESE REQUESTS INCLUDING MY
HOME COUNTY OF INTER A- IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAINTAIN A
SAFE CONVENIENT ACCESS O
VITAL. RECORDS WHICH ARE OFTEN
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN BENEFITS
SERVICES OR INSURANCE TO ENSURE
THE SECURITY OF THESE RECORDS
AB SEVEN FIVE ONE UPDATES THE
STATUTE TO ADHERE TO THE GOLDEN
STANDARD OF INFORMATION
SECURITY. THE NEXT STANDARD OR
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY. THIS
BILL REQUIRES ELECTRONIC
REQUEST TO BE VALIDATED THROUGH
A MULTI LAYERED REMOTE IDENTITY
PROOFING PROCESS THAT VERIFIES
THIS IDENTITY ASSURANCE LEVEL
TO. EXISTING LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES AN ELECTRONIC
STATEMENTS FOREIGN UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. THAT APART-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ROUTINELY CITES AND
UTILIZES THE STANDARDS TO GUIDE
INFORMATION SECURITY FOR THE
STATE. BIRD PROVIDING THE CODE
TO REFLECT NEW STANDARDS AB
SEVEN FIVE ONE FOLLOWS THE
PRACTICE OF CD T. AS WELL AS
IMPORTANT- PROVIDES IMPORTANT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LAW.
ALLOWING FOR ALTERNATIVE HERE-
TYPES OF VERIFICATION TO BE
USED. WITH THIS PROGRAM SUNSET
IN THIS YEAR WE NEED TO TAKE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
FROM OUR CALIFORNIANS WILL LOSE
THE ABILITY TO REQUEST COPIES
OF VITAL RECORDS ONLINE. WITH
ME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
MARKLAND VENTURA COUNTY
RECORDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION.
OF CALIFORNIA AND- LEAH AT
NIGHT TAKE. FROM TECHCONNECT.
IT IS ON THE LINE FOR TECH TEST
IS TO GROW CIRCLE PLACE FOR OF
TIME TRACK. VERY WELL THANK YOU-
OPERATIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
OPEN THE LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IN OTHER
LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE WOULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARKLAND OF CASTING OF
THE COUNTY RECORDER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO THE ELECTED BEEN TURRET
COUNTY RECORDER CLERK AND
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS FIRST I
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR ONE FOR HER
WORK ON ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIFTY ONE AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. GIVEN THE
RECENT CONSTRAINTS OF THE
PANDEMIC INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPTION OF
WALKING INTO A GOVERNMENT
OFFICE IN CONDUCTING THEIR
ROUTINE BUSINESS THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE COUNTY RECORDER'S
MAY PROVIDE THE GREATER.
FLEXIBILITY TO THE PUBLIC WHEN
REQUESTING A VITAL RECORD BY
ELIMINATING THE REQUIREMENT FOR
APPLICANTS TO SEEK OUT AND
APPEAR BEFORE A NOTARY PUBLIC.
IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO COME
INTO OUR OFFICES AND DO IT IN
PERSON. THE ONLINE
AUTHENTICATION OPTIONS BRINGS
EQUITY FOR ALL PEOPLE NEEDING
THEIR OR THEIR LOVED ONES BY-
RECORDS. THIS BILL ELIMINATES A
SUNSET DATE OF JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THIS
ONLINE REQUEST PROCESS. AND
ALLOWS THOSE COUNTY IS
CURRENTLY OFFERING THE PROCESS
THE ABILITY TO CONTINUE USING A
MULTI LAYERED PROOFING PROCESS.
TO ELECTRONICALLY VERIFY THE
IDENTITY OF AN APPLICANT FOR
VITAL RECORDS. ELIMINATING THE
SUNSET DATE WOULD GIVE NON
PERSONS PARTICIPATING COUNTIES
THE ABILITY AND CONFIDENCE TO
ENROLL THEIR COUNTIES INTO THIS
PROCESS. WE ARE NOT TECHNOLOGY
EXPERTS SO WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
EXPERTISE. AND GUIDANCE WITH
BUSINESS STANDARDS ARTICULATED.
AS WE ARE COMMITTED TO
INCREASED CUSTOMER SERVICE
ACCESS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
SECURITY. THIS BILL WOULD EASE
THE BURDEN ON COUNTIES AND THE
PUBLIC ALIKE AS WELL AND MAKE
THE PROCESS MORE EFFECTIVE AND
LESS COSTLY. THANK YOU AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF ALL. COUNTY RECORDER
INTO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AFTERNOON
CARE NUMBER MY NAME IS LI ANY
POCKET AND I'M THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PACKED
NOT. LIKE NOT IN THE NATIONAL
BIPARTISAN NETWORK OF TECH CEOS
AND SENIOR EXECUTIVES THAT THE
GROWTH OF THE INNOVATION
ECONOMY. TECHNOLOGY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE
WHICH WOULD REMOVE A SUNSET TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO CONTINUE
TO REQUEST THEIR VITAL RECORDS.
YEAH AND I WOULD TRY TO QUOTE
ALL STATE REGISTRAR LOCAL
REGISTRAR. OR CRANK COUNTY
RECORDER. WE'VE SEEN DURING THE
PAST YEAR AND A LIST TO THE-
JUST HOW. IT IS TO HAVE ALL
TURNED OPTION TO ADD AND QUEST
BY- RECORD YEAH LIKE TRYING TO.
BE VITAL RIGHT. BEING STARTED
COPY OF BIRTH DEATH AND
MARRIAGE TO. WE MY ENSURE TYPE
OF FUNCTION IT PROTECTED FUTURE
UNFORESEEN CHECK. EIGHTY SEVEN
FIVE ONE INSURANCE AT AN APP BY
AND- BY MY- LAYERED REMOTE.
PROCESS IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO ACT
AS THEIR BACK BASICALLY AND-
RETAINING A MUCH NEEDED PROMOTE.
THAT WALK INTO TO COME ACT TO
CRITICAL. RELATED TO MANY OF
MOST THE EVENTS. FOR THESE
REASONS TECHNO THE COURT EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY RED OFF. TO
THE BILL WE GO AHEAD TO MOVE
THE PHONE WILL ASKING. SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISS ROBERT PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR. ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
AND LATER JOHN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THERE
ARE CURRENTLY THREE IN OUR
QUEUE RIGHT THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. WE'LL
START WITH LINE THREE THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVERY
BREATH ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NOW GO TO NUMBER THREE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE NUMBER-
CAN ATTENTION WITH THE PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
UNDER CARE- THE OPPOSITION WAS
UNAWARE OF THE COMMITTEES
DEADLINE AND WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE FOR ME TO SPEAK FOR
ONE MINUTE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. YES I'M GONNA MAKE IT
REALLY CLEAR FOR EVERYBODY
THOUGH WE DO HAVE DEADLINES
THESE ARE NOT MY DEADLINES
EASIER DEADLINES THAT ARE
CARRYOVERS FROM LAST YEAR. AND
ANYBODY WILL BE NO EXCEPTION SO
I JUST WEEK OR WILL BE ACTUALLY
NO EXCEPTIONS NEXT WEEK YEAH.
WORKSHEET EXCUSE ME GIVE ME
YOUR COMPUTER. YOUR THERE WILL
BE NO EXCEPTIONS NEXT WEEK SO
AUTHORS OF BILLS NEXT WEEK
PEOPLE HAVE POSITIONS ON BILLS
NEXT WEEK IF YOU WISH TO
REGISTER AS A WITNESS YOU HAVE
UNTIL THURSDAY AT THE END OF
THE DAY TO DO THAT SO ALLOW YOU
ONE MINUTE THE THIS PROCESS HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR WELL OVER A
YEAR SO I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU
DIDN'T KNOW BUT- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE- AGAIN WITH A
BEHALF BUT- EFF AND- YOU NEED A
PRINTER FOUNDATION OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE WE ARE
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE
METHOD FOR IDENTITY
VERIFICATION PRESENT TROUBLING
PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THIRD PARTY MANY
INHERENT RISK IN VERIFYING
SOMEONE'S IDENTITY WITH
BIOMETRICS SUCH AS THE
PREVAILING TECHNOLOGY OR WITH
THIRD PARTY DATA BROKERS THESE
METHODS ARE ALSO RIGHT FOR
FURTHER IMAGE USED BY
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES. MOREOVER IT NEITHER
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE ONE OR THE
PILOT PROGRAM THE BILL WOULD
MAKE PERMANENT ARE NECESSARY TO
ENSURE PEOPLE CAN THINK WE GET
CERTIFIED COPY OF THE VITAL
RECORDS DURING THE PUBLIC
NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. BACK TO CALL
IN UP JUST NAME POSITION
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. NEXT TO
NUMBER THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI BECCA KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION OAKLAND PRIVACY AND
MEDIA ALLIANCE COLLEGE STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND AGAIN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN FIVE ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE QUEUING UP TO BE
JUST A MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE LINED THREE FIVE
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
THREE FIVE EIGHT. DANIEL GOOD
CARE OF ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR. C. NINE WOULD THE
MEMBERS OF THE WITH BUT WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW WAS
SECOND BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF BILL ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION TO A
CLOSE MISTER WITH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
STATE AGAIN THAT NEWEST IS THE
NATIONALLY ACCEPTED GOLD
STANDARD COUNTY RECORDER'S HAVE
ALWAYS DONE THEIR UTMOST TO
PROTECT YOUR PRIVATE
INFORMATION AND WHAT AS WE
MOVED TO THE CONVENIENCE OF
BEING ONLINE. WE ASK THAT THEY
FOLLOW THE HIGH STANDARDS OF
MIST- BUT THEY WILL ULTIMATELY
BE ABLE TO DECIDE THEMSELVES
HOW TO APPLY IT AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
THE MOTION BY- MR BIGELOW
SECOND RAMOS AGUIAR-CURRY DO
PASSED TO PROCREATION IS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT HI. WHAT I
MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW. HELLO I
BONTA. BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA MAIN TRYING. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI
SANTIAGO. WALDRON EIGHT WALDRON
AYE MAYES. MAYES I. NINE ZERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN THE BILL IS OUT WITH
THE ROLE OF THE BROTHERS ANNA
YOU CAN GO ON IF YOU'D LIKE TO
NEXT BILL ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR WOULD AND WITH
THE- INCREDIBLE FOCUS THIS YEAR
ON HOMELESSNESS AND THE
PRIORITY THAT CALIFORNIANS
RIPPED UP PLACE ON SOLVING THIS
ISSUE I AM. HAPPY TO PRESENT TO
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WOULD IMPROVE ACCESS TO
CRUCIAL MEDICATIONS FOR MEDICAL
PATIENTS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES BY REMOVING
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US I
ACCEPT YOUR AMENDMENTS BEFORE
TODAY- BEFORE YOU TODAY UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE MEDICAL BENEFIT
REQUIRES THAT THE PHYSICIAN
APPROVED EACH REFILL EVEN WHEN
PATIENTS ARE. ON A LONG TERM
COURSE OF TREATMENT TO REDUCE
OR RELIEVE SYMPTOMS OF
PSYCHOSIS THAT CAN OCCUR WITH
BI POLAR DISORDER DEPRESSION OR
SCHIZOPHRENIA. THESE PATIENTS
OFTEN STRUGGLE TO REFILL THEIR
ANTI PSYCHOTIC PRESCRIPTIONS-
PROVIDE- STUDIES SHOW THAT DRUG
ACCESS PROBLEMS AMONG
PSYCHIATRIC PATIENTS HAVE LED
TO NEGATIVE OUTCOMES INCLUDING
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
HOSPITALIZATIONS- HOMELESSNESS
SUICIDAL IDEATION OR
INCARCERATION. IN CALIFORNIA
STUDY FOUND THAT FIFTY SEVEN
POINT 9% O THE PATIENTS WITH
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSIS
EXPERIENCE AN ACCESS PROBLEM.
LEADING TO A NEGATIVE OUTCOME.
REVISING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS TO MENTAL HEALTH
DRUGS WILL HELP INSURE THAT
THESE PATIENTS CAN FOLLOW THEIR
DRUG REGIMEN. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT PREVENTS PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FROM BEING
REQUIRED FOR ANY DRUGS
PRESCRIBED FOR THE- TREATMENT
OF MENTAL A SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS FOR A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS AFTER THE INITIAL
PRESCRIPTION IS. DISPENSED AND
THE I HAVE- TWO SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. MISSOURINET THIS TO
THIS- THOSE WERE IN SUPPORT.
YES YES A GOOD OUT NUYS SHERMAN
WOODS- IN HEALTHCARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS DR AMOL
BERRA AND I'M A CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHIATRY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IRVINE
WHERE I PRACTICE FOR THE LAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN MY AREA OF
SPECIALTY- IN DIRECT LINE- WITH
THIS BILL- IT'S WORKING WITH
THAT THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL- THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA BIPOLAR DISORDER
REFRACTORY DEPRESSION. YEAH I
SEE- ONE OF THE CHALLENGES.
INCREASE MEANT- THE INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS IF
ACCESS TO MEDICATION OFTEN
BECAUSE OF THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS. NOW
AT THE NATION'S THAT FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE DOING THEIR
BEST TO HELP THEIR LOVED ONES
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE TREATMENT
TEAM. WE HAVE ENOUGH CHALLENGES
IN THIS POPULATION AB ENSURING
MEDICATION ADHERENCE AND REALLY
THE LAST THING WE WANT TO
ESPECIALLY WHEN SOMEONE'S DOING
WELL IF THEY HAVE A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION COME INTO PLAY.
THAT DISTURBS- THIS SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME. THAT WOULD WITHOUT
QUESTION MEDICATIONS ARE MOVING
THE MAINSTAY OF SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME IN THE SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL AND WE REALLY NEED
TO DO EVERYTHING. AND NOT
MISTER. ACT ACCESS TO TREAT S.
TREATMENT THAT'S WORKING THAT
HARD OUR GOAL AT THE TREATMENT
TEAM IS TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
CHALLENGING INDIVIDUALS WERE
WORKING WITH- NOW AS YOU KNOW
IN THE PROVISION IN THIS BILL
YOU KNOW IT'S UP TO THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS- ONE A
MEDICATION HAS BEEN APPROVED
THAT IT WILL YOU REMAIN
APPROVED FOR THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS. WHY THIS IS
CRITICAL YOU KNOW UNLIKE
CONDITIONS LIKE HYPERTENSION
DIABETES WE'LL SEE RESULTS
FAIRLY QUICK. IT MAY TAKE THREE
MONTHS SIX MONTHS TO REALLY GET
A GOOD SENSE OF THE CONTINUED
IMPROVEMENT OF THE MEDICATION
THAT YOU ADMINISTERED SO THAT
CONTINUED PROVISIONS OF
APPROVAL OUT TO WIN YOUR IS SO
CRITICAL. TO REALLY ESTABLISH
THAT THE MEDICINES WORKING WELL
THE LAST THING YOU WANT IS
INTRODUCTION OF MEDICINE AND
THEN A MONTH LATER OR TWO
MONTHS LATER IT'S NO LONGER
COVERED FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION- COULD YOU
STRUGGLED ENOUGH WITH HELPING
THIS PERSON YOU KNOW- I
UNDERSTAND IMPORTANT MEDICINES.
ANY KIND OF BEARING-
DISTURBANCE THAT RESULTS OFTEN
GOING TO LEAD TO SEVEN NINE AND
HEARINGS TO TREATMENT. SO
THAT'S WHY IT'S REALLY
IMPERATIVE TO REMOVE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR PATIENTS
WHO'VE BEEN WHO'VE BEEN
PRESCRIBED THE MEDICINE THAT IS.
PRODUCING POSITIVE RESULTS. NO
I THINK EVERY DAY IN MY- YOU
KNOW I. YEAH OUTPATIENT
PRACTICE HERE- AT THE U. ALSO
IN THE COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
CENTERS. EVERY DAY THREE OR
FOUR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS COME IN YOU. THE
CLINICIANS- THE BURDEN OF
TRYING TO CONVEY. HAWAIIAN
MEDICINE NEEDS TO- CONTINUE
JUST THAT FRUSTRATION AND
DELAYS IN ACCESSING MEDICINES-
IS REALLY A REGULAR OCCURRENCE.
SO YOU KNOW WE BILL I MEAN IF
WE IMAGINE THAT THERE WERE NO
BARRIERS THAT ONCE YOU KNEW
THAT A PRESCRIPTION WITH FILLED
IN APPROVED AND YOU HAVE TO
GUARANTEE THAT IT WOULD
CONTINUE FOR THE NEXT YEAR
WITHOUT QUESTION HE WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS RELIEF STEP PATIENTS
FAMILIES CLINICIANS. ARE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM- SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY YOU KNOW A. B. IN
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS SO
CRITICAL YOU KNOW THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THE LAST. THAT'S A
MOTHER I THINK WE I THINK I
THINK WE UNDERSTAND I THINK
YOU'VE MADE YOUR MESSAGES. BEEN
ALLOWED TO GO OUT LOUD AND
CLEAR. IS THERE A OKAY I CAN'T
CAP SO DO WE YOU KNOW HOW THAT
A I- BY COMMITTEE- WILL TAKE
PLACE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GOING TO THE
SECOND SECOND WITNESS. AND I
PASS A STOPGAP. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK WITH YOU. MY NAME IS
MAY HAYES JACKSON AND I AM A
FAMILY MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATE.
I AM THE CARE GIVER AND PARENT
OF AN ADULT SON. JASON JEPSON
WHO HAS DIAGNOSIS OF
SCHIZOAFFECTIVE DISORDER. I'M
ALSO A VOLUNTEER WITH THE
SHARED NETWORK. WHERE I SHARE
MY PERSPECTIVE ALL MIDDLE HELP.
AS A PARENT WANTING DESPERATELY
TO HELP AN ADULT CHILD THE NEW
FOR THE CHALLENGES. OF
SCHIZOPHRENIA. TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO FOR MY- FOR WOULD BE-
ELEVENTH EIGHT. THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS TO GET
THE MEDICATIONS THAT THEIR
DOCTORS THINKS WILL WORK BEST
FOR THEM. AS A PARENT WHO HAS
BEEN DEALING WITH THESE KINDS
OF ISSUES FOR YEARS I CAN TELL
YOU THIS SEEMS LIKE A SMALL
CHANGE BUT IT REALLY HELPS A
LOT. I WANT TO TELL YOUR STORY.
WHEN I FIRST ALL MY NEWBORN SON
JASON I HAD LOTS OF THOUGHTS
ABOUT WHO HE MIGHT BECOME. BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THE ONE THING
THAT NEVER ENTERED MY MIND.
THAT WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. JASON
HAD A NORMAL CHILDHOOD WE WERE
A VERY NORMAL ORDINARY FAMILY
SOME POP SOME PEOPLE MIGHT EVEN
SAY WE WILL BORING. UNTIL I GOT
THE PHONE CALL THAT WOULD
CHANGE OUR LIVES FOREVER. IT
WOULD GET IN. A FEW MONTHS
EARLIER HE HAD ENLISTED IN THE
ARMY AND HE WAS CALLING ME FROM
FORT IRWIN HE SAID MOM GUESS
WHERE I AM AND I SAID WELL
WHERE ARE YOU. AND HE SAID I'M
IN A PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL.
THAT'S WHERE HE RECEIVED HIS
DIAGNOSIS OF SCHIZOAFFECTIVE
DISORDER MY HUSBAND AND I WERE
SHOCKED TO ARE VERY POOR WE
WERE ALMOST PARALYZED AS TO
WHAT TO DO. WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH SO MUCH TRIAL AND ERROR
SAID THEN BUT WE KNOW- AND
JASON KNOWS THAT HE HAS AN
INCURABLE BRAIN DISEASE. WE
WERE TOLD FROM THE FIRST HELP
GROUPS THAT WE WENT TO. YOU
WERE GOING TO NEED AN ARMY OF
HELPERS ON YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
JOURNEY. AND THAT IS SO TRUE WE
WENT THROUGH YEARS OF TRIAL AND
ERROR AS HE WENT THROUGH
DIFFERENT TREATMENT AND
MEDICATIONS. CHANGING CHANGING
MEDICATION CHANGING THE WAY HE
TOOK THE MEDICATION. SO THAT IS
WHY I SUPPORT THIS BILL THEIR
JOURNEY IS ALREADY HARD ENOUGH
YOU SHOULD ALSO HAVE TO GET
SPECIAL PERMISSION TO GET A
MEDICATION THAT YOUR DOCTOR
SAYS IS NEEDED. I AM OFTEN
ASKED WHAT IT TAKES TO MANAGE
AND MANEUVER THE OBSTACLES OF
MANAGING UMBILICAL. PATIENT
TRUST AND HONESTY ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT TOOL TAKE CARE GIVERS
HAVE IN THEIR TOOL BOX AND THE
BEST ADVICE THAT I CAN GIVE IS
THAT YOU CANNOT DO THIS ALONE
AND MY SIMPLE REQUEST TO YOU IS
TO PASS THIS BILL SO THAT THE
ARMY OF HELPERS LIKE ME. ONE
LEFT BACK TO FIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
WELL PLEASE TAKE A- WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY REGISTERED OFFICE
ASIAN SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW AND WILL ASK FOR-
THOSE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WOULD JUST ASK YOUR NAME.
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTRUST RATED.
AND LADEN GENTLEMEN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION- AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. YEAH IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE-
LOOKS LIKE EIGHT IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY. IT WILL START
WITH THE BLIND THREE FORTY FIVE
ZERO AT. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHEN I GO
TO LINE THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF ALKERMES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
THREE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS I THOUGHT IT OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE OF
THESE GO AT. PICTURE NUMBERS
COUNTY DELGADO IN BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTOR SO PATIENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS IS NUMBER TWO TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CINDY HILLARY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
CONNECTS CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE NUMBER THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL HAGER
REPRESENTING THE PSYCHIATRIC
POSITIONS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
DO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL AND COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
OVER THE LINE THREE OF- TWO OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO OH
FIVE. SURE UNDER SECRETARY FROM
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT TO NUMBER ONE
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINES OPEN. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
SHALL WE DO VERY ON THE
HAPPENED THAT CALIFORNIA ACCESS
COALITION WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORED INFORMED THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NO ONE I UNDERSTAND THERE WAS A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MR BUSH
WAS THE MISTER BIGELOW SECOND
BY. OKAY FIVE BY MISTAKE YEAR
CURRY. OF THE MOTION WOULD BE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- THE CHARITY
THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BY THE CHAIR-
MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO TEST
WITH US JUST AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
THIS BILL ENJOYS A BROAD
SUPPORT AND IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE- REMOVE
BARRIERS TO ACCESS- MEDICATION
FOR PATIENTS WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL. ILLNESS SO. ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS YOU ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS YES YOU DIDOKAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HI WHEN I MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I. BONTA BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. FLORA MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI THIS AREA.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THE BILLS
OUT AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADAM. SENATOR COM
MARKER. YOU HAVE A BILL BEFORE
CB THREE SIXTY NINE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU IN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB THREE SIX
NINE THE STREET MEDICINE ACT.
AS THE ANALYSIS MENTIONS I'M
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE STAFF
EXCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
REGARDING. MANDATORY MANAGED
CARE PLAN AND ROMAN
APPROXIMATELY. FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN L. A. COUNTY
LIVE ON THE STREET L. A. HAS
MORE PEOPLE EXPERIENCING.
HOMELESSNESS THAN ANY OTHER
CITY IN THE NATION. COMPARED TO
THE AVERAGE POPULATION THE
HOMELESS DISPROPORTIONATELY
SUFFER FROM PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
ILLNESS DISABILITY AND
PREMATURE DEATH. DESPITE THEIR
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HAVE
LESS ACCESS TO PREVENT TO
PREVENTIVE PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THAT'S WHY ON AVERAGE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS HAVE
LIFE EXPECTANCIES THIRTY YEARS
OR SHORTER THAN THEIR HOUSED
PEERS. MOST COMMONLY DUE TO
PREVENTABLE AND TREATABLE
CHRONICLE CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. RON I COVER FOR
TWENTY. MANY OF THE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ARE INSURED THROUGH
MEDI CAL HOWEVER EVEN WHEN
SHORT 73% OF THEM HAVE NEVER
SEEN A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
THERE ARE SIMPLY TOO MANY
BARRIERS STARTING WITH THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS. WHEN YOU
ENROLL IN MEDICARE ALL YOUR
INSURANCE CARD WITH THE NAME OF
YOUR ASSIGNED PROVIDERS MAIL TO
YOUR HOME ADDRESS SO FOR THE
HOMELESS THIS MEANS NEVER
FINDING OUT. WHO THEIR ASSIGNED
PROVIDER IS. EVEN IF THEY'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO FIND OUT WHO
THE DOCTOR IS MANY ARE
RELUCTANT TO LEAVE ALL THEIR
BELONGINGS BEHIND UNPROTECTED
AND HAVE NO MEANS OF
TRANSPORTATION. AND FINALLY
WITH THEIR ID CARDS FREQUENTLY
BEING STOLEN MANY LACK OF FORM
OF IDENTIFICATION AND ARE THUS
DENIED ALL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT SHOULD BE COVERED
UNDER MEDI CAL. ALL OF THESE
BARRIERS MAKE IT DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE HOMELESS
TO ACCESS CARE IN THE
TRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE MODEL.
SO CLEARLY ARE MAINSTREAM
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY MODELS ARE
FAILING TO MEET TE COMPLEX
NEEDS OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. SO RATHER THAN
ASKING THE HOMELESS TO OVERCOME
THESE CHALLENGES WE NEED TO GO
TO THE STREETS AND CARE FOR THE
PATIENTS WHERE THEY RESIDE.
THERE ARE SO MANY SUCCESSFUL
DELIVERY MODELS MISTER CHAIR I
BELIEVE YOU MENTIONED SOME THAT
ARE IN YOUR DISTRICT. THESE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE MEDICAL AND
BEHAVIOR CARE TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. IN
ROMAN AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
ASSISTANCE WITH HOUSING
TRANSITIONS. ALL CARE PROVIDED
FREE OF CHARGE AND DELIVERED ON
SITE. THESE PROGRAMS HAVE ALSO
BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE AVOIDABLE
EXPENSIVE HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS
BY TWO THIRDS SO EXPANDING THEM
WILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT COST
SAVINGS FOR THE STATE. DESPITE
THESE BENEFITS MEDICARE DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE THE STREET AS A
LOCATION FOR PROVIDING CARE. SO
AB THREE SIX NINE REMOVES
BARRIERS TO RECEIVING MEDICAL
CARE AND SOCIAL SERVICES BY
EXTENDING THE MEDIC COW
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ALLOWING P. H. TO
RECEIVE MEDICAL SERVICES AND
REFERRALS. REMOVING ID CARD
REQUIREMENT. AND ALLOWING
PERSONS THAT. WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
RECEIVE COMPREHENSIVE MEDICARE
BENEFITS OUTSIDE THE WALLS OF
THE TRADITIONAL MEDICAL SETTING.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS BRETT
FELDMAN WITH THE STREET
MEDICINE INSTITUTE AND DR MAYOR
MARY MARTHA C. RTC WITH THE
UCLA DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY
MEDICINE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES AND ASK THE OPERATOR OPEN
THE LINES FOR OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. FOR
EIGHTY THREE SIX NINE PRESS THE
ONE TEN ZERO AGAIN LONDON. ZERO
WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE
LOCAL TO LINE Q. SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD
MEMBERS TWENTY DOES NOT ONLY
HAVE A COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAD PRIME
WATER WE WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE THEY NOT
ON THE LINE. WE ARE WE ARE ON
THE LINE THIS IS DOCTOR
MARQUEES CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
GOOD I'M GOING TO GET TO MY
STATEMENT RIGHT HERE SO I'D
LIKE TO THINK THAT YOU'RE
WORKING NOW YOUNG MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
ABOUT A TOPIC THAT'S VERY DEAR
TO ME SO MEDICAL CARE OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. MY
NAME IS DR MARY MURPHY FROM A
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY
MEDICINE AT UCLA. FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS MY MEDICAL
PRACTICE HAS BEEN EXCLUSIVELY
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING MEDICAL
CARE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS- I PRACTICE IN THE
STREETS ENCAMPMENTS EMERGENCY
SHELTERS TRANSITIONAL HOMES. AT
THE PROJECT'S ROOM KEY HOTELS
REALLY ANYWHERE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE HOMELESS ONE OF MY TITLE IS
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE STUDENT
RUN HOMELESS CLINIC SIX A
THIRTY TWO YEAR OLD PROGRAM-
THAT. HAVE BROAD HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE ASKED TO GATHER WITH
STUDENTS RESIDENTS PHYSICIANS
WE CREATED OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS- RANGING IN AGE. FROM
NINETY TWO TO A NEW BORN JUST
TWO DAYS OLD. SO EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY NINE IS ALL ABOUT ACCESS
THE OVER ARCHING COMPLAIN AMONG
OUR THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS IS-
THAT WE SEE THEIR COLLECTIVE
STORY OF PERSISTENT BARRIERS TO
CARE ADDRESS SO WELL. IN THE AB
THREE SIXTY NINE BILL ANALYSIS.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT ONE
STORY OF ONE OF OUR PATIENTS IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE BARRIERS TO CARE
AND THE UNFORTUNATE
CONSEQUENCES. THIS IS THE FORTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD STREET DWELLING
MADE. WITH THAT A DENTAL
ABSCESS ON EXAM HE WAS MY LEAST
FAVOURITE ALWAYS TO LIMIT DOWN.
AFTER PROVIDING ANALGESIA AND
BASIC ANTIBIOTICS WE REFERRED
HIM TO AN URGENT CARE COMMUNITY
DENTAL CLINIC. UPON OUR RETURN
ABOUT TWO WEEKS LATER TO THAT
STREET SITE WE LEARNED THAT THE
PATIENT HAD BEEN TURNED AWAY AT
THE DOOR. DUE TO NOT HAVING
MEDIC CAL ORGANIC CAL. AND NO I
NEED TO START THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WE LEARNED FROM HIS ONE
OF THE STREET NEIGHBORS THAT
AFTER SEVERAL DAYS OF UNITED
CARE. THE PATIENT'S CONDITION
WORSENED AND HE WAS FOUND DOWN
NINE ONE ONE WAS CALLED AND HE
WAS ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL
WITH MENINGITIS LIKELY RESULT
OF ITS UNTREATED DENTAL
PROBLEM. AND THAT'S WHERE HE
STAYED FOR A FEW WEEKS AND WAS
NEVER THE SAME AFTER DISCHARGE.
THIS WAS AN INVALUABLE LESSON.
FOR THE STUDENTS AND I AND WE
GO OUT TO BREAK THOSE BARRIERS
AND- LET'S. LIKE HAPPENING. SO
THREE SIX NINE DOES DOESN'T. IN
FACT THE- FOR THIS. WHAT THE
JURY EXPERIENCE OF ONE OF OUR
OWN MEADOW STUDENT. SHE HAD A
PASSION WITH US. AFTER VISION.
AND THEN IN NEED OF COURSE. I
SHE HAD NO. NO MEDICARE NO ID.
NO ACCESS TO THE REQUIRED
DESIGNATED PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS WHO WOULD BE THE ONLY
ONE TO REALLY AUTHORIZED
REFERRAL FOR OPTOMETRY OR
OPHTHALMOLOGY. FRANKLY ENVISION
WHAT'S SO BAD THAT I WAS
WORRIED ABOUT AND STEPPING INTO
THE STREET AND GETTING HIT BY A
CAR. FORTUNATELY THAT STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE STARRY FOUNDER
WAITED DRAFTING PROMOTE AB
THREE SIXTY NINE. BY WORKING AS
A LEGISLATIVE AIDE FOR SENATOR
TOM LOGGER IN HERE WE ARE
TODAY. SO PLEASE DON'T YET FOR-
AB THREE SIXTY NINE WILL WORK
WITH YOU TO ENSURE THAT THE
DELIVERY. THE BILL REACHES ITS
GOAL OF. PROVIDING THE BEST
UNHINDERED. MEDICAL CARE FOR
OUR HOMELESS NEIGHBORS. THANK
YOU AND WE ARE- HAVE. BRETT
FELDMAN ON THE PHONE YOU DID
GREAT THANK YOU YEAH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. AT THE THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN DR WOULD ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND CENTER COME LONGER
MONEY GOING TO PRESS HELP MEANT
FROM A DIRECTOR THREE MEDIC
UNIT U. S. HE AND CHAIR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ST MEDICINE
INSTITUTE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY PROGRAMS AROUND THE WORLD
TWENTY FIVE OF WHICH ARE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
INTERMITTENTLY GO TO THE PEOPLE
ON THE STREET IN THE WORLD
UNDER THE BRIDGES ARE BEHIND
THE DUMPSTERS. WITH THE GOAL OF
FIRST DELIVERING HIGH TENDER
BOX AND THEN THE TEAM QUALITY
HEALTHCARE ON THE STREET YOU
WOULD EXPECT IN A BRICK AND
MORTAR CLINIC AFTER SPENDING
THE PAST FOURTEEN YEARS UNDER
DIFFERENT FREEWAYS AND RIVER
BEDS WITH THE PEOPLE WE SERVE
AND SHARING THEIR REALITY I'VE
LEARNED THAT PART OF THAT
REALITY IS NOTICING THAT BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN BENEFIT
ELIGIBILITY AND BENEFIT ACCESS.
RESEARCH WE CONDUCTED A UFC HAS
SHOWN THAT HE 5% OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
INVOLVED IN THAT ACCOUNT OF
THOSE IN THE WALLS HOWEVER ONLY
25% HAD EVER ACCESSED THERE PP
ONE FOLLOWED BY THREE MINUTE
THAN THAT NUMBER GOES UP TO
SEVENTY PERCENT. WITH THREE
AMERICAN HOW QUOTATIONS WERE
DOWN 60% AND ONE HOSPITALIZED
PATIENTS A DAY AN AVERAGE OF
THREE DAYS LAST INCREDIBLY
THERE WAS ALSO A 42% HOUSING
RICHMOND STREET MEDICINE WITH
ADDED TO EXISTING SERVICES.
CARE PROVIDERS AROUND THE STATE
ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT THIS
WORKED WITH TWENTY FIVE PROGRAM
THINK IN CALIFORNIA BUT MANY
MORE WHO HAVE NEVER STARTED
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BE
REIMBURSED FOR THEIR WORK THE
REASON IS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
CLEAR MECHANISM TO REIMBURSE
FOR STREET MEDICINE NOT BECAUSE
OF THE TYPE OF SERVICE YOU ARE
PROVIDING THE BECAUSE OF THE
LOCATION WHERE TO DELIVER. A
CALL THIRTY DIVERSE SERVICES
AWAY FROM PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FOR DEFINING
GRANTS AND DONATIONS TO SUPPORT
THE WORK FOR PATIENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY IN SHORT AB THREE
SECTOR THAT BY ALLOWING STREET
MATTER CONSIDER YOUR REIMBURSED
FOR SERVICES WHICH ARE ALREADY
REIMBURSABLE BY RECOGNIZING THE
NECESSITY TO PRACTICE OUTSIDE
FOR AWHILE GATHER IMPORTANT
RESULT OF AB THREE SIX NINE
ADELINE PATIENTS DIRECT ACCESS.
TO ST MEDICAID PROVIDERS
MEANING EVEN WHEN THEY CAN'T.
OF FEW KEY. AND THEREFORE THE
MEDICINE MANAGED. PAY WE CAN
STILL PROVIDE THE WITH THE CARE
THEY NEED CAN WITH THEM BUT-
FLAT STRUCTURE FOR ALL. NEEDED
KEEP THEM HEALTHY. DID YOU HAVE.
HIM OF GOING TO THE- AND THINGS
LIKE EXTREMELY TEN ONE IS LIKE
HELPING. HAS THE GOAL TO
IMPROVE COMMUNITY CARE. OF GOAL
WHICH IS NOT NOT. WITHOUT THE-
OF P. THREE NINE. BUT NO SIMPLE
PATIENTS. THE JUST LIKE OTHER
MEDICAL PRACTICE WE WILL ON THE-
AND LYFT WAY TO GET YOU PATIENT
THERE ARE FOR FROM ONE BRIDGE
TO. EIGHTY THREE THIRTY NINE.
THE TIME ISSUES BUT RECOGNIZE
ST MADISON. AS A LEGITIMATE FOR
OF HEALTH TO LIVE. AND INTO SO
ALL BACK IN THE KEY THAT WE
COLLECT SIR. AS HUMAN WHOSE
LIFE IS WHAT THE A LOT. THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY TO.
THANK YOU MUCH. WITH THAT WE
WILL TO THE- WE GO HAVE ANY
REGISTERED SO WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE ASKING FOR SOME OR
OPPOSITION- JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE. SO AS THE
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. FOR THE FOR THAT
TESTIMONY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR A. B. THREE SIX
NINE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN LONDON ZERO. GLOBAL TEL
NINE ONE SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR NUMBER AND YOU ON
BEHALF OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MAXIMAL CAROLINE THIRTY
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALIKE JOHNSON OVER AT
THE STATION OF YANOMAMI SHOWS
SUPPORT THANK YOU THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MAC. SURE MAXIMO
TO LINE Q. THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MAXIMO CAROLINE THREE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY TEAM WITH
HEALTH NET AND CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SERVING
OVER TWO MILLION MEDIC CAL AND
BELIEVE IN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT AT THE EIGHTY THREE SIX
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. SOME OF THE LINE
TWO OH FIVE WE'VE ALL HAD. I'M
VERY GOOD TEARS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NAKAMOTO LINE THREE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ERICA SAID ABOUT THAT
CALLING IN FROM CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE SIX NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ENACT THE MOTEL NINE THREE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE MAY BE NEAR
THAT ON YOUR END. NO RESPONSE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. NO ONE I'M-
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THE MOVE THE BILL WOULD MOTION
BY MISS BURKE. THE SECOND.
SECOND BY THE CHAIR- MOTION IS
TO PASS A FEW PICKS UP AT THE
AMENDMENTS YES SIR THE MOTION
IS- DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- WOULD WOULD YOU
LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WAS COMMON AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
SHOULD THE BILL MOVED OUT OF
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU'D
HAVE ME. I WILL PUT THAT DOWN
RIGHT NOW. I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIRTY ONE SEASONS BURKE. MISS
BURKE WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AS WELL. OKAY SCENE
SEEN KNOW WHAT THE NOTHING ELSE
AT THIS POINT- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE ROLE
OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. WHAT
I WOULD AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NONVOTING
BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY I
MCCARTY I. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I. NAZARIAN. HE
SHOULD BE REVERSED. NUMBER OF
THE MAKES. RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
YES I SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON
HIGH. SEVEN ZERO. YOUR BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTES MUST COME UNDER
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BUT THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE MAYBE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. MR LOW
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
CALLING TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITTEE STOPS WORK. ON THIS
BILL AS WELL THIS IS WITH
RESPECT TO COVERAGE THAT THEY
DON'T WANT TO THANK MY DISTRICT
STAFF IT'S ALSO HELPING TO. A
PROPOSED THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SO WE HAVE A MOTION- BY
MISS BURKE A SECOND BY MISTAKE
HERE TO CURRY- WITNESSES YOU
HAVE SUPPORT. YES IF I MIGHT
MISS AND NANCY MALDONADO CEO OF
THE CHICANO FEDERATION GREAT-
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR A WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
TERRAIN HERE ON THE LINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NANCY MALDONADO AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CHICANO FEDERATION WHICH IS AN
ADVOCACY AND SOCIAL SERVICES
NONPROFIT ANSWER IF YOU GO
COUNTY FOR FIFTY TWO YEARS. I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN
LOW PEOPLE FOR AB ONE THREE
EIGHT EIGHT WHICH IS TO BRING
GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO WHAT
HAS OCCURRED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WHICH HAS ESPECIALLY
HARMED UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
REPORT COULD NINETEEN DEATH
DATA BUT THAT CODE ON THE
STATE'S PUBLIC NINETEEN
DASHBOARD. AND TO CREATE A
UNIFORM DASHBOARD FOR COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF RECORDING HOLDEN
NINETEEN DATA. INCLUDING BACK
BUT THE CODE ON COUNTY WEBSITE.
ALL FIFTY COUNTIES HELLO WHEN
LOVE TO THEIR OWN. IN TRACKING
THE VIRUS AND CREATING THEIR
OWN DASHBOARD. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO HELP COMPANIES
BETTER PREPARE FOR POTENTIAL
FUTURE PANDEMIC. I STUDIES HAVE
FOUND THE UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR PUBLIC
SYSTEMATICALLY HARMED BY THE
PANDEMIC. BUT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO FULLY COMPREHEND THE
DEVASTATING LOSS OF LIFE TO
COVER NINETEEN INFECTION
WITHOUT TRANSPARENT DATA FROM
THE CODE. THE ONSET OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC I HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CO DATA ONTAP. AND HAVE
TAKEN SPECIFIC AIM AT HOW THE
CORONA VIRUS HAS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THE BILL WOULD REPEAL NEW
INFORMATION ON COPING NINETEEN
DEATH. WHICH IS NECESSARY TO
ELEVATE THE CONVERSATION FROM
HELP WITH THIRTY. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
COUNTIES AND HEALTH PROVIDERS
TO GIVE THE DEATH EIGHT AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THIS INFORMATION IS NOT
BEING PUBLISHED. I AM THAT.
TALKING ABOUT DEATH TO BE AN
UNCOMFORTABLE SUBJECT BUT
UNDERSTANDING MORE PRECISELY
WHAT PEOPLE DIED FROM COLD
NINETEEN WILL FURTHER EXPOSE
THE INEQUITIES IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHICH LEAVES
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AT GREATER RISK. THIS ISN'T
ABOUT SHAMING PEOPLE ARE
STIGMATIZED IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. THIS IS ABOUT USING
INFORMATION TO SHOW THAT
CALIFORNIA COULD HAVE DONE MORE
TO HELP THOSE WHO ARE AT HIGH
RISK OF CONTRACTING COMPANY
NINETEEN. CALIFORNIA COULD ALSO
BE AT GREATER RISK OF NOT
PROPERLY RESPONDING IN THE
FUTURE WITHOUT THERAPEUTIC
REPORTING. EQUITY IN RESPONSE
TO THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN A
CONSISTENT CRITICISM. AND THIS
INFORMATION WILL HELP HOLD THE
STATE ACCOUNTABLE AND HEALTH
PROVIDERS MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
HELP TO ENSURE THAT EQUITY
REMAINS AT THE FOREFRONT DURING
OUR RECOVERY. THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN ENSURING THAT
WE LEARNED VALUABLE LESSONS
FROM THE WHAT WILL PANDEMIC AND
THAT WE MAKE NECESSARY CHANGES
TO ENSURE THAT WE NEVER END UP
HERE AGAIN. AND HE'LL- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'LL HAVE
THE OPERATOR OPEN THE LINES FOR
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WILL JUST ASK FOR THEIR NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION IF
THEY REPRESENT ONE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE- NOW. AGAIN THAT ONE
AND THEN. ZERO AND AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU WILL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. C.
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER LOAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE IS A MOTION- BY MISS
BURKE A SECOND BY MISTAKE YOUR
CURRENT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT HI WHEN I AM MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER I THINK A
LOW. BIGELOW I'M BONTA. BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO HI I FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. THIS RIVER.
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO WELL WALDRON HIGH.
EIGHT ZERO ZERO YOUR BILL HAS A
VOTES IT'S OUT- AND BELIEVE THE
ROLE OF THE BROTHERS TO ADD ONS
THANK YOU. I DON'T HAVE A
SENIOR ALSO I'M GONNA MAKE THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT ONE MORE TIME JUST
FOR. ANYBODY WHO'S OUT THERE
LISTENING I HOPE THERE'S PEOPLE
OUT THERE LISTENING TO US TODAY.
SO FOR THOSE WHO ARE ARE- ARE
WITNESSES ON BILLS FOR THE NEXT
HEARING WHICH IS OUR LAST
HEARING WE UNDERSTAND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE. LESS THAN
IDEAL FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY BUT
WE NEED THE NAMES OF WITNESSES
IN ADVANCE. FOR NEXT WEEK'S
HEARING WE NEED TO NAMES FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION BY
THURSDAY AT THE END OF THE DAY.
PLEASE CHECK OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS NO EXCEPTIONS WILL
BE MADE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION WE HOPE AUTHORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS ARE RESPECTFUL OF
THIS PROCESS NEXT WEEK PROMISES
TO BE AN EXTREMELY LONG
HEARING. AND I HOPE THAT-
WITNESSES- WILL- REGISTER IN
ADVANCE SO THAT WE CAN PROCEED
IN AN ORDERLY QUARTERLY BACK
MATTER. AND DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS AS EFFICIENTLY AS
POSSIBLE SO. WITH THAT- THIS
YEAR MISS REAVIS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT. YOU CAN DO FROM
THERE. THREE DIFFERENT THEIR-
BUT YOU DO FROM THERE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THIS
BILL AND BY ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB TWELVE OH SEVEN
WILL ESTABLISH THE PATHWAYS
THROUGH PANDEMICS TASK FORCE
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE TASKED
WITH ANALYSING LESSONS WE ARE
LEARNING FROM THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND DEVELOP STRATEGIES
TO NAVIGATE FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
ALL OF US UNFORTUNATELY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ARE
BEARING A DISPROPORTIONATE
BRUNT OF THE HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. IN THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS OF THE PANDEMIC- AND AN
EQUITABLE AVAILABILITY OF
COVERT NINETEEN TESTING HAD
DEADLY CONSEQUENCES FOR
CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY LATINOS. FOR
EXAMPLE A STUDY IN THE BAY AREA
FOUND THAT WHITE RESIDENTS WERE
TWICE AS LIKELY TO BE TESTED
FOR COVERT NINETEEN COMPARED TO
LATINO RESIDENTS OF THAT SAME
COUNTY. HOWEVER LATINO
RESIDENTS WERE SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO CONTRACT THE VIRUS. A
RECENT CDC REPORT ALSO FOUND
THE CALIFORNIA'S AMONG THE FIVE
WORST STATES FOR EQUITABLE
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. THE
REPORT SHOWED THE CALIFORNIA
HAS ALLOCATED A SMALLER
PROPORTION OF VACCINES TO
COUNTIES WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS DESPITE
THESE COUNTIES BEING AMONG THE
HARDEST HIT BY THE PANDEMIC.
RECENT RESEARCH BY UC BERKELEY
FOUND THAT IN CALIFORNIA 65% OF
LATINOS AND 56% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS REPORTED INCOME LOST
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC. IN
COMPARISON LESS THAN HALF OF
WHITE HOUSEHOLDS REPORTED A
LOSS OF INCOME DURING THIS TIME.
THE NEXT. IS NOT A MATTER OF IF
BUT OF WHEN. AB TWELVE OH SEVEN
WILL GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A ROAD MAP
FOR FUTURE PANDEMICS SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE DEFICIENCIES IN
OUR CURRENT RESPONSE. TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY I'M EXCITED
TO BE JOINED BY DOCTOR JEFFREY
REYNOSO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LATINO COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR OUR WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. THANK I DO NOT SHOW DR
JEFFREY ON THE FALL MINE FOR
LIFE YOU'RE ON THE LINE WITH
SOMEONE ELSE THEN YOU CAN JUST
EAT. HE SAYS WE WERE A LITTLE
EARLY HE MAY. THAT'S TRUE I
MEAN I DON'T. YOU KNOW I CAN WE
CAN LET HIM KNOW I MEAN WE
THANK HIM FOR BEING AVAILABLE
ON TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY BUT-
IF. I YEAH I WAS ABLE TO CHECK
IN BETTER STATES FOR SORRY I
DIDN'T THINK OF THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION- IN A SECOND-
MEMECREATOR WE CAN OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SHARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB TWELVE
ALL SEVEN PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN ONE BEEN FERAL.
AND AT THAT TIME THERE IS NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT SURPRISING
CONSIDERING THE ORDER BUT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE NEW
HEAR SOMEBODY. MAYBE THAT WAS
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THIS RIVAS SURE THANK YOU
MEMBERS- FOR THE DISCUSSION ON
THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO LET TIME PASS
AND ALLOW THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE
SYSTEM WAS ESTABLISHED FOR
COVERT NINETEEN TO DISBAND
WITHOUT FIRST REVIEWING WHAT
INEQUITIES WE MUST ACCOUNT FOR
IN OU RESPONSE TO A FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES CRISIS
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WAS RIVAS A BILL DOES
ENJOYED DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
AND MISS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ LAST
MADAM SECRETARY TO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE MEMBERS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD HI WHAT I
AM MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY BAKER
CURRY I BIGELOW. BIGELOW II
BONTA BURKE BURKE I CARILLO.
FOR MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON ALL THANK YOU AND I.
WALDRON NOT VOTING. SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU AND ARE YOU
READY MISTER RODRIGUEZ. JUST
READ JUST FOR THE RECORD YOU
CAN BE HERE IN AB SIX SIXTY
TWO. BY MR RODRIGUEZ SO. I
BELIEVE HE HAS A WITNESS OUT
THERE. AND ALSO THOSE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
BEGIN QUEUING UP SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISS RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS LET ME
BEGIN BY SAYING EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
BE ADOPTED IN G. JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPTION FOR THAT SB SIX SIX TO
THE MEASURE THAT AIMS TO
ADDRESS CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH TRANSPORTING MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS AN EXISTING LAW
THERE'S NO MENTION OF AN EMT OR
PARAMEDIC UNDER THE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY COLD AS RELATES TO MENTAL
HEALTH. HOLDS AND TRANSPORTS
HOWEVER PRACTICE MOST
TRANSPORTS OF MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS ARE DONE THROUGH
AMBLIN SERVICE. THIS PROBLEM
COME ITSELF WHEN I'M WITH A-
MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS TO EIGHT
DOES. FACILITY THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHICH UPPER SIX PRINCE
WHEN PATIENTS WILL SLOWLY
BECOME AGGRESSIVE. AND DECIDE
TO LEAVE THEM WITH BY FORCE.
AND THESE SCENARIOS THERE'S NOT
MUCH AND STUFF CAN DO. AS THEY
DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO DETAIN
A PERSON UNDER FIFTY ONE FIFTY
OLD. ONLY OFFICERS AND COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
CAN DO THAT. THIS IS ONE OF THE
SEVERAL CHALLENGES RELATED TO
FIFTY ONE FIFTY TRANSPORT WHICH
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS BY
STOP MOTION IT WORKING GROUP.
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO. EVALUATE
DESTRUCTION AND RESPONSE
PROTOCOLS MEANT PROVIDING EMS
TO MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS.
COOPER CUSTOMER IS AMY BROWN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA. WHO I
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE. YES I AM THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- ANY
BROWN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR- FOR-
DURING THIS BILL WE ARE THE
SPONSORS- YOU KNOW WE SUPPORT
OF MULTI DISCIPLINARY GROUP TO
EVALUATE THE CARE. OF MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENT AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
ADOPTION OF BEST PRACTICES LOVE
TO BE A PART OF THAT DISCUSSION
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD
APPRECIATE THE IBM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION PLEASE AN ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. FOR
EIGHTEEN SIX SIX TO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN LONDON ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE LOCAL TO LINE TO SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON RESEARCHER MEMBERS
TWENTY DELGADO WILL BE HAPPY TO
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER IF THERE IS. ONE
AND THAT TIME NO ONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NONE THE BILL DOESN'T DO IT
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
BOOK THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. WE HAVE A SECOND.
CHAIR SECONDS THE CHECK IS THE
BILL- MADAM SECRETARY. WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A- ACCEPTED THE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE
ASKING FOR IT DO PASSED TO IT.
ACTUALLY YOU'LL BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN JUDICIARY SO THIS
IS A PROMOTION IS A DO PASS TO
JUDICIARY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT HI
WHEN I MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE. CARILLO CARILLO HI FLORA.
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON. SIX ZERO LIDA BILONG
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
RODRIGUEZ. AND WE ARE WE ARE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS SO. OTHERS
WITH BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE COME TO THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS.
HAVE AN AUTHOR. THE
RECORD BUT THE RECORD NOTE THAT
THE AUTHOR WRITES TO A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. RIGHT MISTER
VIEWPOINT WHILE YOU HAVE A BILL
BEFORE US EIGHTY ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
WOULD REQUIRE HEALTH CARE
CLAIMS BE PAID BY SERVICE PLANS
OR INSURERS WITH TWENTY WORKING
DAYS DOWN FROM THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENT OF. THIRTY OR FORTY
FIVE WORKING DAYS THE COPA
NINETY PUT THEM IT BROUGHT TO
LIGHT THE NECESSARY. NECESSITY
I'M SORRY OF THE HEALTH
PROVIDERS HAVING THE NEED THE
NEEDED TOOLS AND EQUIPMENT AT
THEIR DISPOSAL TO BEST SERVE
THEIR PATIENTS UNFORTUNATELY
RIGHT NOW. MANY PROVIDERS ARE
FORCED TO TAKE ON DEBIT AS THEY
WAIT FOR CLAIMS TO BE RESOLVED
SO THEY HAVE TO THE THEY HAVE
THE FUNDS TO CONTINUE TO CARE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS THAT THEY
NEED. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF THE BILL IS ALEX
HAWTHORNE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL HAVE OUR
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
THEIR NUMBERS OUT ACCORDING TO
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WITH A PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. DRUG THE PANDEMIC
HOSPITALS AND EXPERIENCE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOSSES
IN PART BECAUSE OF INCREASED
EXPENSES AND REDUCED REVENUE
DURING THE CRISIS. OUR MEMBERS
ALSO REPORT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. RELATED.
WE DO WE LOSE OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LINE HERE.
WE ARE STILL HERE ALEX THREE
YOU FINISH. I'M NOT SURE IF THE
LINE IS STILL THERE BUT I'M NOT
SURE TO BE MUTED IN YOUR END.
ALEX. RIGHT EXACTLY OKAY. OKAY
WE WILL- WHAT WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL- ALLOW OTHER WITNESSES TO
SUPPORT IN A TWO TEST BAN
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IF MR
HAWTHORNE COMES ON WE'LL LET
HIM BUY NO THERE IS OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL SO- WE WILL ALLOW
IF THE OPPOSITION IS ON THE
LINE WILL ALLOW THE OPPOSITION
TO TESTIFY AND THEY WILL GIVE
MISTER HOPPER CHANCE TO FINISH
HIS TESTIMONY. IF HE CAN FIND
HIS WAY BACK THROUGH. THE PHONE
LINE. MISTER MISTER CHAIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. APOLOGIZE I
WAS ON THE CALL FROM THE
BEGINNING AND I GOT KICKED AT
THE EXACT MOMENT CERTAIN
SPEAKING- THE CALCUTTA.
PROPITIATION WITH THE SPONSOR
I'M NOT SURE WHERE IT LEFT OFF
BUT I WILL SAY RECENTLY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- OUR MEMBERS ARE
OWED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LATE CLAIMS- THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
ONGOING FOR YARS WE HAVE A
VERY OUTDATED LAWS ON THE BOOKS
THAT NEED TO BE UPDATED- WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS NOT RADICAL
OR NOT. THAT PREVENTING PLANES
FROM DISPUTING CLAIMS ANYTHING
OF THAT NATURE WE'RE NOT DOING
ANYTHING MAJOR. WE SIMPLY WOULD
LIKE PLAN THEY'RE BUILT ON A
MORE EXPEDITIOUS MANNER AND
RESOLVE DISPUTES FASTER I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT THE
LAW TO ALLOW REGULATORS TO
REQUIRE. CERTAIN CONSUMER
HEALTH CARE PROTECTION DURING A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY
JERRY THANKFUL TO BE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
ME- I THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I JUST CAN'T. THEM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLAN
RADICALLY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN FIFTY
TWO AM AT THAT MEN THAT. I
PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR
ENGAGING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
HOWEVER IS DRAFTED WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT A DELAY FIFTY
TWO WOULD UNDERMINE THE HEALTH
PLAN TO BILITY TO PROPERLY AND
THOROUGHLY REVIEW CLAIMS. A
CURRENTLY HELPING HOOSIERS AT
THIRTY TO FORTY FIVE DAYS TO
ANALYZE REVIEW. AND PROBABLY
GET A CLAIM. THIS BILL WOULD
CUT BACK TIME IN HALF. BY
REQUIRING A PLAINTIFFS WE IN
THIS PRICE THAT INTO TWENTY DAY.
WITH THAT ARBITRARILY. THE TIME
FRAME HEALTH PLAN A CLEAN
WITHIN TWENTY DAYS ONE.
HAMSTRING HELP AND THE BILL. TO
RIGOROUSLY REVIEWED THE SUBMIT
A CLAIM. IN COULD
UNINTENTIONALLY LEAD TO RUN ITS
CLAIMS BEING PAID WHEN NOT
WARRANTED. A ALMOST WE TO AND I.
AND THEN COSTS FOR PLAN
INSURERS. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IT IS IMPORTANT NOTE THAT AT
LEAST THIRTY SIX STATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
CURRENTLY ALLOWED PER THIRTY
DAY DEADLINE FOR PROFITING IN
PAYING CLAIMS. ANY FURTHER NOTE
THAT THE NEW AND NUMEROUS
ADDITIONAL STATE ALLOW BROUGHT
TO FORTY FIVE DAYS A CLIENT.
WE'RE ALL CONCERNED A DEAL ON
TWO. OCT UPDATED THAT
SHORTENING AMOUNT OF TIME FOR
HELPING INSURANCE PROP WITH THE
CLAIM. WILL CREATE OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES FAR CONTRACTED
DELEGATED ENTITIES. ARE CONTACT
DELEGATE IT MAY NOT HAVE THE
OPERATIONAL FAMILY PROFIT
DECLINE UNDER THE PROPOSED
UNDER PROPOSED- SHORTEN TIME
FRAME OUTLINED IN THE BILL. THE
COULD FORTY HELPING THE MEASURE
TO BRING ON THE STAFF TO HELP
THE CONTRA DELEGATED ENTITIES
PROPERTIES KIND WHICH WILL
LIKELY SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE-
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR HEALTH
PLAN. ADDITIONALLY ONE FIFTY
TWO SOUTH OF KNOWLEDGE THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH INSURERS PAID
THE HIGHEST INTEREST HEALTHY
THE LATE PROPERTY IN PAYMENT
PLANS IN THE COUNTRY. AND BE
THE FIRST HAND GOAL ONLY
INCREASE THAT THE THAT THE
CLAIMS PROCESSING TIME FRAMES.
ARE SHORTENED LEAD TO EVEN MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WITH THE
PLAN. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB ELEVEN
FIFTY TWO UNLESS IT IS AMENDED.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE DOCTORS OFTEN SPONSORS.
RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ZERO
SECOND WITNESS IS. I REMEMBER
WATCHING IT ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANY.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF OUR THOUGHTS AND
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT AB ELEVEN
SIX EQ. WE DID HAVE BEEN
TOPPLED CONVERSATION BUT THE
AUTHOR AND STAFFING NEEDS
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THOSE
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE HERE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION. TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE SOME INITIAL
CHALLENGES AT THE ON GOING TO
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURANCE COULD MAKE
A CONCERTED EFFORT TO CREATE AN
OPEN DIALOGUE WITH OUR PROVIDER
PARTNERS. TO ADDRESS ANY ISSUES.
ALBUM BETTER ROUTE. THE
ULTIMATE OF THE JOB IN MANY
PRESS. TO ENSURE A SMOOTH
SEAMLESS. BUT THAT BEING SAID
WE THINK SOME CONCERNS THAT
THIS BILL AND REQUIREMENTS
INSURANCE IMPLEMENTED SEPARATE
PAYMENT PROCESS FOR ANY CLAIM
THAT IT'S PREVIOUSLY BEEN
APPROVED OR CONTRACTED CURRENT
REVIEW PROCESS. IT'S AN
AFTERTHOUGHT OBLIGATED PLANNERS
OR TO PAY ANY CLEAN EVEN IF
THEY'RE EVEN IF IT INCOMPLETE I
WOULD OTHERWISE BE CONTESTED OR
DENIED. THE PROVISION
COMPLETELY IGNORE THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE MANY LEGITIMATE
REASONS LIKELY MIGHT BE COULD
HAPPEN AND IT OR DENYING. THAT
GO WELL BEYOND HAVING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION OR CONCURRENT
REVIEW PROCESS IN PLACE. FOR
EXAMPLE A CLEAN MIGHT BE
IMPROPERLY COLLUDED OR MISSING
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION.
ACCURATELY PROCESS AT. AB
ELEVEN SIX GETS THE FACTORED
REQUIRED MAINTENANCE. PAID THE
CLAIM ON THE FRONT IN. THE
CHURCH BUT THEN HOW TO REACH
ANY UNNECESSARY CLAIM PAYMENT
AFTER THE FACT THIS WOULD
CREATE A VERY. AND MINISTRY TO
BELIEVE COME PROCESS. THAT
WOULD ONLY INCREASE THE WITH
THE- AND- THE BILL. LAST WEEK
YOU HAVE TO THIRDS OF PROVISION
OF THE BILL THAT GRANT TO
DEPART OF MANAGED. AND THE
COMPANY DEPARTMENT INSURANCE.
IN FLORIDA TO REQUIRE HELP
PLANS IN THE- IT'S BEEN PRIOR I
THINK FOR ANY SERVICE UNDER. OF
EMERGENCY. RESHAPE THE PROPOSED.
THEREALLY TO THIS WE HAVE TO.
THAT THE LINK DOES NOT BELIEVE.
THE FACT EACH DECLARATION OF
MEMORY. IF YOU DEATH. JUMPING
NUMBER TWENTY THREE INDICATION.
HEALTH PLANS ARE HOW ON. OTHERS
NOT HELP INSURANCE CORRECT GO
TO GREAT LENGTHS TO TURN RELIEF
AND PROVIDE. AND THEIR WHEN
THEY ARE. BY THE DIVERGENCES.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT GIVING
THE DEPARTMENT. AND CD I AM
READY TO ISSUE A BLANKET
PENSION A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
ITSELF CAN BE. THAT COULD ALLOW
HER BACK. AFTER SIX POINT THAT
CHANGED ISSUE AT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH BOTH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS DISABILITY
ADJUSTED FORWARD TODAY- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR A
SINCE. OR UP. JUST YOUR NAME.
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU RESENT
WRITTEN REPRESENT ONE SO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY- OPERATOR.
YEAH LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. FOR
EIGHTY ELEVEN SIX EQ PRESS THE
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PRESS THE ONE
BEEN ZERO. WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
AND MAKE YOU A BOTTOM LINE TWO
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
TO MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN THE
CALVARY SOCIETY OF PLASTIC
SURGEONS ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. METSOVO TWO
ONE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THIS IS FRED NOWHERE
REPRESENTING STANFORD HEALTH
CARE IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NOW BEAT A
MOMENT PLEASE. THAT TIME NOT
ENOUGH TO MAKE YOU VERY WELL
THANK YOU GREENBACK COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NOW DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION BY MOTION BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ- THE YOUR ACCEPTING
THE- AMENDMENTS CORRECT. OKAY-
I WILL EXPECT SEVEN MINUTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF
GREAT THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR VEHICLES ARE- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
WHICH YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
WHAT I WHAT I AM MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BONTA BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO HI FLORA LARA
AYE MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO.
WALDRON. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THINKING INITIATED. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS IS HERE FOR ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY-
THE GOAL AND THIS BILL IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO PACE THE
PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY I PACE IS A%
WELL RESPECTED AND EFFICIENT
PROGRAM THAT AIMS TO KEEP
SENIORS IN THEIR HOMES IN
COMMUNITIES THAT NOT IN
INSTITUTIONS PACERS ELIGIBLE
PARTICIPANTS BY PROVIDING ALL
INCLUSIVE MEDICARE AND- MEDI
CAL COVERED BENEFITS THROUGH
ONE STOP SHOP HE CENTERS. WHILE
STILL ALLOWING THEM TO RESIDE
IN THEIR HOME OUR PACE IS AN
INTEGRATED IN CONCERT
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION WHICH
INCLUDES PREVENTIVE PRIMARY
ACUTE AND LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES. THE PROGRAM IS A
PROVEN SUCCESS HE'S ACHIEVED
HIGH LEVELS OF OUTCOMES FOR THE
BENEFICIARIES THAT IT SERVES
INCLUDING FEWER
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND NURSING
HOME ADMISSIONS BETTER HEALTH
AND QUALITY OF LIFE AND HIGH
RATES OF PARTICIPANT
SATISFACTION WITH OVERALL CARE
PIECES ALSO EIGHT MONEY SAVER
AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT PAYSAFE
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. A MODEL FOR
SENIOR CARE FOR FRAIL SENIORS
MANY BENEFICIARIES ARE UNAWARE
AT THE PACE AND HOW IT MIGHT
BENEFIT THEM AND AS A RESULT
ONLY 12% OF PEACE ELIGIBLE
SENIORS ARE ACTUALLY ENROLLED
IN THE PROGRAM I THINK THE
CURRENT ENROLLMENT PROCESS IS
FRAGMENTED AND HAS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE LOWER RATES AND ROMAN SO
AB FIVE FORTY IS TAKING SOME
STEPS TO IMPROVE THE
BENEFICIARY AWARENESS AND
ACCESS TO PACE. ARE THE
MEASURES IN THE BILL INCLUDE
REQUIRING PACE TO BE OFFERED AS
A MEDIC CAL PLAN CHOICE AND TO
BE IDENTIFIED AS A MEDICARE
PLAN CHOICE AND ALSO REQUIRING
DH CS TO ESTABLISH AN AUTO
REFERRAL PROCESS TO PACE- AND
BEFORE I WHICH I INTRODUCED OUR
WITNESSES TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL OUT WE'LL
JUST NOTE THAT I'M ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS AS I DETAILED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND REALLY WHEN I
THINK COMMITTEE STAFFER ON ALL
THEIR WORK ON NOT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WELL THANK. BUT THAT
GOT AT TO WHAT ON THE I COULD.
AND MELISSA WHO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO
THE WITNESSES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANALYSTS WHO
THEN FIFTY- HUMBLE IN YOUR
RESOURCES AND REDWOOD COAST
PACE. WE'RE LOCATED IN RURAL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CITY OF EUREKA AND HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. EIGHT FOR THE PROVEN
AND COST EFFECTIVE MODEL OF
INTEGRATED CARE THAT ENABLES
FRAIL ELDERLY BENEFICIARIES
WITH CHRONIC HEALTH CARE NEEDS
TO REMAIN SAFELY IN THE
THE SERVICES NEEDED BY FRAIL
SENIORS TO ENABLE THEM TO LIVE
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING ACUTE CARE LONG TERM
SUPPORT AND SERVICES. AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. HE HAS RISEN
TO THE CHALLENGE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS A TRUSTED COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO NURSING
HOMES FOR OLDER ADULTS WITH
SIGNIFICANT MEANS. WELL PATRON
OPTION FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES ONLY 10215% OF
MEDICARE. BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR IT AND HAVE ACCESS
TO IT ARE ENROLLED IN PACING
CALIFORNIA MANY MENTAL HEALTH
BENEFITS. ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT
AWARE OF IT AND ARE NOT
INFORMED OF THEIR OPTIONS WOULD
BE IF THAT'S THE CASE
ELIGIBILITY. EIGHTEEN FIVE FOUR
ZERO WOULD IMPROVE AWARENESS OF
AND ACCESS TO PAY INCLUDING AND
BY REQUIRING THAT CASES
CONSISTENTLY AND ACCURATELY
PRESENTED TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. AT THE MANAGED
CARE ENROLLMENT CHOI IN THE
SAME MANNER AS OTHER MANAGED
CARE PLAN OPTIONS. AND THAT
CASE IS INCLUDED IN ALL AND
ROMANTIC AND OUTREACH MATERIALS
WERE ALL DUAL ELIGIBLE TEN
YEARS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. AND ARE COUNTY OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND RESIDENTS
THE PAPER MODEL HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING
ACCESS TO CARE WHICH IS
CRITICAL IN A RURAL AREA. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO REACH
MORE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
ULTIMATELY PROVIDING MORE CARE
TO A PORTION OF OUR COMMUNITY
MOST NEED. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE FOUR ZERO AND WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR INTRODUCING
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EILEEN CAMPBELL I'M
THE CHAIR OF THE CAMPAIGN
REPORTED DIRECTORS AND I'M ALSO
THE CHIEF OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND COMPLIANCE FIRSTHAND FOR
UNLOCKING THE PAYMENT THE CUP
CARE ACT. I'M NOT CONFOUNDED
FIFTY YEARS AGO TO SERVE
UNDERSERVED VULNERABLE SENIORS
LIVING IN THE CHINATOWN NORTH
BEACH NEIGHBORHOOD SAN
FRANCISCO AND CREATED THE PAID
MODEL TO ENABLE NURSING HOME
ELIGIBLE SENIORS JERMAINE IN
THEIR HOME COMMUNITY. TODAY ON
SERVER THAT SIXTY HUNDRED FELT
OLDER ADULTS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WHERE CROWN
THE PACE IS NOW A NATIONAL
MODEL AVAILABLE IN THIRTY ONE
STATES. THANKS TO THE GROWING
UP AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO NURSING
HOMES IN FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
HELPING YOUR POPULATION PAPER
GOING TO STATION NOW THIRD OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS
THROUGH SIXTY FOUR PAINT
CENTERS AND ALTERNATIVE CARE
SETTINGS IN TWENTY TWO COUNTY.
ALMOST ALL PROTECT THE PENDER
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES WITH THE
VAST MAJORITY BEING ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDICARE AND MEDICAID AL.
DESPITE THIS THE NUMBER OF
BARRIERS MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
BENEFICIARIES SHOULD CONSIDER
ENROLLING IN. MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE FOR PAY-
AND IMAGINE ROLLING MANAGED
CARE PLANS ARE NOT CONSISTENTLY
INFORMED THAT THEY- MAY BE
ACCESS FOR TASTE ALLEGE
ABILITY. INFORMATION ABOUT PAYS
CONTAIN THEM FROM MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE MOMENT. IS. OUT OF
DATE AND ACCURATE. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CARE IS HEALTH
CARE OPTIONS WHEN CONTAINS
LIMITED FOR ABOUT PAY. AB FORTY
WOULD INCREASE AWARENESS ABOUT
PAY ISN'T THE SOLE ATTAIN
ACCESS TO PAY ENDEAVOR WAYS
INCLUDING BY REQUIRING VIA
SHOES GREEN BENEFICIARIES FOR
POTENTIAL PAINS ELIGIBILITY AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH OUTREACH
MATERIAL THAT THEY WISH TO BE-
AND TRANSPORTATION ELIGIBILITY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ALREADY STATED BY- CALPAIN
ESTIMATES THEY SAVE MONEY FOR
CALIFORNIANS COMPARED TO THOSE
THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF HEY THAT'S
IN ADDITION TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES THAT FAILED THING YOU'RE-
THINKING HANDS SAYING ACCESS TO
PAIN- THROUGH THE CHANGES IN
THIS BILL WILL ALSO RESULT IN
COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE. FOR
THESE REASONS CAPITA TAPI TO
SPONSOR AB FIVE FORTY AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT WE ALSO
WISH TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR INTRODUCING
IT I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THERE IS NO RICHEST
OFFICE TO THE SO WE'LL MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES S. C. OPERATOR
TO HAVE PEOPLE COME- THE
TESTIMONY WILL JUST BE ASKING
FOR YOUR NAME. YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL AND ANY ORGANIZATION
YOU MIGHT REPRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MADAM OPERATOR.
AND LATE GERMAN- IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND AT THE
MOMENT WE HAVE ABOUT THREE IN
THE QUEUE OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. ABSOLUTELY
JUST A MOMENT. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LUCAS EVAN
TEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE DH
CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO FORTY NINE- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
GENRE CRENNEL COMBI HALF OF THE
INNOVATIVE INTEGRATED HEALTH
FRESNO PAY BAKERSFIELD PAYS AN
ORANGE COUNTY PACE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WILL
BE GOING TO LINE THREE SIXTY
EIGHT THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS MANY MCCARTY VOCAL
REPRESENTING WILL BE HEALTH AND
ARE FOR PEACE PROGRAM CAN
CALIFORNIA CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OKAY GOOD LUCK
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE FORTY
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND WE
DO HAVE ABOUT TWO IN THE QUEUE
OKAY. WILL FIRST GO TO LINE UP
THREE EIGHTY TWO THREE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
THRILLED TO HEAR LINES OPEN.
HOW DO I LOOK AT THIS TIME-
THEY DID DROP OUT OF THE QUEU-
THEY ARE AT THIS POINT NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
WHICH WILL IN MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. WE DID I THOUGHT IT IS
GOOD TO HEAR I'M SORRY THANKS
MISS KOREA SO WE'LL MOTION BY-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. I THINK IT IS TERRORIST
ACT LAST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
TO PASS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD ALL RIGHT
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BONTA BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO CARILLO III FLORA FLORA
I MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO WALDRON.
EIGHT ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE A
BILL ON WILL BE THE ROLE OF THE
BROTHERS TO ADD ON. SO WE ARE
LOOKING FOR SOME AUTHORS- THREE
OF THEM ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE. SO AND THEN ALSO-
MISTER TEAM SO. MR CHANG MR
MCCARTY MISTER HIS AREA MR
SANTIAGO. READERS.
ONE
REPRESENTS SOMEBODY ELSE'S BILL.
WHO VOLUNTEERS. RIGHT THEY HAVE
GOOD. GO AHEAD SO MISTER MISTER
RODRIGUEZ'S PRESENTING MR
TING'S BILL AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN THE BILL DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. SECOND OF
A MOTION BY MISTER FOR A SECOND
BY MR MAYES. A MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR GIVING OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. ARE
CRISP. FOR THREE HOURS WHEN I
VOTE. WELL DONE MR RODRIGUEZ
WELL DONE. WE WILL SEE I'M IF
THERE IS A SUPPORT TESTIMONY
FOR AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN WE
DO HAVE TWO SUPPORTS REGISTERED
SO- MISTER- OPERATOR IF WE CAN.
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN SUPPORT FOR
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN BY MR
TANG. I DO SHOW THE WITNESSES
ARE ON THE LINE OTHER LINES ARE
OPEN OKAY GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI
THIS IS A ED MERON HO- I WANT
TO THANK EVERYOE OF YOU. FOR
HAPPY THAT THIS- ADULT
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT I'M A COMMUNITY
MEMBER OF THE BOARD AND VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD. THE
FUNNY AND NOT. AS A LITTLE
IMMIGRANTS THANK YOU JUDGE YOU
THE WEATHER THE HOSPITAL AND I
ALSO USED TO GET FREE MEDICAL
CARE THERE. AND YOU KNOW IT TO
THE HOSPITAL AND H. M. C. IS
TOTALLY COMMITTED. AND MAKING
SURE THAT HOSPITAL VIABLE.
SPECIALLY TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
IT SERVES. IN SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO. SOUTHERN OF SANTA
DALY SAN BRUNO. THERE ARE TWO.
THAT WE SERVE HEAVENLY WITH
PERCENT MEDICAL OUT. IN
IMMIGRANT SPECIALLY FOR BLACK
NEEDED THE LATINO COMMUNITY
CHINESE COMMUNITY THE
ISLANDERS. MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
SERVES EVERYONE IN THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY. IN THIS
HOSPITAL HMC NEWTON WHAT THE
OWNERS. ARE REALLY WORKING HARD
TO MAKE THIS HOSPITAL CRIED AND
THEY'VE ALREADY PUT INTO IT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEY'RE GONNA PUT
ANOTHER EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE RECORD OPEN AND TO
MODERNIZE. SO WE SO THE PEOPLE
THAT I CONSIDERED LIKE MIGHT
NOT LIKE MYSELF BUT PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY WITH ASSISTANCE
WITH A SEVERITY. IN EQUITY IN
HEALTH CARE CONTINUE TO GO TO
THAT HOSPITAL. AND GET. THEIR
CARE THEY- WHEN I TAKE IT
YOU'VE GOT. ARE JUST ONE OF YOU
KNOW THANK YOU FOR GREAT THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE DONE TO GET THIS
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
HOPE WE WILL GET THE SUPPORT.
SO I TO COMPLIMENT YOU AND- ONE
THING I WANT TO SAY ABOUT
AGENCY I'VE TOURED THE
HOSPITAL. ALL THE HOSPITALS
THAT THEY HAVE WITH US IN EAST%
LA. OR CENTRAL. THE ECONOMIC SO
POPULAR- SAYING THINGS-
CULTURALLY DIVERSE POPULATION.
THEY KNOW HOW TO TURN AROUND IN
THE- THE THOSE TYPE OF PRODUCTS
WITHIN DENTIST WELL SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW THEY'RE
COMMITTED TO IT SO AGAIN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH A BILL PAYING COURT
FOR YOUR STAFF IN YOUR SYSTEM.
AGAIN TO ALL OF THE MEMBERS
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS CHARLES PHONE I'M A
LICENSED ENGINEER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND SERVING AS
THE PRINCIPAL REPRESENTATIVE OF
AGENCY. IN MY CAPACITY AS A
VICE PRESIDENT AND CHIEF
ENGINEER TO EXPRESS MY
UNWAVERING AND STEADFAST
SUPPORT FOR A BI. FIFTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
ALL AGENCY PERSONNEL I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO REVIEW AND ULTIMATELY PASSED
THIS CRITICAL BILL IN ORDER TO
ALLOW SETON HOSPITAL.
SUFFICIENT TIME TO COMPLETE THE
STATE MANDATE. THANK MAKE
RETROFIT PROGRAM THE AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN ALL RIGHT
THERE ARE SPOTS THE OFFICE OF
THE STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT. TO GRANT THREE
TO MEDICAL CENTER IN DALY CITY
A WAIVER OF UP TO ONE YEAR TO
BECOME COMPLIANT WITH THE FACT
THE REST OF IT REQUIREMENTS AT
THE CALIFORNIANS MY FELLOW
RESIDENTS AND CITIZENS HAVE
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO THE
BEAUTIFUL COASTAL ENVIRONMENTS.
AND AMAZING CLIMATE HOWEVER WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL OF
A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE THAT WORKER
AND CALLED THE WIDESPREAD
DAMAGE WITH MAJOR LOSS OF LIFE
IN THAT THING ANDREWS PAUL
RUPTURES IF THE DEFENDERS FAULT
RESTAURATEUR ONE OF AGENCIES
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE FACT
THAT THE SEASON HOSPITAL IT
MERELY. THREE POINT THREE MILES
EAST OF THIS MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
FAULT. THE POWER IN THE PODIUM
FEUDING AT THE SEASONS ARE
CONSIDERED TO HELP THE HIGH
POTENTIAL COLLAPSE IN THE EVENT
OF THE MAJOR SEISMIC ACTIVITY
BUT THEY ALSO. HELP HOLD THE
CRITICAL CARE SERVICES FOR THIS
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN BETH
HOSPITAL WHICH PROVIDES A FULL
RANGE OF INPATIENT AND
EMERGENCY CARE SERVICES TO A
LARGE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN THE BAY AREA
SEE THE MEDICAL CENTER AFTER
NUMEROUS YEARS OF FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY AND THE BANKRUPTCY
WHAT ULTIMATELY ACQUIRED BY
AGENCY IN OFFICE TWENTY TWENTY
FOLLOWING APPROVAL FROM THE
STATE. THE FINANCIAL CERTAINTY
UNDER SEASON- OUR OWNER AS WELL
AS THE THREAT OF THE POTENTIAL
CLOSURE MADE MEETING THIS IS A-
TECHNICAL REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSSIBLE ORGANIZATION EMILY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO COMPLY
WITH THIS TACTIC OF REGULATIONS
WHY MAINTAINING THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CONVENIENCE PATIENT
CARE IN THIS AREA. DUE TO OUR
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE OPERATING
HOSPITAL IN CALIFORNIA AGENCY
AFFECTED BOTH. THE COMMITMENT
AND THE REQUISITE EXPERIENCE TO
BRING THE TWO FEUDING AT THE-
SETON HOSPITAL IN TO START THE
COMPLIANCE. IN THE PAST TEN
YEARS AGENCY THE HEALTHCARE SO
AT THE FIFTH BROUGHT ALL EIGHT
OF OUR HOSPITAL. IN TO COMPLY.
WITH TECHNIQUES SANDERS AND IN.
SHE THAT C. A MEDICAL IN ALSO
GONE UP THE WITNESS. ALL WE
HAVE BEEN INUNDATED WITH
CHALLENGES THAT TAKING OVER.
SUCH A FINANCIAL FINANCIAL
STATUS POP WHAT THAT MEANS
TENANTS LEASE DEAL WITH LINK
COLD AT ENDEMIC BY PER QUICK
LIFE. CARE TO COPE PATIENT AND
THE TESTING WITH THE
RESIGNATION. WE HAVE STRUGGLES
BALANCING THE VERY DYNAMIC
FORCES OF PATIENT CARE WHICH
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC.
CONSTRUCTION EFFORTS AT THE
HOSPITAL INCLUDING WORK ON THE
FACT MAKE PROJECT HAS BEEN VERY
LIMITED DUE TO THE REQUIREMENTS
INVOLVED QUARANTINE ISOLATION
IN INFECTION CONTROL MEASURES
TAKEN. TO PROTECT OURSELVES
STEP CONTRACTORS AS WELL
ESPECIALLY PATIENT AT OUR
FACILITY WHY WE HAVE CONTINUED
TO MAKE STRIDES AT THE
COMPLETING ALL THE NECESSARY
PATH. IT HAS BECOME CLEAR THAT
WE REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
EFFECTIVELY WEATHERED THE STORM
WARSOM BY THE COVE IN NINETEEN
AGENCIES. HEREBY WE REQUEST
THAT BE THE POINT SEVEN HE IN
ORDER TO ALLOW EATEN TO OBTAIN
THAT RECORD THE- TO COME THIS
PROJECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR TIME I'M ALL HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
IN REGARDS TO THIS MATTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'LL LASSIE OPERATOR
TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OTHER WITNESSES IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WAS
BASKING FOR NAME- POSITION ON
THE BILL IN OREGON IS AN
ORGANIZATION AT THE REPRESENT
ONE SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTRUST WRITER. AND LATER
GERMAN FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THE M. FOR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE ONLY HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE OKAY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER CALLERS. ONE THREE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. THE TIMER NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM MR FOR A SECOND
BY MR MAYES MISTREATING WHICH
YOU LIKE CLOTHES JUST A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AT ON
THIS- CRITICAL DISTRICT BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES ANGER.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BONTA
BURKE. CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA. LAURA HI MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY. THIS
AREA NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU WHICH IS
YOUR YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
MISTER KING LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHER STAT ON. MR THIS AREA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES- CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
EVERY SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
OR STEPS TO EMPLOY A MEDICAL
DIRECTOR WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF RESIDENT CARE
POLICIES AND COORDINATION OF
MEDICARE MEDICAL CARE IN THIS
THAT. THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY FROM
CONTRACTING WITH A PERSON AS A
MEDICAL DIRECTOR IF THE PERSON
IS NOT OR WILL NOT BE WITHIN
FIVE YEARS CERTIFIED THROUGH
THE AMERICAN POST ACUTE AND
LONG TERM CARE MEDICINE AS A
CERTIFIED MEDICAL DIRECTOR-
AGING GUY CALIFORNIANS. AND OUR
MOST FRAIL LIVING IN SNIFFS
HAVE BEEN A TRAGIC HIGHLIGHT.
OF COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SNIFFS HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR A
MINOR PERCENTAGE OF.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT AFFAIRS
CASES BUT A FAR GREATER
PERCENTAGE OF ITS DEATHS WHILE
KERN OF VIRUSES RESPONSIBLE FOR
THESETHAT'S THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES THAT ALLOW FOR THE
INORDINATE NUMBER OF DEATHS
AMONGST RESIDENTS AND STAFF
HAVE BEEN EVIDENT AND
DOCUMENTED FOR DECADES RESEARCH
IN THE AREAS OF STAFFING
PROTOCOLS INFECTION PREVENTION
AND OUT OF DATE FUNDING
MECHANISMS. HAVE LED TO AN
INDUSTRY THAT NEEDS GREATER
STRUCTURES IN PLACE TO DELIVER
A CARE MODEL THAT IS
SUSTAINABLE SAFE AND ABLE TO
MEET DEMAND AS NEEDED MEDICAL
DIRECTORS IN SNAPS CAN BETTER
SERVE AGING CALIFORNIANS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES LIVING
IN CONGREGATE CARE SETTINGS. BY
HAVING THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
THAT COMES WITH CERTIFICATION.
WITH ME ON THE PHONE LINES
TODAY SUPPORTING AB SEVEN FOUR
NINE R. DR MICHAEL WASSERMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LONG TERM CARE MEDICINE AND
BHAJAN PARO CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER WITH NEW CHEN HEALTH.
OKAY STRUTTER PLEASE WHENEVER
THE WITNESSES ARE READY THEY
CAN GO AHEAD AND PROCEED. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY MY
NAME IS BILLION BARREL AND I'M
CURRENTLY SERVING AT THE CHIEF
CLINICAL OFFICER FOR NEW CHEN
HELP WHICH IS BASED OUT OF LOS
ANGELES. I HAVE BEEN IN THE
LONG TERM CARE INDUSTRY FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS. I
STARTED AT THAT THIRTY FIVE
NURSING ASSISTANT. LATER BECAME
A REGISTERED NURSE AND-
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN
BEACON OVER THE YEARS. I
EVENTUALLY BECAME A DIRECTOR OF
NURSING IN THE LATTER PART OF
MIND OR PROFESSION AND
CURRENTLY IN THE ROLE OF THE
CLINICAL OVER OFF THEIR-
OVERSEEING THIRTY FIVE FIELD
NURSING FACILITY. IN CALIFORNIA
WASHINGTON AND NEVADA COMBINE.
BEING IN A VARIETY OF NURSING
ROLE YOU KNOW KILL NURSING
FACILITY PROVIDING IT ALLOWED
ME TO WITNESS THE BIRTH HAND
HOW THE ROLE OF THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR EVOLVED OVER THE
YEARS. BUT DEMAND FOR THEIR
INTENDED IMPEACHMENT INDICATE
BEING. NURSING FACILITY
OPERATIONS BECAME VERY APPARENT
AND CHALLENGING AT THE. TIME IN
MY OPINION. WELL THE MEDIC
DIRECT IS CONSIDERED A CAPTAIN
OF THE SHIP IN TERMS OF.
MEANINGFUL GUYTON DIRECTION
AND- ALL RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
DELIVERY OF CARE IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE FISCAL
LEADERSHIP. HAVING HAS ON
TRAINING AS A MEDICAL DIRECTOR
IN A FIELD NURSING FACILITY
SETTING AND OR REQUIRING
CERTIFICATION AS MEDICAL
DIRECTOR TO WONDER ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM OFFERED BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. AND LONG TERM CARE
MEDICINE. WILL BE OUR LAND.
YOU'LL GET ALL THE IN. THE MUCH
NEEDED- IN DRIVING BETTER
PATIENT AND OR RESIDENT
CLINICAL OUTCOMES. THE LACK OF
BASIC KNOWLEDGE OF INVOLVING
FIELD. OPERATIONS THE TECHNICAL
GROUP BECAUSE- FOR THE LACK OF
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR INVOLVED THE
COMPLEXITY OF PEER REGULATORY.
COMPLIANCE AND CLINICAL OUTCOME.
HILL NORTH ABILITY TWENTY FIVE
YEAR OLD DARK HI. BECAUSE MY-
THE RESIDENTS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES ARE VERY MUCH ENGAGED IN
THEIR PLAN OF CARE. AND IN
RETROSPECT THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY HAS BEEN A ROOTLESS HERE
FOR THIS FIELD NURSING FACILITY
INDUSTRY. DUE TO THE COLD AT
NINETEEN AND THEN TICK AND THE
NUMBER OF FATALITIES INVOLVING
RAPID. AND FRONTLINE STAFF. ALL
OUR ALL. REFER AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE FIELD NORTH BUILDING
INDUSTRY TO REDEFINE WILL BE
FORWARD. I DON'T KNOW IT WILL
BE THE SB POTENTIAL OF THE-
LITTLE WILL CONTINUE PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND NEED FOR A WEALTH
BURKE FIELDS AVAILABILITY
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY GOING TO BE A VITAL
COMPONENT TO MEET THE DEMAND
FOR SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
BAD. TO EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIANS
AND OPPRESSOR TO ACCOMMODATE
OUR PATIENTS AND BALANCE. ALL
ORDERS WITH GOOD RECKLESS
POLITICAL. OUTCOME WE CAN NO
LONGER THE WAY IN THAT NIGHT
THE NEED FOR COMBAT AND HOW
ENGAGED MEDICAL CARE. I GREW UP
IN NURSING. AND PROBABLY WHERE
I WILL. MY PASSION- BEING THAT
GERIATRIC POPULATION I HOPE BY
TENURE AND MIGHT NEED TO HELP
YOUR INDUSTRY. COULD PAVE THE
WAY- AND TRIGGER AN INDELIBLE
CHANGING FOR THE NURSING
INDUSTRY AND THAT IS PERHAPS
ENGAGED AND WELL TRAINED
MEDICAL DIRECTOR. ABOUT THE
BILL. EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY NINE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE HAVE WITNESS I BELIEVE.
ABOUT YES. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DR MICHAEL WASHER MEANT
AND I CHAIRED PUBLIC POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WHAT TRUMPCARE
PATTERSON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TO THE
COURT OF EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE. CALLING MINE IS A
CERTIFIED MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR
NURSING HOME. IN THE EARLY DAYS
OF THE PANDEMIC SHE LIKE MOST
OTHER MEDICAL DIRECTORS WAS
FACED WITH PRESSURE TO ADMIT
KOBLET PATIENTS TO HIS HIS
DISABILITY. BUT MY COLLEAGUES
THAT IF YOU SATISFIED WILL SET
YOU BACK TWENTY WITHIN A WEEK.
SADLY MY COLLEAGUE WAS
PROPHETICALLY RIGHT BECAUSE OF
HIS TRAINING HE KNEW WHAT TO DO
WHAT HE WAS ABLE TO LIMIT
OUTBREAKS HIS DISABILITY. HIS
ACTIONS SAVED LIVES. MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE THE NECESSARY
SKILLS IN LARGE PART BECAUSE HE
IS A CERTIFIED MEDICAL DIRECTOR.
L. BEFORE YOU TODAY WOULD HELP
INSURE THAT EVERY MEDICAL
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA. IS AS
PREPARED AS MY COLLEAGUE WAS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT OF QUALITY AND SAFETY
IN THEIR NURSING HOMES. AS AN
EXPERT IN GERIATRIC MEDICINE
NURSING HOME QUALITY BECAUSE
FORMER NATIONAL INDUSTRY
EXECUTIVES I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT LIVE YOUR CHEESECAKE FOR
DECADES SENATE COMMITTEES-
AGING REPORTS PEER REVIEW
PAPERS AND INDUSTRY EXPERTS
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THE VALUE OF
COMPETENT AND ENGAGED MEDICAL
DIRECTORS. WE CAN NO LONGER
HOLD THE DIRECTING HAPPENED ITS
OWN ACCORD IT'S TIME ACQUIRE IT
ALL NURSING MEDICAL DIRECTORS
BE CERTIFIED. NURSING HOMES FOR
THE COMPLEX AND VULNERABLE. TO
PANDEMIC IS REMINDED US JUST
HOW VULNERABLE WITH NEARLY TEN
THOUSAND DEATHS. IN HOMES ON
THE HOSPITAL'S DEMANDING
ACTIVITY GAUGE MINT OF MEDICAL
DIRECTORS OF CLINICAL
REGULATORY BIOETHICS IN
MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS WHOLE BECOME
PROJECT. AND BY FEDERAL
REGULATION THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR
IS EXCLUSIVELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
COORDINATING MEDICAL CARE IN
THE NURSING HOME. YET MANY
NURSING HOME MEDICAL DIRECTORS
ARE WOEFULLY UNPREPARED TO DO
THIS REQUIRING MEDICAL DIRECTOR
SHOULD CATION PROVIDE CLEAR
RECOGNITION. OF THEIR VALUE AND
IMPORTANCE FINALLY
CERTIFICATION IS SELF PACED WEB
BASED AND DOESN'T REQUIRE AN
EXAMINATION. YOUR RESPECT THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THE POSITION
WHILE RECOGNIZING THAT MOST
RESIDENCIA FELLOWSHIP TRAINING
PROGRAMS DO NOT PROVIDE THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS NECESSARY
FOR A DOCTOR TO BE PREPARED FOR
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COORDINATING MEDICAL CARE IN A
FACILITY. ALLOWING THE STATUS
QUO TO CONTINUE SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT WE CANNOT TELL YOU
ARE BOTH LOCAL NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS OR THE QUALITY OF
CARE THEY RECEIVED. IN THE WAKE
OF THE TRAGIC OUTCOME TO THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT'S
TIME TO TAKE THE SIMPLE STEP OF
ACQUIRING CERTIFICATIONS. WHICH
IS WHY I SUPPORT AB. SEVEN
FORTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY REGISTER OFF. SO WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION SO JUST ASK YOUR
NAME. YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND IN ORDER ANY ORGANIZATION
THAT YOU REPRESENT SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER OPERATOR.
UNLEASH YOUR MIND WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB SEVEN FORTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE
OKAY PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SIR. WE WILL START WITH
NUMBER THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M GOING
TO ACT ON BEHALF OF ASKING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARBARA PLAYED
HERE WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- MISTER MASON. AT THE
US CHAIR- I'D TO THE AUTHOR
THERE WAS SOME SUGGESTED
LANGUAGE- THAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE ANALYSIS- BY A CH A- IS
THAT- IS THIS DO YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU. I WAS JUST
WANTING WHAT YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT AND IF THAT WOULD BE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER- AMENDING THAT IN MANY
ABILITY. I DON'T WANT TO PUT
YOU ON THE SPOT NO NOT AT ALL
NOT AT ALL. I JUST WANNA I'M
SORRY I CAN'T REMEMBER.
SPECIFICS OF THIS THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED TO. GIVE YOU THE
APPROPRIATE ANSWER. IT'S SAFE
TO SAY THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THEM BUT
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A MORE
SPECIFIC ALWAYS ON STAGE ON
PAGE THREE OF THE NLCS. I SEE
IT.
I THINK THE ISSUE IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN. WAS THE ABILITY
WE WANTED TO ASCERTAIN THAT
WHOEVER IS GETTING THIS.
WHOEVER BECOMES THE DIRECTOR.
IS CERTIFIED OR IS GOING TO BE
CERTIFIED WITHIN A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. AND THERE IS NO WAY OF
WE WANTED PERMANENCY PART OF
PART OF THE CHALLENGE PART OF
THE CHALLENGE WITH THIS ISSUE
WITH SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AND A LOT OF LONG TERM
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES. IT'S
BEEN THAT. THERE IS A LACK OF
COMMITMENT OF DELIVERY OF
SERVICE NOT SAYING THIS IS
INDUSTRY WIDE. THERE ARE SOME
PLAYERS THAT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT'S WHY
WE'VE HAD SUCH VULNERABILITY.
AND THIS PANDEMIC JUST ALLOWED
FOR THAT LONG ABILITY TO BE
AMPLIFIED IN TO BE SEEN. AND TO
BE UNVEILED YEAH. ONE OF AND
THIS BILL IS JUST ONE OF. MAYBE
ABOUT A DOZEN DIFFERENT
SUGGESTIONS. OF HOW WE CAN.
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
CARE OF THE AGING POPULATION IN
THESE FACILITIES IS AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF. WHAT WHAT
THEY'RE DESIGNED TO DO AND THAT
THE DELIVER THE BEST SERVICE
POSSIBLE. UNFORTUNATELY WHAT'S
HAPPENED COLLEAGUES IS THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A LOT OF THESE
CENTERS. MOST OF THEM ARE MONEY
MAKERS BECAUSE THEY GET A
CERTAIN SET SET AMOUNT FROM THE
STATE. AND IT BECOMES A REAL
ESTATE VENTURE AT SOME POINT.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD RATHER MAKE
THE INVESTMENT INTO THE REAL
ESTATE PORTION OF THE BUSINESS.
AND AT SOME POINT WHEN. THEY'VE
MADE THE PURCHASED OR ACQUIRED
THE LAND THEY CAN EASILY
MANEUVER OUT AND DO SOMETHING
ELSE YEAH SO THIS WAS YET ONE
MORE STEP IN MAKING SURE THAT
THERE WAS A FIRM COMMITMENT
FROM THE BUSINESS. THAT IT'S
NOT CONTRACTING OUT THAT IT IS
HIRING SOMEONE. THAT IS
QUALIFIED AND IS CERTIFIED AND
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE AND I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE.
PROVIDED DIDN'T GIVE COMPLETE
ASSURANCE THAT THAT WAS GOING
TO BE THE CASE IF I'M RECALLING
CORRECTLY I THINK THAT'S WHERE
IT WAS LEFT. SO I HOPE I
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION SURE I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL- TODAY-
I JUST THOUGHT WHEN I SAW THIS
LANGUAGE SUGGESTIVE LANGUAGE-
THAT. I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THE
STILL HAD QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS
AND THEY COULD DO THAT THAT
TYPE OF WORK- UNDERSTANDING-
YOUR EFFECTIVENESS AS A AS A
LEGISLATOR- AND YOU ARE. NOT
SINCERE DESIRE TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS- IS I
SEE NO NO NO ISSUE AND
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE. I HAVE
A CAR I JUST HAVE A I DO WANT
TO GO BACK TO SOMETHING- MISTER
NAZARIAN BECAUSE I THERE WAS
THERE WAS A CONCERN- BYE C. H.
A. THAT THERE ARE SOME SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THAT ARE
SPECIALIZED MORE IN REHAB
REHABILITATION AND THEY'RE VERY
SHORT TERM AND SO THEY WERE
ASKING I BELIEVE- FOR SOME
CONSIDERATION AROUND THAT
RECOGNIZING THAT. THAT THEY ARE
A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY BUT
THEY'RE NOT NOT A LONG TERM
FACILITY SO THEY'RE GOING TO
SEE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT- PATIENTS THEIR YOU
KNOW SOMEONE WHO MIGHT HAVE
BEEN IN AN AUTOMOBILE ACCIDENT
OR OR SHORT TERM FROM A STROKE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND SO
SUB MY I JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
FULLY SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE IN THIS BILL- AND- AND IN
THIS BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
WE- THEN THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
THE BEST QUALITY CARE FOR
SENIOR CENTER SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. I AND I AND THE AND
THE IDEA OF MEDICAL DIRECTORS
THAT ARE CERTIFIED I SAID I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THAT I WOULD
JUST ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH C. H. A. ON THIS
LITTLE PIECE OF IT- THERE MAY
NOT BE A HUGE THERE'S PROBABLY
NOT A HUGE NUMBER OF THESE AND-
THAT'S SO THAT'S THAT'S WE HAVE
CREATED THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND I
APPRECIATE. WHAT EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO DO BUT THERE IS THAT
LITTLE PIECE THERE THAT MIGHT
YOU KNOW MIGHT MIGHT BEAR
LOOKING A LITTLE BIT CLOSER OR
CLOSEST HAPPY. TO DO SO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SO WE DO. HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAIENSCHEIN A
SECOND BY MISTER RIVAS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
NAZARIAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST MEDICAL
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW HI BONTA. BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. HI FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
AYE NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON HI. TWELVE ZERO CLOSER
YOUR BILLS THAT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER STAT ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN MR SANTIAGO. THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A PERSON
LIKE THIS EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AND YOUR-
STAFF FOR HELPING US TO MAKE IT
A BETTER BUILDING AS AMENDED.
EIGHTY FIVE AND SEVEN WOULD
CREATE THE PROTECTION OF
PATIENT CHOICE IN TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER ACT WHICH WOULD ENSURE
PATIENTS RECEIVE ADEQUATE AND
EFFICIENT. TELEHEALTH SERVICES.
TELEHEALTH SERVICE PROVIDERS
LIKE THIRD PARTY CORPORATE
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS WOULD BE
EXPANDED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
ESPECIALLY IN RESPONSE TO GO
THE NINETEEN. WHILE THESE
PROVIDERS CREATE MORE ACCESS TO
TELEHEALTH SERVICES IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARD FOR
PATIENTS ARE PUT IN PLACE. AT I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT MY MASK
INSPECTOR FOR PATIENTS THAT ARE
PUT IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY GET THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
THAT THEY NEED- THIS BILL GET
PATIENTS THE OPTION. HOW TO USE
PROVIDERS OF THEIR CHOICE IN
PERSON OR VIA TELEHEALTH OF THE
PROVIDER CHOOSES TO USE IT. A
THIRD PARTY CORPORATE
TELEHEALTH COOPER PROVIDER THE
RECALL THE RECORDS FROM THEIR
VISIT WOULD BE FOR INTO PRIMARY
CARE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES-
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR- LET'S
HOMES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE FOR. COLLISION AND
SEE THE HEALER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
MISTER SHOW ALSO BE BRIEF AND
TAKE YOUR MATCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL- THE STRUCKER PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND TWENTY IF YOU'RE ON THEIR
GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY.
EARLY EIGHTEEN CHAIRMAN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CAROL AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COLLECTION. THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT YOUR CODE SHOULD BE
UNIQUE ALLIANCE LEADING
NONPROFIT VOLUNTARY HEALTH
ASSOCIATION CONSUMER HEALTH
ORGANIZATION PROVIDER GROUPS
THAT YOU NINETY TWO APPROVED TO
HELP THE CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK
IT'S JUST OR CAN YOU USE IT.
OUR MISSION IS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN GAIN ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLINIC YOUR
COLLISION I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR POINT SEVEN. THE
CALL YOU HAVE A CHANCE
CERTAINLY CHANGED THE WAY
PATIENTS RECEIVE HEALTH CARE
AND TELEHEALTH IS PROVING TO BE
IN THE SPECIALLY IMPORTANT PART.
ABOUT THE G. CARE. QUALITY ARE
TO BE IN THE ARE HAVE TO CALL
BETWEEN MULTIPLE PROVIDE.
PRIMARY CARE SPECIALIST AND
FIVE CARE. YEAH NOT. SIX OF
TELL IT FEELS LESS. PAGE. IT
ALSO MEANS HOWEVER CHRONIC
DISEASE PATIENTS ARE THE MOST
AT RISK CAN'T BE FRAGMENTED. IF
THE PATIENT WE REPRESENT
PARKING THIRD PROVIDERS RECORD
THE BOTH IRAQ INTERACTIONS ARE
NOT WE LAKE THE CASE CARE. IT
CAN'T JUST RUN SOMETHING
DISEASE LABELS ARE YOU IN THE
MAKING. YEAH I'M UNACCEPTABLE
RAN. AB FOUR FIVE SEVEN ONE
THAT THE BURKE ENERGY A PLEA
RECORD THE SHARE A LOT IN LOWER.
FINER PARK OTHER WHITE LEVINE
THE ENROLLEES CARE. EIGHTY FOUR
FIVE SEVEN FIVE THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN ALLOW THE THIRD
PARTY. TO CONTINUE TO OP WELL
PLAYED A AREN'T REALLY THERE
YOU READY FOR WE FINALLY URGE
OF PAPER THE PLEDGE PLACE THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND DOES ARE NOW WITNESS- AND
SO. YES HI. HI I'M HILLARY
RECORDS THE FIFTH THOUSAND
DOCTORS AND MEDICAL STUDENTS
THAT MAKE UP THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE FOKKER
AT EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SEVEN. I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY REALLY
EXPRESSING MY GRATITUDE THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WHO WORK DILIGENTLY WITH
STAKE HOLDERS AND THE HOPPER
PROFIT CLARIFYING. AND
STRENGTHENING THE MASSES THAT
MEASURE. IN OUR AT THE TWO MODE.
IS TO ALLOW PATIENT INTERACT
WITH THEIR CHILDREN PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN OR OTHER
PROVIDER WHEN IN PERSON BUT
THAT WOULD BE CHALLENGING.
CAMPAIGN STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF TELEHEALTH
UTILIZATION IN THE SWEAT AND
THE MEASURE IS NOT AN ATTEMPT
TO STIFLE INNOVATION OR LIMIT
THE EXPANSION OF OUR HOUSE.
WHAT EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
DOES IS TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH
PLAN YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE THERE HE
SENT A THIRD PARTY CORPORATE
TELEHEALTH COMPANY. MOREOVER
THE BILL FOR FRAMEWORK BY. THE
REMARK FOR WHICH PATIENTS ARE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES. RECEIVE
HIGH QUALITY INTEGRATED CARE
INCLUDING MAINTENANCE OTHER
PATIENT RECORD. IT DOES THIS BY
REQUIRING PLANS WHEN FOR
PATIENTS OF ALL OF THEIR
OPTIONS WHEN MAKING AN
APPOINTMENT YES THIS AND YET
POWERHOUSE. SEEING THEIR USUAL
POSITION MAKING AN APPOINTMENT
WITH ANOTHER NETWORK WITH THEIR
SON SO WHEN APPLICABLE USING
THEIR OUT OF NETWORK BENEFITS.
A NON CONTRACTED SUFFICIENT IN
THEIR AREA. IF THE PATIENTS
YOUR THIRD OPTIONS AND SELECT
THE THIRD PARTY CORPORATION
BACK THERE CHOI. WHEN THEY DO
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN FURTHER
GUARANTEES THAT THE RECORD OF
THAT INTERACTION RELATE BACK TO
THEIR USUAL SOURCE OF CARE.
TELEHEALTH MUST BE CONSIDERED
ANOTHER TOOL A DIFFERENT
MODALITY ACROSS WHICH FEATURE
AND THE XIN NEED. NOT A
DIFFERENT KIND. OF CARE. BY
THROUGH TELEHEALTH BE CARRIED
CHRYSLER. PAPAHEALTH OUTCOMES
IN MANNER. EIGHTY FIFTY SIX
IMPORT THAT TO ENSURE FOR
QUALITY CARE NO MY THE LOWER
FOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I BELIEVE WE HAVE-
WITNESSES ENOUGH. SO THEY ARE
ON THE LINE PLEASE- GO AHEAD
AND- BEGIN. GERMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY IS QUALITY OF
PARK AND SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
AFFAIRS AND PUBLIC POLICY UNTIL
THAT I CAN HELP I DON'T SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED HELLO I
CALPERS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
TELEHEALTH COMPANY IN ALL FIFTY
STATES AND ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE COUNTRIES I
CALIFORNIA CLIENTS INCLUDE
LARGE AND SMALL EMPLOYERS LABOR
UNION HOSPITAL HEALTH SYSTEMS
AND HEALTH PLANS INTEGRATED
SERVICES UNTIL THAT I KILLED
INCLUDE TELEHEALTH EXPERT
MEDICAL SERVICES MY PATIENT
MONITORING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND LICENSABLE
PLATFORM SERVICES FOR HOSPITALS
AND PHYSICIAN PRACTICES. WE ARE
OPEN THREE OF SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
YEAR SEVEN DAYS A WEEK TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY HOLIDAYS ALL
THE TIME WE WERE ACCEPTABLE TO
OUR PATIENTS HELLO I CALPERS
VERY PROUD OF THE CONTINUED
CONTRIBUTION BECAUSE BANNING
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYERS OFFER
TELADOC CAL TO THEIR EMPLOYES
ONLY COVER FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION LAST IN THE STATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE TELADOC
CALCULATIONS PERFORMED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE CONSOLE
WERE USUALLY FOR FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND CONSOLE AND SAY THE
STATE'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
THE PATIENTS OVER TO HER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. I HAVE
PERSONALLY SPOKEN END UP WITH
PROPONENTS OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN ABOUT CONCERNS
TOLD I KILLED HAS WITH THE
LEGISLATION FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IT APPEARS THAT THE
PROPONENTS LACK A FUNDAMENTAL
pUNDERSTANDING OF HEALTH
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS LIKE HELLO
HELLO TELADOC HILLS
PERFECTIBILITY INTEGRATED INTO
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THROUGH
INSURANCE PLANS AND SERVE AS A
SIGNIFICANT PARTNER OF THE
PLANS AND EMPLOYERS TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE A LOT OF OPPOSITION
WHO COMMITTEE SHARES WITH
DETAIL THOSE CONCERNS. FIRST
ALLIED HEALTH NO TELL HIM TO GO
FOR FIFTY SEVEN LACKS A CLEAR
DEFINITION OF THIRD PARTY
CORPORATE HELP TELEHEALTH
PROVIDER WELL THIS TERM WAS
INCLUDED LAST YEAR TO PROVE
THAT PROVISIONS OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. SEVEN FORTY FOUR IT WAS
AND THE FACT WE HAVE WITH CAN
STAFF. THE MANY ISSUES THE OF.
BUT THE TERM. SECOND ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FIFTY SO. OF THEM
HELPING PLAN A RAIN. CARE FOR
ROWLEY'S THIS IS JUST NOT TRUE.
HEALTH AND PLAN ENROLLEES. CARE
THEM SO. RECALL LIGHT PROVIDERS
YOU'VE BEEN BILL HELP AND PLAN.
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE SERVICE
BEFORE. PLACING A THREE OF OUR
REQUIRE OF HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS TO PLAY THE CONSUMER AND
ALL WITH. OF HAVING TO
DETERMINE OR NOT IT EXCEPT. TO
ACTIVE REMOTE CARE FROM A
CERTAIN PRODUCT AND DIDN'T
WHETHER OR NOT THE SERVICE
CONNECTED CONDITIONS SET OUT IN
THE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN WILL BE REVIEWED FOR
REIMBURSABLE THROUGH THE HEALTH
INSURANCE PLAN WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO PUT THE BURDEN ON THE
PATIENT. I HAVE READ THE STAFF
ANALYSIS ON THIS BILL AND AGREE
WITH THE DEFECT THE STAFF AT
THE DON'T THAT THOSE DEFECTS
WOULD NEED TO BE ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSED THE MAKERS
LEGISLATION TRULY PATIENT
CENTERED AND CONSUMER FRIENDLY.
TELADOC HELP REDUCE IF
COMMITMENT TO THIS COMMITTEE TO
BE A READY RESOURCE AS A
DELIBERATE ON THIS IMPORTANT
TELEHEALTH PUBLIC POLICY THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. BECAUSE
THAT ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
ANOTHER. WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE. YES THEY CANNOT
THIRTY WHAT CAN ON BEHALF OF
THE S. OF CALIFORNIA LICENSE
AND COMPANY. AND I THINK.
FRANKLY OF THE AUTHOR BONSER
COMMITTEE AFTER THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUR
CONCERNS. AS WELL FOR THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
BE TAKEN TODAY. THAT BEING SAID
WE STILL HAVE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. HI
MERRILY WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS ALWAYS INSURANCE CAN
ACCESS THE CARE THEY NEED WHEN
THEY NEED IT. I PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED THE BILL REQUIRED
PLANTING A CHURCH COMBINED WITH
THE THINK INFORMATION TO AN AND
GROWING YOUR INSURANCE WHEN
THEY SEEK ASSISTANCE FROM THE
PLANT. CARE RANGE TELL
HEALTHCARE IT. REMOTE CONCERN A
LACK OF SPECIFICITY HAS TO WHAT
THE FORM FOREMAN. THE NOTICE
WOULD BE. FOR TO SOME THAT CAN
INCLUDE IN OUR- BE. EXPECTING
THAT THE TO THE- WRITTEN NOTICE
THAT IT PROVIDED ONE PATIENT.
CONTACT WITH THE PLANE. AND OR
IS IT. TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION BURKE AT THE POINT
OF CONTACT. EIGHTEEN DETAILS
MATTER I THINK THE TECH TO TELL
SERVICES AND PROVIDING A
VALUABLE BENEFIT ENROLLEES AND
INSURED. AND ONCE MAKES SURE
THAT THE PATIENT DID NOT
EXPERIENCE ANY DELAYED THERE
BEAR YOU'RE ACCESSING THAT
CARE. IN WHATEVER FORM OR
FORMAT IT MAY BE AND- THAT
BEING SAID WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
AND APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE
AND VALUE OF THE ESTABLISHED
DOCTOR PATIENT RELATIONSHIP.
AND HAVE NO DESIRE TO REPLACE
OR DISCOURAGE THAT
RELATIONSHIP. THE BENEFIT OF
THESE TYPES OF THIRD PARTY
TELEHEALTH SERVICES ARE REALLY
MEANT TO BE A COMPLIMENTARY
SERVICE. AND MANY OF US CAN I
HAVE NOTHING HAPPENED WITH
CHILDREN BETWEEN NORMAL
BUSINESS HOURS OF NINE TO FIVE.
AFFECTING ALTERNATES TELEHEALTH
SERVICES IT'S REALLY MEANT TO
BE AN ALTERNATE PATIENT
FRIENDLY OPTION THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS ALWAYS ENSURED. THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ACCESS CARE
WHEN THEY NEED IT. SINGLE PAYER
IF IT IS HAVE A LOT TAKE TIME
WORK TO SEE THAT THE ABOUT
MINOR CAR. BUT THE FIRST THING
MY WHO WANTS TO THE DOCTOR TAKE
A CO LOOK AT THEIR CHILD
THROUGH. THAT DOES NOT WANT TO
WAIT UNTIL THE- OFFICE OF IN
THE MORNING. YOU CAN JUST A FEW
EVERY DAY EXAM. OF THIRTY TELL
CARE PROVIDERS ALLOW CAN. AND
FAMILY AFTER TO GOOD. SERVICES
AT THE MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE-
THREE ARE NOT INTENDED NOR
SHOULD FAVORITE. THE TO. DRPH
RELATIONS. BUT INSTEAD OF THE
TO PROVIDE AND ALL. BOX THAT.
CO EXPECT WHEN ARE NEEDED. BUT
BACKING WE WOULD LIKE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
SPONSORED. FACTORS THAT THE MEN
YOU KNOW DEPEND PATE- SUPPOSED
SEEKING THESE TYPES OF SERVICE.
WITHOUT TO THINK THAT. PROTECT
AND ARE AVAILABLE TO. HE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO- TO
WITNESS IN SO. OR ARE. WILL
JUST BE ASKING YOUR NAME HERE
BECAUSE ON THE- AND ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT. SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER ROBERT RADER. IN
LATE IN GERMAN IF WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT TIMES. BEGIN
ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND AT THIS TIME WE
DO OF A DE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. HEY WILL SERVE A NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF HANSON
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS HERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SB NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING SHERMAN THOSE CALLS
WORSE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE A POSITION OF NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL BUT DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORED SPONSORS AS WELL
AS COMMITTEE FOR HIM WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS IN ADDITION- I WAS
UNABLE TO GET THROUGH- AS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF I THINK THE
NINE EIGHT EIGHT EARLIER IN THE
DAY. SONESTA COMMITTEE TAKE
THAT DOWN AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS GOING TO BE
NUMBER THREE NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KELLY
BEING ON BEHALF OF- HEALTH NET
AND CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
WELLNESS IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SEVEN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING AT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDED AND CRANK AND
WE CAN REEVALUATE OUR
CONDITIONS THEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE AND. SIX OF
THE NUMBER THREE NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER SHARON
MEMBERS BUT I THINK HE THAT
WOULD KEEP YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY. SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL NOW THE
NUMBER THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR CHER GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF DOC DOC DOC IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT IS NUMBER THREE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AS
CHAIR MEMBER JOHN WHEN YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS THEY HAVE AND
THE ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ADVAMED ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. OKAY THE NUMBER
THREE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CRAFTING
YANKING CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNMENT LIKE TO THANK
HIM THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR
EFFORTS SO FAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXUS
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT DONT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
DERMATOLOGY AND DERMATOLOGIC
SURGERY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND AGAIN
TO VOICE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN- I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS
THEN I'M GOING TO DIRECT THOSE
WANT TO THE SPONSORS AND WANT
TO THE OPPOSITION- JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION ALSO FOR THE-
SKEWS ME THE SPONSORS.
ULTIMATELY THE PATIENTS RIGHT
TO ACCESS HEALTHCARE SERVICES
VIA A THIRD PARTY TELEHEALTH
CORPORATION IS NOT TAKEN AWAY
IS THAT CORRECT. YES ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT ALL WERE SPEAKING TO DO
WITH THE SPELL OF THE I'M SORRY
THE PERSON DEALERS TìM I'VE
TALKED ABOUT. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT- THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH- DENYING PATIENT.
ACCESS THOSE SERVICES OR YOU
KNOW LIKE THOSE SERVICES IF
THEY HAVE THAT BEEFIT IT'S
REALLY JUST ABOUT ENSURING THAT
THE PATIENT HAS- THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THEM
TO MAKE. AN EDUCATED CHOICE IN
THEIR HEALTH CARE ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT THAT
TELEHEALTH APPOINTMENTS IF YOU
WITH A NETWORK PROVIDER OR WITH
A THIRD PARTY QUOTE RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND THEN I HAVE A QUESTION
TO THE OPPOSITION- WHAT DOES
YOUR DEMO. OF PATIENTS LOOK
LIKE DO YOU SEE A LOT OF MEN
PATIENTS THAT YOU BELIEVE WOULD
LOSE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. THE WITH DEFICIENCY
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE ACTUAL POTENTIAL
IMPACT WOULD BE ON MEDIC HOW-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT
WHAT THE DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE
MEMBERSHIP PAGE AND WE CAN WORK
WITH OUR VENDORS TO GET YOU
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT- BUT
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE WILL
BRING SO- ZERO WAS THERE A
MOTION AND THEN LET ME JUST IF
I CAN'T EVEN IF YOU CLICKED I
DID I JUST WANTED TO SAM TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I'M A
LITTLE BIT I'M GUESSING THIS IS
PROBABLY WHERE- WHERE- MY
COLLEAGUE OF WAS THAT SOME OF
HER CONCERN ESPECIALLY NOT IN
THE RURAL AREAS A TELEHEALTH-
IS REALLY HAS BEEN A LIFESAVER
BECAUSE- IT'S DIFFICULT TO BE
ABLE TO GET A TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO PROVIDER- IT'S ALSO
THE SAME FOR THE FOR THE CHAIR
IT AS WELL. ON THE WAY THAT I
SEE THIS BILL IS THAT IT
DOESN'T LIMIT LIMIT THAT MAKE
SURE THERE'S GOOD QUALITY CARE
AT THE OTHER END OF THE LINE
AND SO ALL THESE. BIG SUPPORT
OF THIS TODAY. EXACTLY THANK
YOU CAN I MAKE A MOTION. OKAY
THE MOTION SEVEN MOTION BY
MISTER MAY SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO- YES
SIGNATURE AND I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. LET ME BE VERY CLEAR
THAT I ALSO AM A BELIEVER
TELEHEALTH. AND THEN I WOULD
NOT CARRY BILL TO KILL
TELEHEALTH. IT BUT RATHER. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY HERE IS
THAT THERE IS. THAT IF. YOU
CALL- YOUR PROVIDER AND YOU
ASK. FOR TELEHEALTH IT YOU ARE.
TOLD THAT YOUR CURRENT DOCTOR-
IT. IS ALSO AVAILABLE IF THEY-
IF THEY PROVIDE TELEHEALTH. AT
THAT THAT'S SIMPLY. THE GOAL OF
DOING AND- WHAT WHEN I TOOK A
LOOK AT KANSAS BUILT. A LOT OF
IT HAD TO DO WITH THE WITH THE
CARE THAT MY AND THEN MY
CHILDREN WE SEE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THAT. AND I'VE I'VE SAID
THIS TO THE OPPOSITION AND- AND
WE'VE AGREED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK BECAUSE IT'S- ELIMINATION
NOT WORK TODAY. BUT THERE AT
THE HEAD THERE IS A TO BE SORT
OF A CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
BEING ABLE TO. HAVE FILES AND
RECORDS- IN THAT YOUR DOCTOR
HAS IF YOU HAVE IF YOU HAVE A
DISEASE. SO IT IS SO IF YOU. IF
YOUR CURRENT DOCTOR. OR YOUR.
OR YOUR CURRENT- PROVIDER. HEY
THE ABILITY TO TELEHEALTH
SHOULD KNOW. AND YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CHOOSE WHETHER YOU YOU
GO THEIR CURRENT- WITH THE KERN
DOCTOR COME. AND I THINK THAT'S
CRITICAL BECAUSE- RECORDS WOULD
BE KEPT. CONTINUITY OF CARE
WILL BE KEPT AND ULTIMATELY
QUALITY OF CARE WOULD BE
CAPPED. AND THE AMENDMENTS-
SEEK TO CLARIFY. THAT WE ARE
NOT TAKING AWAY THAT WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MAKE IT A LITTLE SONG
AND I ALSO HAD. AND IT'S BEEN A
LONG MEETING ALSO ADDED IN
URBAN AREAS TELEHEALTH HAS NOW
BECOME MORE IMPORTANT AS WELL.
BECAUSE IN. BECAUSE BECAUSE-
DURING KOBE WE FOUND OUT THAT.
BASIC SERVICES LIKE-
PHARMACEUTICAL REFILLS- BASIC
CHECKUPS COULD BE DONE VIA
TELEHEALTH SO THEY BECOME A LOT
MORE IMPORTANT- TO URBAN AREAS
AS THEY WERE. AS THEY ARE
IMPORTANT- TO RURAL AREAS AND I
RESPECTFULLY WITH US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS SALTY.
SO WE DO A MOTION THE SECOND-
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT HI WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NONVOTING BONTA BURKE
BURKE CARRILLO. CORREO AYE
FLORA. FLORIDA VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ HI
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON WALDRON I. SENATOR YOUR
BILL IS OUT MR SANTIAGO. RT FOR
A MINUTE I WILL SEE IF I COULD
GET ARE. THE. YES- CORRECT ME
IF. THE TEST. THIS MCCARTY YOU
ARE UP TO YOU HAVE AB FOURTEEN
FORTY THREE. WE HAVE A MOTION%
BY MISS BURKE A SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS A AT DISTRICT
BILL WOULD HAVE STATEWIDE
SIGNIFICANCE- THAT THAT'S THE
WRONG FOLDER HELLO. EVEN IT'S.
NO A GREAT SPEECH I HAVE A
PHENOMENAL SPEECH PREPARED
REMARKS TO BE ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES THAT OKAY YOUR YOUR
BREVITY WOULD BE MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU THIS IS A
AB THAT'S A DISTRICT BILL BY MY
CITY OF SACRAMENTO BUT IT'S A
BIG ISSUE IT'S ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT BEING CALLED OUT
FOR MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE-
CALLS WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
TIMES- TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES AS A
RESULT IN HAVING MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND HEALTH CARE EXPERTS
INTERVENING AS OPPOSED TO- LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD REALLY PEACE
OFFICERS AND ALSO- FRANKLY THE
GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY SO THIS
BILL. WOULD WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP TRAINING
AND POLICIES TO ALLOW A MOBILE
CRISIS TEAMS TO RESPOND TO
THESE CALLS- WITH ME IS THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO TO TESTIFY-
THEY WILL MENTION OF A ONE
UNBELIEVABLE HERE LAST YEAR
THAT WE HAD OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND CALLS FOR SERVICE
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH CRISES
AND SO THIS WHAT- ENABLE US TO
MAKE OUR COMMUNITY SAFER AND HE
MORE STRATEGIC. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE TO
WITNESSES I OR JUST JUST ONE
JUST ONE JUST WEST OF THE CITY
SECOND OKAY- MR OPERATOR WHEN
THE WITNESSES READY PLEASE
HAVING GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS- CONTROL HERNANDEZ THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO- I'M STEPPING INTO
BRIDGES DEAN HAS BEEN DIRECTOR
OF OUR NEW DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY RESPONSE IN THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS VERY PER EACH. LAST
YEAR THE SACRAMENTO CITY
COUNCIL DIRECTED STAFF TO
CREATE AN ALTERNATE RESPONSE
MODEL FOR NINE ONE ONE CALLS
THAT DON'T REQUIRE POLICE
OFFICER RESPONSE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED ONE KEY AREA
FOR CITY IS CALLS FOR SERVICE
RELATED TO MENTAL ILLNESS FIFTY
ONE FIFTY HOLE- WE HAVE
OBSERVED HOW THE TRAINING AND
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT. STAFF TO WRITE
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES AND TRANSPORT
PEOPLE TO AN APPROPRIATE
FACILITY IF THESE BECAUSE
PROCESSING. AND APPROVAL-
DIFFER FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY-
THEY'RE CURRENTLY PERMITTED FOR
COUNTIES WITHOUT MANY
GUIDELINES- AND THEREFORE WE
SHOULD BE DIFFERENT I'M
AVAILABILITY OF TREATMENT YOU
HAVE TRAININGS AND WILLINGNESS
TO APPROVE STAFF- EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE WOULD
CLARIFY AND PROVIDE
PREDICTABILITY OF THE COUNTY'S
APPROVAL PROCESS. WHICH IS
REALLY CRITICAL AS WE AND OTHER
CITIES MOVE TOWARDS ALTERNATIVE
RESPONSE MODELS TO BETTER
BETTER RESPOND TO PEOPLE IN
NEED- I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WHAT WE HAVE I BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SO
THERE IS A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION SO I THE OPPOSITION
BACK TO TESTIFY PLEASE. GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING CHAIR WHAT
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS TIRING
THE WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RECORD WITH PROBATION
THE BAFTA IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN FORTY THREE
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR FOR THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION THE DATE AND
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN COME TO AN
AGREEABLE RESOLUTION ON THE
BALLOT CONVERSATION CONTINUE WE
AGREE WITH THAT BONTA ON
AUTHORED CONTENT INTO FIRE TO
HAVE THE VIDEO SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL LOT MOBILE CRISIS
TEAM TO BECOME DESIGNATED TO
WRITE FIFTY ONE FIFTIES IN JULY
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CHALLENGE THE SPONSORED
EXPERIENCING CAN BE RESOLVED
UNDER EXISTING LAW AND WITH
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
OUR ASSOCIATION THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY TOP AND-
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU KNOW THINK
THAT OTHERS OFFICE FOR THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES ASK FOR WITH
OTHER OTHER TESTIMONY JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT.
ONE SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MISTER OPERATOR. IN LATE JULY
MEN TO SUPPORT- OPPOSITE. FOUR
EIGHT FORTY FORTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME I'M NOT SEEN ANY JOIN
OUR QUEUE. OF RIGHT BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE MISTER RODRIGUEZ. FOR
QUESTION I THINK FOR THE-
PERSON TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
SORRY JUST QUICK QUESTION SO
WHEN YOU CALL NINE ONE ONE
THOSE CRISIS MOBILIZING TEAMS
WILL BE. RESPONDING TO THE
CALLS AND WRITING THE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY ON. ARE THE PATIENT
CORRECT AND IF SO WHO WILL BE
TRANSPORTING THE PATIENT TO I
GUESS IN THIS CASE. A MENTAL
FACILITY WOULD THAT BE A LOCAL
FIRE DEPARTMENT OR THEY'LL BE
CONTRACTED WITH A- PRIVATE
AGENCY OR WERE THEY TRANSPORTED
TO THE SHELVES. ALL ALL ANSWER
THAT QUESTION- I THINK THE GOAL
OF THIS CRISIS TEAM IS TO
REPLACE. THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
FOR RESPONDING BUT IF THERE IS
A NEED TO TAKE SOMEBODY TO THE
HOSPITAL WOULD BE THE LOCAL.
PARAMEDICS HERE SO INSIDIOUS
SACRAMENTO WE DON'T CONTRACT
WITH ANOTHER OUTSIDE AGENCY
IT'S THE CITY OF. SACRAMENTO'S
FIRE DEPARTMENT THAT HAS THAT.
PARAMEDIC UNIT. I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE NOTION THAT THAT
PART WOULDN'T CHANGE INSTANCE
THE REPLACEMENT OF THE SWORN
PEACE OFFICER. I FELT. IT IS
THAT CORRECT AND MR NANDO'S.
YES YES THAT IS CORRECT WHERE
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE THESE
SITUATIONS BE DE ESCALATED AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND THEN HAVE
TRAINED YOU KNOW MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THOSE PEOPLE TAKE
IN SOMEBODY BUT IF THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL NEED FIX A CHANGE
THE DANGEROUS SITUATION OR
SOMEBODY HAS HEALTH ISSUES THAT
REQUIRE CENTS NEMS RESPONSE
THEN WE WOULD STILL USE THOSE-
THAT PERSONNEL. OKAY ALL RIGHT
VERY WELL- SO THAT'S SO THIS
SEE WE HAVE A- MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE'VE TAKEN ALL
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY I THINK-
WE WILL- ASK IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE EARLY THANK YOU ASK YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SECRETARY- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHAT I WHAT I MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I. BONTA. BURKE. BURKE
I CARILLO CARILLO I LARA
FLUORIDE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY
I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RIVAS HI RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO
MISTER MCCARTY YOUR BILL IS OUT
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
SO WE WILL NOW GO TO THE TOP OF
THE FILE ORDER AND WE'LL GO
THROUGH THIS- I KNOW WE HAVE AN
OFFER WE HAVE SOMEONE MISSING
SO- MR BONTA STILL AROUND IN
THE CAPITAL COULD LIKE COME. WE
DO HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE US SO
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. BY THIS PARA QUE
HAN PLEASE. LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BONTA
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN HI SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WALDRON I WALDRON NOW. IT'S TO
NINETY TWO THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER TWO ELEVEN AND
FOURTEEN OR THE OR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THAT'S AB. TEN FIFTY
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
AND EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS A MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHT P. FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
FONG. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE SANTIAGO NOT NOT VOTING NOT
VOTING I'M SORRY MAIENSCHEIN
NOT VOTING. SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WALDRON I. IT'S TWELVE ZERO
TWELVE ZERO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS A. B. TEN TWENTY
FRIEDMAN. MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING. BURKE BURKE I FLORA.
LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I SANTIAGO. STRO
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
GABRIEL PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MATHIS
MAYES I. BURKE BURKE I LARA
FLOOR NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
TWELVE TO TWO FOR THE TWO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. TEN THIRTY
EIGHT MISTER GIBSON PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MATHIS. MAYES I. BONTA
BURKE BURKE I FLORA LAURA HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
RIVAS RIVAS I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. TWELVE TO ONE TWELVE TO ONE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
ONE IRWIN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FOR MOM
ONE MOMENT HERE. I'M SORRY. WAS
IT WAS I WRONG. ON TEN THIRTY
EIGHT IT WAS THIRTEEN A ONE
THIRTEEN ONE OKAY I'M SORRY. SO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
CARRILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA LARA
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
REVERSE REVERSE I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT IRWIN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA. LARA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
NAZARIAN. THIS AREA I REQUEST
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO III
BONTA BONTA HIGH FIFTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
THREE SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR COM
LONGER PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES
AS I. BONTA BONTA I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE MAYBE THIRTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MR LOW PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES MAYES I. BONTA BONTA AYE
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I IN THIS AREA. THIS AREA I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB FIVE FORTY FIVE IS
PETRIE-NORRIS PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I. BONTA BONTA
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
BY MISTER TEEN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I. BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE BURKE I. MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN PLEASE LIF THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE APPROVED WHAT. MAYES
MAYES NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I. BONTA BONTA I.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. WALDRON NO. THIRTEEN
AT TWO THIRTEEN TO PLAY I'M
SORRY THIRTEEN A ONE THIRTEEN
ONE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE MCCARTY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE IS AREA PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA BONTA I'M MAIENSCHEIN.
MASON I MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
FIFTEEN ZERO FIFTEEN SERVICE
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB TWELVE
OH SEVEN PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES.
BONTA BONTA I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB SIX SIXTY
TWO BY MR RODRIGUEZ PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES. BIGELOW. BIGELOW
I. BONTA. BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY ARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON. WALDRON I.
FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU AND
THEN FINALLY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
SANTIAGO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BONTA
BONTA HI LARA WAS VERY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN THIRTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO- VOTE
CHANGE MR MCCARTY WHICH BILL.
OR MANY MORE. I AM NUMBER FOUR
A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR FONG
MR MCCARTY CHANGING HIS VOTE
FROM I TO KNOW. MCCARTY ITEM NO.
ELEVEN TWO ONE ONE TWO ONE OKAY
THANK YOU. I THINK. YEAH WE
NEED TO GO BACK THROUGH I THINK
THERE'S SOME. SO GO BACK TO- GO
BACK TO THE TOP I THINK WE'RE
WEEK WE'VE GONE THROUGH
EVERYTHING I THINK YOU GUYS I
THINK. PARDON ALSO YOU HAD WE
DID THE CONSENT ALSO- BUT I
CALLED- THAT WILL GIVE YOU A
CALL OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
CONSECUTIVE. BONTA BONTA I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO HI. FIFTEEN
ZERO. I AM THREE WAS WAS- NOT
HEARD TODAY WAS PULLED.
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. FOURTEEN A
FOR FONG. DID YOU. OVER ALL
START AT THE TOP OF HIS GO BACK
SIX I THINK THERE'S MR BONTA
NEEDS TO ADD ON AS WELL CHANGE
SO LET'S GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA I.
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO. ELEVEN TO
TWO SEVENTY TWO AND THEN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WE JUST
WENT THROUGH EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR
FONG PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SANTIAGO
SUTTER BY TWELVE TO ONE THE ONE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE MAYBE TEN
TWENTY FRIEDMAN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI THIRTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO GABRIEL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THERE WERE NO
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE KNOWN- A
NIGHT OF NUMBER SEVEN WHETHER
ANY OF THE MEMBERS. BONTA BONTA
I ITEM NUMBER EIGHT THAT'S
FOURTEEN TO ONE FOURTEEN ONE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT- PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BONTA BONTA HI FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER NINE PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
NO ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB THREE SIXTY NINE OVER
THE ROAR OF EMBER SNOW. I
REMEMBER TWELVE NO. FEATHER
RIVER THIRTEEN NO M. NUMBER.
FIFTEEN WELL SAID NUMBER
SIXTEEN NOW AT A MEMBER
SEVENTEEN. NOW I REMEMBER.
EIGHTEEN NOW ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN. MAYES. THIRTEEN ZERO
STILL NOT HERE NO. I REMEMBER
TWENTY MAYES NOT HERE FOURTEEN
ZERO IN AN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. NAPS
ARE MEMBERS I THAT'S IT THAT'S
A WRAP- WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE
THE WE WILL END THE HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO OUR OPERATOR
IF HE'S STILL AROUND. THIS IS
NOT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYWAY.